With over 4,000 players attending the
regional qualifier in Utrecht, there are
plenty of different categories of
players represented. Young, old,
experienced veterans, and fresh
recruits. After day one completion, we
have two undefeated first-timers remain
for day two.
>> What made me like
make the decision to come into Reborn
specifically was the friends, right? And
the community
because people I know were bought into
it. They are hyped on it. And I like to
have people that travel with me like and
then we we come here together. I thought
there is a chance for me to make day
two,
but I thought realistically I was
thinking I am at 5-3 level of skill. 6-2
was possible, and there was no way in
the hell I thought I was ever going to
make like 7-1 or 8-0 or whatever.
>> After finishing my degree like 1 year
ago, I didn't really play anything at
all. And then I finished my degree in
July, and I was like, "Hey, this is a
perfect chance to start a TCG. So,
what's coming up? There's Reborn." I
played leagues in season two. I wanted
to get into trading card game. I noticed
that I'm still quite competitive. Try to
improve on myself, keep improving, and I
and somehow ended up here.
>> There's been a lot of talk about
managing energy and nerves. But what was
that like for them at their first
multi-day tournament?
>> To prepare even for the event, I play a
fair amount of skirmishes at my
regionals like first TCG good store in
Bremen. All of the guys are really cool,
so I won like four skirmishes. So I
think I was like getting on the level. I
also met some people that participated
in previous like skirmish like regional
qualifiers like Eric, and they gave me
quite confidence that I at least have
chance to make day two. That was also my
bare minimum. I wanted to make day two.
I did apparently make day two and even
maybe higher. So hopefully maybe top 64.
Everything else I think I think they're
quite good players around here and
always draw of the luck, but let's see
where it goes.
>> Playing with this many unfamiliar
players can feel like a big step up from
playing in your local Nexus night.
This is how they experienced playing at
the regional qualifier tables.
>> So I'm not that nervous around crowds
and with the more I was able to play
better like when I the confidence grew
it was getting more and more like
looking into the game.
>> I probably will be nervous playing on
stage, yes. Well, when I get there, yes.
I mean it's just stage jitters. I assume
I I'm not like I'm not immune to it,
right? So yeah. I'm not in my regular
job on my regular day. I don't let that
myself on stage, right? So yeah.
>> At one point you will be nervous at the
beginning, but the more the game goes
on, the more you will look in hopefully
and just focus on yourself, focus on
your place, focus on your opponents, and
just try to play the best game, and
hopefully not fumble up on stage.
>> Honestly, I think the best way for me to
manage will be like focusing on the
gameplay, right? And then ignoring
everything around me. So, if I'm just
trying to play the best I can, that will
be on my mind like probably that I will
try to put in my mind right to help me
focus.
>> I must say everyone I played against was
so nice. So, I really, really felt
welcome. So, from like the more casual
player playing Jin
to the best of Kazex, June, who was so
cool that we had such a nice talk during
the game. I felt like the atmosphere,
the vibe was really there.
And then I also see some amazing people
that you only see like in or like think
you see in like video like LNCQ or Colin
who I had like very nice chats with.
They're all very, very, very, very cool
guys.
>> Everywhere like people were welcome and
people here are also specially like
really friendly. Everybody like likes to
meet people from other countries, from
other regions, see their stories, see
how they're doing.
>> So, if you're still in doubt about
attending a regional qualifier for
yourself, just listen to the advice from
these successful starters.
>> I think like these cities in general and
especially like like they found and
these larger cities are really good like
opportunities for people to travel
together, also like to compete if they
are really competitive, for people to
also experience other cultures and other
people in person, right? You can compete
on online, you can compete play online
games, but that is not it. Like for me
like playing in person has a different
feeling like you are hanging out with
people. Like there is some social
context here, some enjoyment that you
experience just for being here around
like all those thousands of people
around you. It in itself is a good
feeling.
Performance-wise,
it's like even if you completely fail,
it should it will still be good.
>> I think if you want to play serious,
it's definitely manageable. But you just
have to put in some of the hours, some
of the work into it. So, it's not just
playing out games for 50 hours and maybe
like improve little by little. Take
advantage of resources. Take advantage
of the YouTube videos. Take advantage of
like the ability to replay stuff. I
think everyone can make it and I wish
everyone best of luck.
>> So,
I will encourage people to
to push themselves out of their comfort
zone, right? It's you for me as well.
Not for the I want to get better because
I was there. Yeah, that's going to
happen, too. But, for like the enjoyment
of everything that's going to happen,
right?
>> For me, this was like dipping my feet a
bit into the water. So, seeing where I
stand and I will try and from now on
take with me every regional qualifier
that's possible, maybe even the regional
if I get top 64.
>> But, if you are on the verge
be sure that's going to be true. It's
going to be like
you'll be nervous. It's going to be
iffy.
Uh but, at the end when all is settled
and done, you're going to be very glad
that you went.
>> So, what are you still waiting for? Get
yourself signed up for the following
regional qualifiers. Join in on the
action and I will see you there.
>> Wait, you're all coming to my locals,
Bandit? You'll see me at my locals? I'm
ready for that.
>> I've been waiting for months. I got a
sleeping bag. I'm underneath the bushes.
>> You are welcome in Brighton with my crew
anytime in the UK. Shout out to my crew
here in the venue. Originally, I was
supposed to be playing with them.
They've been like they're on a tear.
Some of my my locals actually are like
top four in the 2v2 tournament today and
I'm like, "THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN ME!
THAT SHOULD have been me!"
>> Instead, you big-timed them the first
opportunity you got.
>> like, "You're out of that. I got a
different spot."
>> Yeah, we're good friends, but
>> So, those of you that have watched IQs
will know that as we go from the Swiss
round to the top eight, we do have to
make sure that everything is in order
for all of our players that have made it
through that. And that is why for us, we
will be taking you through just some of
the the overview of the weekend. Some of
the things that have caught our eye, the
things that are most interesting to us.
I will say what we do have for the top
eight is quite a treat because it is
eight unique legends.
>> It is honestly I I can't remember the
last time we've seen it. Is this the
first time ever?
Because if it's not, then you should
remember and keep it dear because
the odds of it transpiring and also not
uh
spoil too much which legends made it. I
I was dumbfounded.
>> Yeah, we we have of course seen a few
different things. As the bracket gets
populated and as everything gets put
together, we will of course give you the
walk through everything about our top
eight cut. And that is what they're
playing for here, regional qualifier,
the first place trophy here in Utrecht.
Um there's more obviously
being
uh distributed to our winners of best
top prizes. That means we have eight
best tops that we can tell you as soon
as the bracket is up. These are all the
best of that legend here this weekend.
Um top 64 of course has been solidified
as well. Those standings will be
available online after the end of the
Swiss Swiss portion for those of you
that are tracking your players in in the
top 64. That includes that's all
important slot at regionals later in the
year. So everybody's been playing for
that. Uh and you know, you will be able
to as well. We're talking about local
play on
uh uh step a slightly wider. Of course,
the showdown series events were
announced. So if there is one local to
you as well, get over there. Those big
events are another way of getting to a
regional championships.
>> And to me that is kind of like cuz it
always kind of feels bad when someone
does make top cut and then doesn't get
the best of. It feels like you've gotten
so far. Like but yes, we will grant you
a top eight entry, but you will not be
recognized as best of. So
>> Not this time around.
>> Not this time around. And we've teased
you enough before showing you the
bracket. Let's take a look at our top
eight bracket of the legends being
played and those piloting them. Uh
One of the big surprises is we look
right at the first row. So, Squirtle
undefeated has been incredibly good
here. Our RQ Leal champion defending
their title on European soil. Uh and
Prismatistism is the player that has
made it through in eighth seed. The
tiebreakers that Prismatistism had put
him through on 10 and two.
>> Beating all of the odds. I had in my
mind already set farewell
>> Same.
>> to Prismatistism as he lost his his
second series. But, that is just the
importance of losing against the best.
There's one 10 and two in Shurima. The
odds are abysmal unless you're called
Prismatistism.
>> And of course, we had to look at taking
that match up for our featured match.
That is where we'll be directing our
eyes. Second
match of the quarterfinals is Collin on
the set against Bacur who we saw a
little bit earlier on the Master Yi.
We'll see who makes it forward from that
match up.
Rameciano on the Rex Sai against Red
Naxel on Victor. That is not a match up
that if anybody had said, "Hey, are you
expecting a Rex Sai and a Victor in top
eight to to clash against each other?"
And everything else is unique too. No
one would have guessed that.
>> I I'm so excited to have this match up
play out. It does however mean we're
going to have to say goodbye to one of
them. And I kind of want both of them to
stay in. But, that goes for 90% of
>> this top cut.
>> Exactly. And and one of the other things
we track all the time is the teams that
are performing of course that we've
we've talked about them a few times.
Misellion having multiple players in
this top eight as Diamond Hat is going
to be piloting the Darius up against
Duwali's Diana. So, Diana did end up
sneaking through right at the end. I
know that we were keeping our eyes on on
the champions and how they would make it
through.
The rainbow of colors. I mean, it's only
appropriate this month to have quite
such a nice spread of legends
represented from the each domain.
>> And the reason why I am kind of
flabbergasted at the the top eight is
because I had been reassured time and
time again that Fury was not a good
domain. You could kind of dismiss it.
Yet, three out of the the top eight
decks have Fury in them. But, what's
even more, Order in five out of eight.
>> Order's broken. Ban it all. Reaction
re-comments.
>> Chaos, I think in the next set we need
some extra strong Chaos cards cuz I
think we need the top eight.
>> Yeah, I think we need to print some
more, actually. That'd be good. Yeah,
let's let's see some good ones. But,
that's a very fair point. It So much of
the conversation coming into a
tournament like this is like what's
what's very strong, what you have to
watch out for. And so much of it does
still from the community sentiment
filter through the lens of Chaos being
very strong, but not necessarily
performing this event.
>> And that is I think the one point that I
want to reiterate still. When you come
to a regional qualifier, when you play
Rift Runeterra, it is not about
following the meta and what it sets out.
It's about playing comfort, playing the
deck that you know how to play best,
that you can get through any situation
out in front of you any day of the year.
Comfort and familiarity will outperform
a meta deck.
>> And I think it's one of the things as
well that sentiment does take quite a
long time to shift. We I
I think people still have the memories
of pre-ban phase uh
Draven and and how people anticipated
playing against Draven and really hated
it even without sitting down at the
table to play against it very often. And
I think that's stuck around even even
with the changes that we've had. And now
we're actually seeing this this I'm so
happy it's eight unique legends cuz we
get to see that like you can literally
just refine, practice, and end up in a
top eight if you're good enough on
whatever legend you choose.
>> For me, when I'm looking at, all right,
what will be next afterwards?
It really comes down to me as
this proves that you can make anything.
We've seen Jin, which has been rated D
tier time and time and time again,
make a very impressive run. And the
creativity that is out there, it just
goes to show that rarely ever is a meta
truly solved.
>> Yeah, exactly. We saw Jibbs from Rift
Labs on stream yesterday piloting the
Jin doing very well. I would love to see
where they actually ended up. I know
there were a couple of of tough losses
actually meeting Colin at a
the next round after playing on stream,
which is like nightmare fuel at that
point. Another champion and legend
combination that we saw earlier today,
in fact, just before we came to us was
Villianaire on the Aurora just missing
out on that top eight spot, but still
such a strong performance.
>> I will say it to to to catch back on on
Set going up against Jin.
That's kind of in character, right? That
the jock is is beating up on the theater
kid.
>> As a as a somewhat theater kid, I'm not
happy with that analogy.
I don't like that. Were you the were you
the jock in high school? Is that it?
>> Yeah, I no, not even a little bit.
>> Got to ask. You never know. People
people's history, you meet all kinds of
people at an RQ. That was the entire
point of the the video we showed you.
And if you are on your journey, you can
go, as you said, local game stores is
where it starts. And at the end of it,
you could very well be making top eight
at an RQ.
>> I I think it's time for a rematch.
>> You do?
>> I do think it's time for for some
guessing of flavors.
>> No.
>> Because you have yet to prove yourself.
>> Don't do that to me.
>> You have yet to proven yourself.
>> No.
We can't. Yeah, it's okay. I'm I'm I'm
I'm
surprised I'm exaggerating. Yeah, it
happens quite a lot. Let's take a look
at, as we said, a couple of minutes
before we get into our actual top eight
games. I think it's really important to
know that there's there's a lot of
administration that the judges have to
get through for a top eight. So, we like
to buy them the time that they need.
>> That is totally fair. I've personally
sabotaged them so that we could play
Guess the Flavor.
>> Uh do we sabotage even though I never
read the flavor text?
>> Haste lays waste. It
>> Is Dr. Seuss?
>> Um I mean, my mind immediately shoots
out to Karthus.
>> Overly waste. I like it. I like it.
>> But I think it's like something like oh
your death shall be well
>> I I'm in two minds. I mean, it's either
an accelerate card or it's like
something as you said about laying waste
like
>> I think it's not Karthus though cuz I I
feel like if I would see that, I would
recognize it. Um who out there still
still racing?
>> Oh, that's
>> Who is death behind?
>> I'm trying to think I
I'm why can I not I mean, when in doubt
I'm just going to personally look
Karthus.
>> You're going to like Karthus.
>> There there is a line. Even though I
don't feel great, I also don't trust
myself on this topic. So, I shouldn't
listen to myself.
>> I'm trying to remember what the card's
called and I even play it. It's
>> You can describe the art.
>> it's the fury card that nobody plays but
people tried to play in Kaizen for a
little bit with the accelerate. It's
like a low cost unit that you can pay
>> Oh, the one from Noxus.
>> Legionnaire.
>> Um Noxus Legionnaire.
>> Noxus Legionnaire. I'll say Noxus
Legionnaire.
>> So, we got Karthus, Noxus Legionnaire.
Let's see. Haste lays waste.
Ah Fury Ritemaker.
>> Close enough.
>> Yeah, Sudden Storm. In fact, this is a
card that every so often creeps into a
deck list
and everyone goes, wait this card
exists? Hang on a second. What do you
mean that there's a
damage spell that that works in this
way? It's pretty cool. It's actually not
too bad. I mean, and we never see it but
>> Want to you want to you want to rate the
flavor? Is that Is that like a storm?
>> I I'll I'll be honest, that one I
I I think our choices were better.
>> It rhymes. It rhymes.
>> It does.
>> is like two points extra.
>> Yeah, okay. That that's fair. I think I
I like our choices better than than
Sudden Storm. Sorry, design team.
>> Can we errata those?
>> If smashing doesn't work, just keep
smashing. This has going to be Poppy,
right? This is going to be a Poppy
direction.
>> Yes. How
>> The
The problem is I can't remember other
than Keeper's Verdict. Oh, which isn't a
bite.
Okay, it could be, but it does more
punching. Like punch first, ask
questions while punching.
>> I I actually kind of like Poppy. And if
I don't think we're going to get get up
with something better.
>> Okay.
>> Poppy.
>> I can't remember what Poppy's subtitle
is. So, I'm going to say the
I'm being told it's not Poppy. Which
means I'm doing a terrible job at Guess
the Flavor. At least you at home can can
just berate me in chat.
>> All right, but what what what what what
is still smashing out there?
>> Other than the pumpkins.
Which for music fans,
you got that.
I I Okay.
>> All right, so I think like Mundo could
work here.
>> I'm
I'm it it we we going like the large
like if smashing kind of Are we saying
big strength? Is it like Volibear or
something like that? Like Volibear
imposing?
>> Could it be
>> Could be Primal Strength, yeah.
>> I'm going to lock Primal Strength.
>> Okay, I'll go Volibear imposing. I don't
know.
I'm getting all of these wrong.
>> Yeah, we're guessing. That is the game.
>> That is That is actually Well, that
makes sense.
Uh Na is not in the game yet, but always
a fan of Na.
>> That is I'm I'm I'm going to claim half
a point on that.
Just cuz
>> Na does feature on Primal Strength.
>> You're right, yeah. I'll give you half a
point. That's fine. That you can have a
half a point on that.
>> I I am now in charge of how the points
go. So, let's see.
>> As long as you're not in charge of
making up the rules.
>> Well, if if Let's do an all or nothing
on the last one, right?
How How Exactly. Let's let's see. I
think we have one more, I hope. Cuz if
we do, this is this is for all the
proverbial marbles.
Half mute, half fish, all nuisance. I
feel I feel like I should know this.
I feel like I should know this.
>> I feel like you should also know that.
Based on nothing.
>> Yeah, I'm
It's It's the problem is being again
being around the game and the lore for
so long and not absorbing any of it is
really not good for this.
>> That's why I insisted on
>> Ask me random questions about 2015
circuit EU LCS and I the the knowledge
is up there somewhere.
>> But you ask me about half league info
then name everyone on Taipei Assassins.
>> Ah, yeah, okay. No, I said 2015. That
was
>> 4 2015. That's 2013, right?
My bad. That's on me. That just goes to
show that I'm a fake fan.
>> Yeah, yeah. Thank you. That was the
trick question. I got you. I got you.
>> Got me twice.
>> Half mute, half fish, all nuisance.
>> All right, who's half fish?
Fizz is half a fish, but he's not half a
mute.
>> Yeah, but he is a nuisance. You know
what? It could be Fizz Trickster. In
which case
>> lock it in.
>> Okay, yeah. I'm with you actually. Fizz
Trickster does make sense.
>> So so much for all the marbles.
Going out as a team.
Show me Fizz.
>> Half mute It's half fish. It's half
mute. Yeah.
>> Okay. All right.
>> We had all the pieces. This one is on
us.
>> That that one is on us. Although Fizz I
I just never read to the bottom anyway.
I I need to start reading the full card.
Which you know at Nexus night Nexus
night when I when I I pick up a card I'm
actually going to read out loud the
flavor text now.
>> James, I barely read the actual rules on
the card
let alone the flavor. But I've been told
>> more.
>> There's it's like the quadruple or
nothing at this point. One more. One
more to go.
>> Just goes to show that we have a true
Aurora player among us.
>> Just one to
>> You know what? The next one is
definitely
>> Oh. Oh, no, but this is actually a voice
line. Places to go, people to gank. This
is actually a voice line for the game,
isn't it?
I can hear it. I can hear it in my Could
Could it be Pit Crew?
Oh, why do I think this is champion
voice line?
>> I hear it in my ear.
>> Same. And it it feels like a Vi line,
but I Vi has too many other lines that
have been used.
>> Yeah. I I I I think it's only the first
line, anyway. Like, "People to gang"
sounds like an old Akali line before her
update.
>> I'm trying to think.
>> If you just go through it, who likes to
gang? Who that is still out there?
>> Maybe it's not a champion, actually.
Maybe that's too obvious.
>> Yeah, but that's what they want you to
think, James.
>> That is. That is. But I'm I'm
>> That is would be very difficult to trip
us up with a
with a double bluff.
>> I'm trying to go as far down like the
avenues of lore as possible.
>> It's not Yi.
>> I I
>> I think that's fair to say.
>> I think it's
weirdly
a lot of these voice lines like this,
I'm like, they're very like
>> "Who likes to move around?" Something
like thinking Rengar, Kha'Zix. They are
like way more intense.
>> Maybe
maybe like the I I I feel like it's like
going the the the seafaring way. Like,
that kind of way. For some reason,
that's like the voice line in my head.
>> I'm going to I'm I'm I'm going to force
us to a decision.
>> Oh oh oh oh.
>> Oh, no.
>> Hang on a second. I think I have it.
>> Oh, dear.
You say it first, and then I'll join
you.
>> No. No, that's not how that works. All
the marbles are on the line.
>> What's What happened to my first guess?
>> want to put a booster on the line?
>> I have
Not even a little bit, but I guess I
have to.
>> bit? What? You backing down?
>> But what if we both miss out?
Then we have to get a booster for each
other.
>> And then we swap.
>> Yeah.
>> And then hope that the other one is
>> have to bless it.
>> Okay. So, fist bump on a booster on the
line? Okay.
>> Three.
>> Two.
>> One.
>> Well
>> What was that? What was that? GIVE ME
SHOW ME THE CARD. Show me the card.
Yeah!
Nailed it. I got it. I got it. The one
card I've ever read.
>> moment and you perfect moment.
>> Yeah, I'm gone. I don't need to do
finals anymore.
>> Honestly, this is This is probably the
the storyline I'll I'll steal for top
eight.
>> Yeah, this is it. This is more
interesting.
>> for prismacism
cuz you know he never peaked before of
course.
>> Now he finally now he has to show up.
>> I'm looking forward to collecting on
that booster. I'm I'm looking forward to
it.
>> Actually, I hope you pull something
good.
I'll feel so good about
>> And you know what? If we do we can when
you come to the locals we'll share it
and then next time I see you I'll take
it you
>> Honestly
>> No, I'll I'll give it to you and then
I'll take it back and then we'll give it
to you every time we see each other we
>> confident saying that but I actually
will be in Brighton this year.
>> Oh, okay. Cool. Yeah, yeah, come over.
My my local's lovely.
Um I'm
>> I'll bring my deck. That will be a lot
of fun.
>> Yeah, no, it's great. Um
>> Unexpected. I love that.
>> I don't know whether I'm allowed to say
a particular shop but no, I have
multiple shops in town that are all
lovely. So
>> We should go to all of the shops.
I love all the shops.
>> If you're in and around the southeast of
the UK there's some lovely local
>> decide. I'm I'm sure people have lovely
local game stores all over your place
and love your local game store as well.
Love us here at
the game
>> turned this into us making plans.
>> I know.
Straight. Like
do you want to send me a calendar link?
We can
>> Uh guys, can we hold on for top eight a
little longer? We're not done setting a
date yet.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly. It's
definitely not looking at two regional
qualifier champions about to face off
against each other. Definitely not like
one of the highest profile matches we've
ever seen
at least here European
>> I'm I'm I'm going to push you to a
decision.
>> Okay. Cool.
>> We had a top eight where it's in
it's hard to pick who's the most legend
in there.
>> Yeah.
>> But I'm going to push you to a decision.
Who is the most unexpected legend in
this top eight?
>> The most unexpected legend. I got to say
for me it kind of feels like Victor.
>> You have Victor less expected than
Volibear?
>> Um
>> Did Volibear not make it?
>> I think Volibear didn't make it. Just as
a reminder
so it is Azir, Annie, Sett, Master Yi,
Rek'Sai, Victor,
Diana
>> Oh, they missed out Braum.
>> Braum, Darius, Darius. They missed out
Braum, yeah.
Good one.
>> Nice, yeah.
That's what they call natural talent.
>> Okay.
Then I would say actually say reviewing
the list, Darius.
>> I
Am I more surprised by Viktor?
>> That's a good question, but I think that
Viktor has historically had some players
here like Ghost to Driver here. However,
>> Wonder no longer.
>> Let's focus in. Let's take us right into
our first deck profile, our eight-seed
player.
>> So, it is a bit unfortunate that I think
all of the Annies we featured on stream
have lost.
>> Yeah.
>> How is this one different into Azir?
Because that is a very different
match-up.
>> Well, first of all, it's Prismaticism
playing it. So, that is as good as it is
for an Annie as you're going to get.
Half of our series played on stream were
by Prismaticism and all of them lost.
Not a single win.
Fair.
>> You you raised good points.
>> Um yeah, that's a really interesting
point because Azir gets so much
efficient value, right? From the
equipments in the deck. Whereas,
>> consistent
>> This Annie
gets value small small amounts for for a
large impact on the opponent's turn.
But, you're really just playing around a
few runes up at a time. Whereas, like
Azir is totally fine to just like Arise
or you know, go into a large set of
units into battlefields, right?
>> I feel like Annie is really good at
leveraging that trading one for one, so
to speak.
>> Sure.
>> never really one for one for the Annie
because either she gets more energy, so
she has more options available to her,
or the trading one for one is I'll put
my Annie back in hand and you put
something that you don't want back in
hand in hand.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
trading your way up time and time and
time again,
But, dealing with big blowout turns is
really difficult. And that is something
that an Azir can work up towards if
they're allowed to develop all these
gears time and time again.
Especially in game one when the gear
hate hasn't been all introduced just yet
in the full amount that they have
available in their sideboards.
A big Arise turn
will blow them out of the water. Now,
I will highlight the Death's Grip here
because we have gone back and forth
>> over it from people the first time they
saw it in Leel, being blown away by it,
and then quickly realizing, "Oh, no,
there are way better alternatives.
Actually, it's only good as a one-off."
>> Squirtle stays true
to his earlier convictions, runs three
of them.
>> Yeah, and and that it was RQ Leel that
really Squirtle showed that off to like
massive potential and on an RQ stage
we need to recognize that if we're
counting series at this level where
we're talking RQ level, yeah, this kind
of performance, I believe Squirtle is
now on just this insane undefeated run
from Leel through to today, which it is
nuts. It's broken Alan's win streak. Now
faces off against the Regional
Qualifiers champion from Atlanta.
>> Wait, he's already broken it?
>> Yeah, yeah, I heard earlier today he's
actually apparently broken the streak
for some somehow. I'm not 100% sure.
>> couldn't have been. You you you you
assured me not even two rounds ago that
that was not going to happen.
>> know. I did. I I assured you
>> I'm giving you a time check.
>> It's okay. As I honestly didn't think it
was going to happen.
Um
but, we'll get the stats.
>> Honestly, neither did I. But, Squirtle
peaking at the right time cuz the last
RQ he played
was Leel.
>> I believe so, yeah.
>> Yeah.
That is
that is mind-boggling.
The consistency that he's bringing into
the match, he's going to have to bring
it again. And
I think similar criticisms have been
voiced that you have been voicing about
Master Yi about Azir, stating that it's
consistent, the floor is high, but it is
capped.
How do you think it it relates to the to
the Master Yi?
>> Oh, that's a a really good question.
>> uh to compare them, which one has a
higher cap or a lower cap?
>> I I would say that there's like slightly
maybe more consistency purely based off
like you don't necessarily need to draw
a unit for Azir. Uh you're you kind of
have equipment options and then the
legend power most of the time. Uh very
few times do you see an Azir go past
turn one. Normally there's at least
something to be done.
>> What I like is that the agency between
them is on Azir's side. Sure. Azir is
always proactively setting up plays
where a Master Yi says, "Ah, you can
fight into me." And you need to be
proactive when playing into a
play-making deck like Annie. You have to
present tough choices to your opponent
rather than letting them roam free.
>> Important to note we do now go into a
moment of the game that
the tournament that is open deck list.
The the top eight now will have printed
lists to be able to to sideboard
properly against their opponents, but
that is now shared information.
I don't think we could have asked for a
better first match in our top eight.
>> I feel there has been a trend today that
I feel at least a third, but almost half
of the games that have been featured all
could have been finals match-ups, I feel
like, where big characters are clashing
into one another.
This does not look great when you go to
legend favor, but when you look at where
Prismatism
is taken into account, suddenly
Prismatism is eking out just that little
bit.
>> This tale of the tape
is crazy. Look at the recent
achievements on both sides. Leo first
place for Squirtle and then four
best of Annie's this and an RQ win in
that mix, of course, is just crazy.
>> Uh
how do you hold all the best of Annie's?
I mean
>> At a certain point he's going to run out
of room on his desk.
>> To bring them all to each
>> Uh I I did a
quick segment actually with Prismat
earlier in the weekend um
and a lot of times he's actually wearing
one of them around his neck.
>> On a like a a string in a top loader?
>> They're they're double-sided as well.
>> Oh, okay.
So, just in case it flips around, you
you got the back side of it as well.
Okay. All right, that's just a little
bit little bit of swag.
>> That uh that is a lot extra. I will say
that is incredibly extra and I love it.
>> So, we're looking at a player with four
top eights,
multiple best ofs,
>> and a truck
>> and an RQ win going up against two top
eights, an RQ win, and an undefeated
streak, being the defending European
regional qualifier champion. I know that
we track this slightly differently
between uh who won the last regionals
and where we're playing it, but while
we're in Europe,
I am taking onus and saying that if a
European RQ
>> I'm hungry.
>> by somebody and the European RQ winner
is in the house, they're the defending
RQ European.
>> I am hungry. Give me those extra steaks.
>> Yeah, exactly.
Uh so, genuinely a clash now of regions
and styles.
>> Here's the thing. If if we want to talk
about open deck list, I love open deck
list.
>> Sure.
>> Because
>> in my opinion, when a game is based upon
more information,
>> Uh-huh.
>> if you if your actions are well
informed, that will
uh usually show a purer
show of skill.
Because you you you don't have perfect
information, but you can anticipate for
things. You don't have to guess out all
the cards. You can focus it into the
playing field that is relevant. And when
you have two champions facing off
against each other, my expectations
can't get any higher.
>> Yeah, that that's that's very fair. And
your your point about also having
information on the deck list, I think is
is totally true as well.
Um for me, it's also like that's part of
playing at a competitive level, right?
Is that anticipating lines. I think
the unknown is is one skill of being
able to play around it. And that's where
you see many players doing very well on,
you know, the Swiss portion where it's
meeting any decks and all the kind kinds
of brews, but then getting to a top
eight and having the like refined
competitive it's pure decision-making at
the end of the day is exactly where some
players will just have a slightly
different strength, a slightly different
benefit. And to be able to do both in a
weekend
is a surprising challenge I think that
people knew don't necessarily
appreciate.
>> And what I like in this situation is
that to get to this stage, you need to
get through a blind field.
You need to prove yourself that you are
worthy of well, playing a game at the
highest level in which we do play with
open deck lists.
>> Just looking at both of our players as
they uh
we're looking to stare down the the lens
of the camera.
Getting ready
to go into this game. As said, there is
quite a lot of
eyes to dot, tees to cross when we get
to the top eight. Making sure everything
is on track.
>> I think it's just important for people
that are just dropping in to set the
stage once again. These people have been
playing since Friday.
On Friday, they played a pre-regional.
That's 7 hours.
Day one of the main event, another 8
hours. 7 hours behind us, and we are
ready to get into our game one of the
top cut in our queue Utrecht.
>> We get to join before battlefield
selection as well.
As our players
The thing about when you have players of
this caliber, right? Our queue winners
people who have won
at multiple events. People are always
looking to okay, what are my
battlefields? How do I play this out?
What is my strategy going into
competitive round? So a game like this
is a learning opportunity for everybody
including us. I'm I'm always fascinated
when we get a match up like this as that
mix of skill, charisma
you know, everything that is needed
to be
a player at the top of the game.
And to be a personality.
>> It is it is a a tough mix to pull off
because on the one hand you really want
to fraternize with the rest of the top
eight.
>> Sure, yeah.
>> Because the best training you can have
is against the best in the world.
But every match you play
gives them more information.
And the best players in the world are
more lethal than anyone else with
information. It's the one resource that
scales with skill.
>> Into game we go. Our queue Atlanta
champion, our queue Lille champion
facing off. Azia and Annie
in a top eight spot. Only one of these
two will advance to the semi-finals and
only one of them can keep their
tournament life alive. We've got
potentially three games to get us there.
>> Chris Madison who has been bailed out
for a second chance to get through the
top eight. No more second chances,
buddy. Now is the time to show up.
And when we are looking at the match up
in general,
>> I'll do two.
>> Azir
I always going to describe it as a
train.
On the rails, looks around pop at every
turn, needs a fresh scoop of coals, in
this case equipments. If you can
>> Find this one.
>> disturb the rhythm,
the train gets wobbly and it can get
derailed.
>> And every time we see Squirtle go, "Yep,
equipment, sand soldier, pass." It's
like, "Well, he's off to the races."
This is already
what you need to begin an Azir game.
This is where you're like, "Cool, we're
we're getting ready to go." And of
course that Soul Sword
one of the equipments brought in on in
Unleashed. And you can see it kind of
forces Prismaticism say, "Well, it's
Grim Apothecary. I can't do anything
tricky with it, but I will just play it
out as a unit for now."
>> As a body, three energy for three might
is a solid deal. You'll take it for
granted. You can always see if you can
get the value out of it later on. And
the first lunge onto the Hollow Legends
has been made.
Making that extra sand soldier
Getting him also a bit of extra leeway,
not as relying on, you know, in this
case a single gust is sometimes very
detrimental.
>> Oh, yeah. A bit of a buffer. Yeah, if
you don't have that follow up to
continue building, to continue
developing your units,
then
that's one of the things that really
slows down an Azir.
>> With
>> Yeah.
>> Go to one.
>> That will take care of the sand soldier,
but
his buddy is already chomping at the
bit, ready to go.
>> But what it also unlocks is a Noxus
Hopeful
>> Noxus Hopeful.
>> coming from Prismaticism because of
course it is a second of the turn. And
now Inferna plays a base.
>> That is
That is an interesting move cuz usually
Inferna best utilized as an ambush, but
with any to maximize all of your energy,
guess you don't need to ambush it per
se.
>> Yeah, it is an interesting
This is what I mean by this always a
learning moment, right? As as well as
the other thing of like is this economy
management of just saying well I know
I'm going to ready two.
Maybe that's an indicator of what else
is in hand from prismatism of like I
want to be able to do both of these
things over the next turn and a half. So
better to just get the unit out now,
it'll be ready next turn. And it it will
get the assault all the same.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Brutalizer one of the absolute standout
cards
as
>> Weapon this one.
>> Will cascade as we call it as units die.
Will be just paying straight up.
To equip it rather than using the weapon
master.
Taking out the Grim Apothecary.
>> Yep. I have another two faded and a
soldier.
>> And going tip for tap.
Right now it is hard to keep up with
just the sheer value that A Azir is
churning out. It's not costing him any
cards.
>> Yeah, it's massive value. Also don't
mind us if sometimes we drop in on the
players to hear. It is a rare
opportunity
to get exactly every word. A rare
opportunity to hear two IQ champions
face off.
>> For the two.
Discard a flash bro.
>> Yeah.
>> That rummage from
Zilean warns is going to allow Pris to
uh
boost this battlefield with the Ferris
Forager and this feels very similar to
the board state that Pris is put forward
against Colin earlier in the set Annie
match up. Will the Azir be able to break
it with this equipment?
>> And that is kind of the real issue here.
We are in a rise territory currently.
That would get him what looks like to be
three units. That is kind of the bare
minimum. It you don't feel too happy
getting three tokens from your eyes.
It's four and upwards where you
you're a happy camper. However, I want
to take a look at the Ferris Forerunner
because you are representing 10 might on
a battlefield. The investment required
to punch through that is significant.
You're going to lose at least a few sand
soldiers. Meanwhile, you're not really
putting Prismatism too far behind when
those tokens spawn back ready to go
to peak back on the turn. We talked
about death grip a little earlier and if
that is the route, we've seen Squirtle
use it to great effect where you can
really transfer the might from each unit
during the turn. See it as like a pseudo
accelerator or like a pseudo right the
wind.
Okay, grabbing the Brutalizer onto the
tapped token now. This would indicate
Here comes the death grip on the new one
so
has the benefit of the Brutalizer.
The only downside of this is you are
burning the candle on both sides. You
can't do this forever, but you don't
need to do this forever. You just need
to peak at the right moments.
>> So it's
11 total.
I will move inside with another.
>> I've been Yeah, it's plus five.
>> Prismatism has three up. The Rangara
could be there, but it's a flash that
will keep him alive.
Prismatism keeps his cards face down.
Close to the chest. Defy on the flash.
He's going to crush through both of the
units and now Prismatism was looking for
the defensive play. Squirtle says no,
I'm going to take first blood in this
exchange. And got up to four points.
>> The cost
The cost associated with conquering this
battlefield, right? Because you gain an
Ox Hopeful, but the might from the
forerunner is still there.
You are slowly dwindling a bit and
you're quite exposed left out on the on
the zone warrants. Now that both the
brutalizer is falling off and the death
grip will be gone.
But you have a bit of a gap. And with
death grip, you are not losing out on
too many cards in hand.
>> Go.
>> So the impact of it in the previous
turn.
And now Squirtle is like, well, you can
take the one that is on the battlefield.
Of course it will return to its regular
might as the turn for Prismaticism
continues. Um
if you're Squirtle, you're like, fine,
take the battlefield from me. I will
just get it back next turn.
>> Yeah, and most importantly, there has
not been a single answer from
Prismaticism to the gears that are
spawning. The arise is inevitable when
you are playing against the Azir. And
the longer you're allowing him to
develop these cheap gears time and time
again. We haven't even seen a BF sword
yet. We haven't even seen an eye of the
herald yet. The worst is still to come
and Squirtle is already halfway to a
win.
>> And in a great position board state-wise
as well. Prismaticism has been kept low
on resources as in hand. Low on the
ability to actually contend with the
battlefields. Yes, there was a stack
on the zone warrants previously, but you
look at what Squirtle has.
>> All right.
Okay.
>> And as long as the BF swords are not
coming out
>> Three.
>> Yes.
>> the death grip on the defense is not as
threatening.
>> Six.
Forerunner.
Ready to impasse.
>> Trying again. If at first you don't
succeed, Prismaticism's like, I'm going
to stack it again. I have to just do
this. I have to hope that you run out of
equipment. I have to hope that you run
out of bodies to be able to hold on to
this, but we know the Azir with the rise
is able
>> Oh. to turn things around. Picks up all
the runes.
>> Whenever they pick up all the runes, I
get so nervous.
>> I know. I'm always like, "Woah, what
what potentially could it be?" There is
a
I believe more equipment in hand
for Squirtle. I think I just saw the
corner of a BF sword there. Yep. There's
That is one option to power things up.
No rise though. Guards helps.
>> So, at this point, you really just want
to continue developing. Keep churning
out these gears. Keep those Sandshrew
just coming. However,
because the Hall of Legends is now
occupied by Prismatism, and the cost
associated with overpowering that is so
incredibly high, you're going to have to
think twice about it.
With a little extra equip, you can start
trickling in the units. Costly play on
the rune department, but very efficient
in the cards available on hand
department.
>> got an On Guard in hand.
>> Six.
Election.
Yep. Pass.
>> And here's the cascade. Says, "I know
six doesn't do it for me right now, but
I have another readied Sand Soldier to
cascade through." And the economy just
works out how you need it to. You're
like, "Cool. I will play another Sand
Soldier."
>> Incredibly costly.
Incredibly costly.
>> Six.
>> Going down
from your runes. Just
>> Put
>> Prismatism behind you. This has to pay
off.
>> Got another two. Greater recruits.
>> Pays using Hall of Legends to ready Azir
the legend, and then use the ability
again
in order to create another Sand Soldier.
Up to six points already. That's exactly
where it is. It's Squirtle setting
himself up on the next turn to take
this. And Prismatism now once again has
to break at least one of the
battlefields, if not both. And here
comes a hidden card.
>> Yeah, and you really have to think twice
about this because
putting away another rune puts you out
of a rise range for the next turn if you
manage to top deck it.
>> But even then, the guards is going to
add another body to the the battlefield
from Hidden. You have to play around
things like Hidden Blade as well. Rarely
is it used offensively, but every so
often, in a pinch, just to secure that
you're going to make sure your opponent
has no units.
We know that it's likely guards from
what we saw in hand earlier.
>> You don't want to give breathing room to
Prismatism right now. And that's exactly
what Squirrel is doing here. He is
keeping the pressure high.
>> Got a four.
>> Yeah.
>> It's so hard for Prismatism to get the
value from these trades when
Fiz Squirrel has got the value.
Units are more expendable.
>> Well, this is a very, very high assault
inferno.
>> Play with inferno?
>> Yes.
Six. I'll probably play guards.
>> Abandon.
>> Ooh, abandon to the guards puts it back
in hand. So, at least that means the the
guard that the sand soldier that comes
through will not be ready on the next
turn. And the overzealous fan will deny
the control on one of the battlefields
at least if there's only two sand
soldiers. However,
>> however,
if they want to commit to it, float the
rune,
>> Yeah, get the zero out accelerated, you
can
>> cheat out tempo in that same way Death
Grip can, but it will come at such a
heavy cost. Win the game or you might
squander it all.
>> Also, as a reminder for guards, you can
pay the one yellow recycle as well in
order to ready the sand soldier that
gets played. So, not the end of the
world.
>> 4-3
>> But, as you said, a zero is another way
of doing it.
That is one.
One point away from success.
Can they bait out the overzealous fan?
The line is out in front of them.
>> 4-1
Going for six.
Yeah, use fan.
>> There is the bounce back from
overzealous fan. Now, put in
Gods ready set with the yellow.
Weapon master will kick in.
Should be just attaching that
brutalizer.
>> So, this is very telling.
If Prismatism had the gust, he could
have responded to the equip. That is
bad.
>> That's it.
>> That is game.
Game one goes to Prismatism. That's
Sorry, goes to Squirtle, I should say,
against Prismatism.
>> That was the 50/50.
>> I was looking at Prismatism's deck list
to to look at whether the the copies of
gust are there. But, yes, it is a Sorry,
going to be Squirtle.
>> Playing out the pace, proving why he is
undefeated so far at RK Utrecht, ex-
getting closer to extending that largest
winning streak one more game, pushing
one of the best players out there to
their absolute limit. Game two will
bring more gear interaction. You have to
imagine.
>> Yeah, you have to imagine, and and it
will come out of the side board.
>> Boy, am I glad that wasn't the end of
the actual game.
>> That would have been embarrassing. Uh
so, game one, yes, as you said, side
board hate, surely we're looking at that
now. Players will have access to each
other's deck list. So,
um there is quite a lot of stuff that
can come in from um
the
I was going to say quite a lot of stuff
from Annie, but that's actually not
true. There's one copy of Factory
Recall. There's a Thermo Beam
>> I was about to say. The one piece of
interaction they have will absolutely
ruin Azir. Taking out all the gears in
the blink of an eye is devastating. That
is the kind of blow you don't recover
from. It's not definable.
It is the answer for Azir. And I will
tell you something about Prismaticism uh
that has stood out to me from previous
regional qualifiers as well.
Even though he's undisputed about one of
the best players out there,
wins never come too easy for him. He has
to work for it every single time. Where
a lot of his peers will be blowing
opponents out of the water,
it is more often than not that
Prismaticism is going to game three. But
that adaptability
and that game knowledge he owns to
leverage his sideboard in the way his
opponent cannot, that is what sets him
aside from the competition.
>> We'll have to see how Prismaticism can
do in this next game. I will say
I always get a little nervous.
As a non-pro player, I always get a
little nervous when it's a one-of coming
out of the sideboard.
>> Yes, there's a Factory Recall as well.
Well, that's going to do is slow things
down a little bit. It's a little bit
more for the Aurora match-up. But a
one-of Thermo Beam, you're going to have
to you're going to have to mulligan and
then dig for it. Unless you get really
lucky and it's there in the opening
hand, you're going to have to get those
stacked decks in this deck that
Prismaticism is running,
I would say one of the weaker aspects of
it is card draw. There's a lot of units
and a lot of things that play well
together, but outside of stacked deck,
there's not too too many ways of
actually drawing into new options.
>> Yeah, it's very heavily relying on the
Kaiser to be able to conquer uh the
battlefields, get the get the draws
through there.
But, you're right. It is uh not as
self-explanatory
as let's say a Diana that can stupefy
stack deck, keep keep get a quay out.
>> And and that's the thing is like Kaiser
is is is good card draw, right? And and
it's one of the reasons why Kaiser as a
unit has been consistent now in the the
lifetime of of Riftbound. Um but, it
always has that little butt, that
asterisk on it where it's like you have
to conquer with it, right? Like you have
to break through Squirtle's uh board
state in order to actually gain access
to that.
So, Prismatism, of course, will be
playing first
in our second game. Squirtle closing in
has one one foot
in the semi-finals for now, but the job
is not done. Um Squirtle on the other
side when we look at their side board
I'm assuming charms likely to come in
from this just to to pick apart some of
the units that uh Prismatism is is very
heavily leaning into. I would imagine Vi
as well potentially one of the the the
directions.
>> I think with the Vi is is a great answer
to call into, let's say
the Ferocious Forerunner.
>> Yeah, yeah. Just to to save
>> got a lot of units. I want to talk
battlefield.
>> Sure, let's go for it.
>> Because there are two remaining for
Squirtle.
Travaian Warcamp
and See the Power.
More draw. Do you hold off on on
introducing another source of draw for
your opponent till you have no other
choice?
>> That's a really good question.
Because I feel that Prismatism is
actually capable of producing enough
bodies to take advantage of Trevenant
war camp. This is not a real easy
decision in my opinion.
>> Yeah, that I I have to think that
through because you'd imagine that
Squirtle going first wants to like post
up on these these battlefields at like
both and just try and again keep the
pace sorry Squirtle going second wants
to just like try and recoup on some of
the pace. Exactly.
>> a Primal Groudon. I don't know why I'm
convinced Primal Groudon won game one.
>> I watched the game.
>> I was in the game.
>> I'm so used to assuming that Primal
Groudon wins that I
>> To be fair, I do get it.
The I think one of the casters did say
that he won.
>> Yeah, exactly. If you're listening to
that guy.
Uh it is going to be Sea to Power for
for Squirtle. Uh Primal Groudon on the
other hand, Arena's greatest, you heard,
already taking
the first point.
>> Good cards.
Primal Groudon for his tournament life,
potentially the last game he gets to
play in Utrecht.
No more second chances. This is it.
>> I saw from Yeah. Ooh, I I was saying how
important it is to be able to dig for at
least the answers that you need. I saw
from Squirtle's hand it didn't look like
there was an equipment at least in the
first three cards in hand.
There's uh
That's the Thermal Beam off the top of
the stack deck.
Do you just say I need this for later?
It doesn't help me now, but I need it.
If If you recycle that to the bottom of
the deck
>> this. You You I feel if you say goodbye
to the Thermal Beam, you're not seeing
it again for the entirety of the deck.
If you do not prioritize keeping it now,
you better have a real good reason.
>> Yeah, yeah, it's gone to have the one of
the payoff is there though. Sometimes
you just have it. Sometimes it's exactly
what you need. Sacked again.
Now you're like, "How do I get there?"
>> How do I That's what I'm looking for.
>> How do I survive to really have a big
impact with Thermobeam?
So,
currently,
when you look at the hand that's going
through, we're looking for some more
cheap bodies to get out of there. Next
turn we can start playing around. The
Noxus hopeful. Uh so, pumping out two
bodies to really rival what is being put
out there by Squirtle. But you cannot
afford to fall behind. If you have no
other choice, you need to lull Squirtle
into the sense of false security where
he wants to commit to it as many gears
as he can for an absolute blowout of a
Thermobeam.
>> So, double unit pass from Prismatism,
one of them being that hopeful. On the
other side, the Eye of the Herald, we've
seen how strong that is for Squirtle and
Azir players in general. Getting that
first unit, and it's going to be Azir
go.
>> That is a sign of weakness if I've ever
seen one. That is really just going to
show I have nothing in hand that I want
to be getting out there. But
coincidentally,
that is not too bad when your phone is
sitting on Thermobeam.
>> to say I was going to say is there a way
to do this
low equipment
>> No, there is
>> No, there's not.
>> There is absolutely not. For a deck that
is half gears,
>> That is very true.
But you feel like Prismatism is going to
be aware of that now. And he's like,
"Ooh, this Thermobeam for now is not as
integral."
>> And here, the Thermobeam is your
insurance policy.
>> Exactly.
>> Exactly. That is good for a rainy day.
Keep in mind that you can get it back as
well with Annie in case you want to ruin
his day twice. Costly, but not
impossible.
Yeah.
But now having so much of your resources
tied up in the Azir, it's a prime
Starcross target.
>> Yeah, that's a really good point about
recurring it with the Annie Chosen
Champion ability once you've used it.
Likely, if necessary, we'll see Prismata
hold the Annie for that, but it may not
be necessary in this game.
>> Twinfernal us.
Ready two of us.
>> And the onslaught of units is coming
from Prismatism this time. It is not
coming from Squirtle. It is not
the IQ Leal champion that is building
the wide board. It is the IQ Atlanta
champion putting out unit after unit.
>> Here is the thing that we brought up
before.
This
tempo.
This rhythm that Azir needs to fall
into, it has been disrupted.
The first bump in the road has reached.
And I'm not sure if you've ever been on
a bumpy train,
but have you ever feared like, "Oh, I
sure hope it stays on the rails?"
Even a single kind of non-turn, which
the Azir it's not nothing, but it's
definitely not the way you want to be
going.
Is that enough to dislodge the Leal
champion?
>> You decline the trigger?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> And you pass?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Leaving the sand soldier in base, course
Azir can bring that with him if chosen.
>> Evolutionizer.
>> Ooh.
And having to defy that is such an
unattractive prospect, but is it the
only thing you can do to stay in this?
He's giggling to himself. He
>> I'll respond with discipline.
>> So, effectively, is if it were to
resolve, it is more of a minus one
through here. So, it would if this all
gets to resolve,
Azir falls down to six.
>> Yeah, it resolves.
>> And then your action?
>> No action.
>> Okay.
>> How important for prismatics now it has
to be thinking
how important is that Azir?
Can I let you keep it? Is there a way to
let you I mean what what other prospect
does he have?
>> Apothecary.
Pick up the hopeful.
>> The ejector seat.
>> Okay. I'm going to go
>> can keep the Azir.
I'm going to go over here with a new
unit. Bounce it back to hand. And
>> I don't immediately hate it because you
have two Infernus sitting in your base
with the assault to lay this Azir under
siege. However, if there is more
equipment coming out and being stacked
onto the Azir
makes you nervous, but it comes with a
heavy equipment.
>> I was going to say but that's fine,
right? Because if Brutalizer gets played
out again, you're eating into the rune
like economy pool for Squirtle. And then
you thermo beam and then you go "Ha! Now
you got nothing. Now you can't do
anything." It is Brutalizer that comes
onto the battlefield so will go
and try and punish.
>> No sense orders.
>> Will punish.
>> Now seed of power trading once again and
this is kind of the risk that you open
yourself up to in that regard where you
still are losing out onto the Grim
Apothecary dying. You're still losing
the other battlefield and now you're not
even getting you know even getting the
Azir in return.
>> That is a
>> a a fair
>> It's a hefty blow.
>> Yeah, I was going to say it's a fair
fair fair amount of damage from that
situation.
So a hidden card could be guards, could
be hidden blade.
I mean now you have to give a little bit
of leeway. These Infernus not quite as
effective as you would have liked them
to have been. They can't both go
together now. Well, or if you do you're
committing a lot.
>> You'd be reliant on a a
or something of the likes to
push past that. Even if the guards do
come out, you can still take out the
Azir and then go in with the other
Inferna who by their self will overpower
a
a Sand Soldier. But, the thing with
guards on your opponent's turn, the
Weapon Master goes off all the same and
then suddenly you're looking down the
barrel of a five might Sand Soldier.
>> And then the question is like how does
the trade go with everything because we
we we we've seen Prismatism have other
options. There's a Kaiser in hand for
instance. Could accelerate that out to
do some of the dirty work and get the
draw on the back end.
Then, you do have enough where you to
get into a position with Star Crossed to
be able to uh to to maintain
the Kaiser. How important is it a
one-way trip for a Kaiser? Is Is there a
way out of that?
>> Is this the moment for Thermal Beam?
Just to cover your bases.
>> It's a good question.
>> It is
It's coming with a hefty price, right?
The the the the double Fury power.
>> And it feels weird asking that when
there's only two pieces of equipment.
But, for Prismatism
you either have to develop units
in order to keep scrapping over this
board state or you have to try and
annihilate Squirtle's game plan and and
keep the single draws.
>> And Squirtle hasn't been drawing a whole
lot. The Seed of Power has the only
extra source of draw and he we can
already deduce from the earlier plays
that he doesn't have a lot of gears in
hand.
>> Yeah, but that that's what the danger of
if Squirtle ends up being in a position
to resolve like a Hidden Blade on a on a
a single unit or something like that. If
he needs to do it defensively and gets
the draw from that, suddenly you could
draw into the options, right?
>> Yes. It is it is a nasty position to be
in. And now you kind of about conquering
the Seed of Power first, you're kind of
conceding that point. Like I'm not even
going to threaten your Azir for this
turn.
But, that means
that you're going to four.
>> So, it's develop units without clearing
out both battlefields. It's It's making
sure next turn you have the potential.
And that would maybe line up
like, okay, I need to see how many
pieces of equipment Squirtle plays and
then maybe thermo beam on the following
turn.
Cuz if you thermo beam and you've got
nothing out, you can't really take
advantage of it and Squirtle gets an
opportunity to to rebuild, right?
>> Definitely. And
even you could technically get the
thermo beam back, but that is so that it
would be five, mate. Cuz it's five,
right? Four for the two thermo beam, one
for the Annie.
I'm not sure if you can really really
recover from that.
And you're not in dire You're not in too
dire straits yet.
Now you start to worry a little more
because
this is the the kind of the the pivoting
point for when an arise starts to become
interesting.
>> trigger.
Yep, move trigger's good.
Killer recruit.
Ooh.
>> Prismat just takes the trade.
>> Conqueror 25.
>> Again.
>> Yep.
>> I have to feel like Prismat's kind of
like knowingly setting this board state
up. I I I'm maybe giving a lot of
benefit of the doubt, but when you a
player as good as Prismat, I'm like I'm
I'm going to assume this is the board
state you're trying to checkmate
Squirtle on. Eventually is wiping the
entire thing and trading as efficiently
as possible.
But it does feel like Squirtle has
managed to despite being low on
equipment for the beginning of the game,
put himself in a position
that if it weren't for the thermo beam,
would be incredibly scary.
>> And the difference between the
Prismatism turns and the Squirtle turns
is Squirtle is consistently leveraging
the drawing power of the seed of power.
>> Yeah.
>> Whereas Prismatism hasn't been able to
achieve similar results.
>> And here you have two bodies in hand,
another Kaiser.
A thermo beam and a merchant. You are
limited on options.
>> Ooh, it's a back off. I didn't even
consider that as
as the hidden card. And of course,
again, open deck list from this point
onwards.
Prismatcisim would have known that this
was one of the options. I wonder whether
this was an attempt to
>> Oi.
>> get a guards. Wow, that's painful. This
Prismatcisim has no no answer to it.
>> That is not the way you want to see your
Kaiza go. And when you consider in hand
that he is already quite low on cards,
you were
your options are slimming. You might
have to commit to the Annie and see if
you can get something from behind. Maybe
start stack decking because the time is
starting to tick.
>> It feels like that
definitely moves things in my mind much
closer to Squirtle's
game to lose from this point where the
Kaiza was part of drawing into more
options. The Kaiza was one of the units
that represented might on the
battlefield.
Annie comes out and we talked about
whether it would be looping things. It's
an Annie coming out for the stacked
deck.
>> And
it was true in the game against
Colossus. It is true now all the same.
When Annie to get a stacked deck back is
your best option,
that is cause for alarm. Even though you
you know, you're still looking
proactively for answers, the fact that
that is your best target is
>> Five to four.
>> Longsword into the showdown. Salvage on
the longsword is going to blow out the
showdown. And that's going to be it.
Prismatcisim is going to concede to the
Arcual champion Squirtle. Undefeated.
Moves his moves his way on to the
semi-finals.
>> Undefeated still. And this goes to show
that Squirtle not only shows that he can
manage his way around side boarding,
that he knows his opponent like no
other. The long sword, which was a
catch-you-off-guard card for the longest
time, Squirtle is not falling for the
tricks anymore. And Prismatism reaching
top eight, but going home all the same.
>> Wow, that that the the read on on that
game from I feel like Squirtle
>> Immediately got slapped down as well.
What a power move.
>> I it felt like Prismatism's sideboard
plan coming in so early in the game. I
was like, is that is that the what
Prismatism needs for this where Squirtle
just plays through? It felt like maybe a
rough and ready hand for Squirtle, but
maybe that's not quite where it ended up
being because the Azir was able to kind
of say, "Hey, I do have a game plan that
is not 100% based on equipment." Where
it's like one step away.
>> There was a slight bump in the road with
the Azir coming out, but he managed to
tide it over. And by the time that you
were like two, three turns later, you're
two Brutalizers
and with your back off, catching
Prismatism completely
off guard. And also the same. I think
that is kind of what forced Prismatism
into such a tight spot that he had to
commit to a upper under play.
>> And I I wonder I wonder now, looking at
this, clearly it's it's a match up that
people will have in mind of if if you're
attending an event and Prismatism there,
you're going to like practice it. I
wonder now, thinking about the Azir
match up of like, "Hey, we're
>> post sideboard.
>> Is this what I have to be aware of of
like, do I have to be concerned against
Fury decks that have the Thermo Beam? Is
this actually not so much of a bump, but
like just how you have to play the match
up?" And it's something that Squirtle
comes into being like, "Yeah, I'm
actually not unhappy doing that." I
would love to know. I'd love to
understand that. So, Barrett, I'm sorry
for giving you the question. Game two,
let's find out if Squirtle felt under
any pressure in that game.
>> Sure, I don't know if that is something
that Squirtle feels, but of course we
will ask him. I'm Bear Bryant, joined by
your now first top four finalist
currently for the RQ here in Utrecht.
Wow. Wow.
That's got to feel good, right? You
2-0'd against another regional qualifier
champion Prismaticism
>> Yes.
>> after already having to beat Alan
earlier today. You've got two down.
There's another one still in the
bracket.
>> Yeah.
It was It's a very stacked top eight, I
think.
>> And including your teammates
>> Yes.
>> on the other side, two more representing
Mis- Mis- Lion, right?
>> Mis- Lion, yes.
>> Representing on the other side of the
bracket, and here you are taking down
regional qualifier champion after
another.
How do you do it, man? Do you feel the
pressure?
>> Right now, I'm like super calm compared
with with my first top eight
at Lille.
So, I was just chilling. I I have a lot
of games with the fear, so I'm
comfortable with the deck, and that
makes it everything goes much easier,
like having a lot of decisions mostly
automatic.
Like not really, but you understand me?
>> No, yeah. No,
and in that same concept, game one I
felt was very dominant. You got You got
You found the equipments, you made the
tokens, you made the units, you had the
control of the board for most of the
game, obviously. And then the game two,
the the script was flipped.
>> Yes.
>> Prismaticism had so many units, so many
things to do that in your hand, frankly,
didn't have a lot of gear to play with,
but
playing it slow, playing it collected,
knowing that you're you can trust your
deck, and even all the way down uh
the fact that Salvage has action on it,
so you can play it in the middle of the
showdown against
It's in It's incredible.
>> discipline
>> Yes, it is. Yeah, exactly. And and
you are so well tailored to be a master
of this deck, it feels like.
Do you think anyone can stop you right
now?
>> I hope not.
>> That's a good answer. Well, I'll keep it
brief for you. That was a great
performance here. We have so much more
still to come here in Utrecht. And so,
we have another match that we want to
get to. So, we're going to send it back.
>> Thank you very much, Barrett, for
getting all the information from
Squirtle. Uh and we're going to be going
quickly into one of Squirtle's teammates
going up against another US RQ winner.
>> It is a good day to be the be a MyCelia.
>> I know. MyCelia fan or teammate, you you
are running the gauntlet of like
world-class players. As we'll be
flipping down to the other side of the
bracket, uh looking at a Diana against a
Darius matchup. Um so, Dawally, one of
you know, the the names that we've heard
from the beginning of uh competitive
Rift Rivals. Obviously, RQ Houston,
uh great performance.
>> Very early on.
>> Yeah, exactly. First one. Whereas,
MyCelia, um we really saw them rise to
prominence a little bit in Lille with
Squirtle's win. And since then, have
been building their team. We'll, of
course, get into that during the game.
Dawally's list uh looking It's so hard
to pick out the specific differences.
This does have the Kha'Zix in the list
that we've, of course, seen from Alan's
EQ earlier in the week.
Uh looking for anything else I As far as
I can tell, it seems pretty
straightforward.
>> The You can really tell that Alan's EQ
and Dawally have been scrimming each
other even more lately as they're both
running very similar lists. Now, I think
the one thing I have to keep in mind is
with two Star Crosses
>> Oh,
right.
>> there is uh it's very slight. It's
really minor. Uh uh two Fists being
played. So, you're going to have to be a
little more heads up with what you're
going to be throwing away and when are
you ditching the spells to be drawing
extra cards from the Quay.
>> And I will say, this is a match up that
Dewali probably has not played as much
as you would want to play going into a
top eight opponent. Whereas, when you're
preparing for this event, I'm pretty
sure Diamond Hat was like, "Yeah, I need
to be able to play against Diana."
>> More than just a few times. So, Baited
Hook Darius, the last time we saw a
version of Baited Hook Darius do well, I
think we were still on the precipice
either at the tail end of Origins or at
the very start of Spirit Forge. It has
come a bit of a way since then. The one
main issue was staying stocked up on
fuel, keeping your opponent under
pressure. Now, with the extra sacrifice
triggers coming through, Falling Star
remaining a key player just as a
one-off, you will be constantly delving
deeper and if you are not sure of the
value of a Matron, then I have a great
little proposition for you.
>> Okay.
>> Hitting that off the Baited Hook is
hitting the jackpot.
>> Well, you'll have to walk us through
that for those at home that aren't
Baited Hook players that that don't
quite know, but you you have to feel
like one of the things that that Diana
at least can can do is present a
slightly
tricky board for the sacrifice effects
to play around. You you do end up with a
unit here or there that you're not so
afraid to get rid of. As long as some of
those main parts of the deck like the
Quay stay alive, you you tend to be
okay.
>> Game number two.
Arena's greatest um
upping
the timeline just that tiny little bit.
Dewali already sitting on match point.
It's all up to Diamond Hat to prove that
they have what it takes to move on to
the semi-finals three in the footsteps
of their teammate.
>> I mean, if another Mycelian player takes
out another RQ champion
>> and they are on the lower line, we could
have immediately our finals far away.
>> However, I feel like as you said, 1-0 up
for Towelie.
Uh I would imagine
you have to feel like feels confident in
this moment.
>> Did you catch that? Double Hwei being
Mulligan. That is painful.
That is one of the key cards that Diana
is playing around and getting to the
point where you only have practically
one left that is within reach, quote
unquote, is really going to put pressure
on the Wally to come out even faster in
this match-up, which is already on a
murdering pace.
>> So, how important in this match-up then
does the Diana become uh without more
units like the Ridiculous, which now
shields um mostly down. Of course, there
in the beginning of a showdown, we will
have access to
um the legend ability further something
like stack deck, that type of thing.
But,
if a sacrifice effect did come out soon,
Diana would just end up hitting the
trash and that'd be it.
>> Yeah, I I didn't spot many Colda Weeks
though
in the in the list.
>> Sure. Yeah, there is Safety Inspector
>> There is a Safety Inspector that is
around it. You kind of want to hit into
that.
>> We're post board, so Colda Week there is
a copy of it.
So, Ash comes out again, another card
that is in the side board.
We'll take the Moonfall. The Hwei is in
hand.
And or Towelie.
Maybe
we should start from step zero and go
over what the Darius legend does cuz
I'm not really sure if people have been
brushing up on their on their Darius
deck.
>> You haven't been?
>> Legion trigger, get an extra energy.
>> Okay.
>> Just being able to play multiple cards
at once that way the shields are here.
You can be a little more greedy in the
power cost cuz your Darius is able to
sustain you through that temporary
setback.
That moonfall is currently banished
until until Wall-E holds and will be
returned to hand. So now Diamond Hat is
basically saying, "If you want this
back, you're going to have to do
something about it." And the only option
for the short term would be Diana.
And uh battlefield here is the stack
deck during the beginning of the
showdown. As said, we'll have access to
that to at least find another option for
Wall-E.
Keeping himself tied over just a little
bit. You need boots on the ground. You
need to see extra cards.
You have not a lot of time to be doing
such things as Wall-E. Yes, you have the
abandoned gate. Yes, you can filter
through your deck with the Diana.
However, having to commit
and put your Diana out in the open, you
kind of need an emergency exit for her
as well because the units that are lying
in wait to trap said Diana
are hungry.
>> Okay, yeah. You score to one or two, I
mean.
>> Yeah. And then I pass.
>> Okay.
We haven't seen too too much in the way
of Darius this weekend. Been
a fringe pick, I think it is fair to
say. But now in the top eight, we have
to look at
the how does the side boarding strategy
play up against Wall-E? Like we we've
seen decks that kind of cut different
parts of their strategy out. I wonder
what Diamond Hat has made room for
to bring in the likes of the Ash, maybe
the the Call the Week,
maybe the Falling Star.
We will have to see what comes out of
the board,
at least out of the deck. As uh looking
to step forward with Diana. Has a gust
in hand, so knows that might be able to
control this, get the look, get the
vision.
>> Top deck or whatever.
>> Yep. Fair.
>> All I know is that you can never
underestimate what a Darius is able to
pump out in a single turn.
>> That's probably
>> So Wally did not like the star cross
from the top.
Goes to hand, maybe has some use later,
but was not particularly happy with
that.
Of course, that's because you need to
target when you've got own units as
well. So in this situation, not an
answer
that Duwali would need, or be looking to
go for.
>> The one thing you're going to have to
keep in mind is that he does have access
to the gust. Leaving the one energy
open.
However, the units available on the side
of our Darius are not really in gust
range, now are they?
>> They are not.
The Ash is not. Uh The scary
>> proposition that Diamond has in front of
him right now is do I want to step out
to the abandoned hall. The battlefield
for Diana where she can really ruin your
day. But without any Ravenbloom
students, without any Huwei's, which
well, to Diamond's knowledge, there
might be a Huwei just sitting in hand
waiting to be coming out, but it
couldn't be further from the truth.
>> Which I'm pretty sure was uh
I'm pretty sure we saw it in hand
earlier, right? We
>> The Huwei?
>> Yeah.
>> Did I just miss that?
>> Am I Am I crazy? Or I'm pretty sure when
the Ash revealed the hand, there was a
Huwei in hand for Duwali.
That is
>> That is very fortunate in my opinion to
be uh
hitting all three of them, if that is
the case.
Until then.
>> I'll just trigger the Diana.
>> And you can see how important it is for
Diamond Hat to try and
>> Sure, I'll just take it.
>> stop Du Wally
from getting the hole to get the moon
fall back and breaking the unit cohesion
that Diamond Hat
>> So, the most important fact here is if
you can get rid of the Vex and you can
get a cheap little spell out there, you
can get the Darius out there on seven
might
and lay waste to whatever remains on the
battlefield.
>> That is one of the strengths of course
of Darius and that chosen champion's
zone, you always have access to that
almost always ready.
Normally, you don't ever play it without
having something else to uh
>> But, it is fickle.
>> set up.
>> It is fickle because if you over commit
Okay, I'll draw two.
>> Whoa.
That is That is a costly price. Giving
Du Wally more cards, sacrificing your
own economy to do it, and now also
closing the door on getting a
a second battlefield conqueror.
>> All of that to deny a moon fall.
But, draws into a second moon fall, does
Du Wally.
>> Unfortunate.
>> Not exactly what Diamond Hat would want
to eventually see coming from this. But,
of course keeping them low on the moon
falls means no back-to-back moon falls.
We saw Alan Zq do that yesterday and
>> units to moon fall.
>> Exactly, you need your own things as
well in order to contend. It doesn't do
anything really on its own in that
regard.
>> And that is the play that we've seen
Diana players crack under.
When they are being pushed to their
limit unit wise, when they're not
allowed to get themselves established,
and not play around their strength with
Huwei and start jumping all over the
place, that is when the cracks start to
show. But, with two units on the board,
even a safety inspector would be far out
of reach of getting the job done. And
not a single baited hook we've seen yet.
>> Haven't seen it yet. Now does
Diamondhead
feel comfortable with one moonfall still
banished
to play units to the base
try and stack up cuz you do need units
in the the back end of this is going to
be a rally the troops.
Looking for one more
draw potentially
I mean we're talking about exactly
Legion is now active so there are
multiple options to come from this.
And even though for this turn you know
that would mean eight might for the
Darius.
Battlefields are empty.
But a few Noxus hopefuls would really
help out in a pinch right now. And
Diamondhead being a four means you're
not forced to try and conquer to be on
time
with things that falling star could be
huge. Uh it's so expensive to get that
on the back side though. That's what I
was going to say. It it's huge but then
the big but is yes you'd have to uh
deramp yourself a lot while to while
he's actually sorry Diamondhead is
actually going to
bring the Darius is the option probably
says that there's not so many
options in hand. Now will go to five.
But and the key here is right
that if you threaten it with just the
Vex
or the Vex and the Titan you'll be
losing out on the Vex.
Sure. Like you do you're just trading at
that point so you're they're going to
have to be more stupefied they're going
to have to be a moonfall to get the job
done but even a moonfall on its own will
not spare the Vex.
Uh uh it it probably will because of the
abandoned hole. My bad. No that's okay.
It's uh one of the things that
the the intricacies of
now being in a second game and different
version of course as you're alluding to
And that's why it's so such a deadly
battlefield for Diana because
the math doesn't math anymore.
And even better if you can just get a
stupify and say that's actually a plus
one minus one now in this exchange.
And this is a little bit of a struggle
because if Diamond had does end up
losing the Darius here, the moonfall on
the back end, the moonfall is so
disastrous.
>> Exactly.
>> Ash.
>> You get the ash as well on top of the
Darius, the minus twos will come across.
>> minus two, so I think
>> And the ripple effects for this are
absolute
they're monstrous because your one
guaranteed accelerated unit is Darius.
You've already committed that.
>> Yeah, it's already gone. It's going to
be And the thing is with Vexina
Battlefield, any other accelerated units
are now hindered. They're going to be
stunned, they cannot move the turn they
enter, so you're taking a a turn off
every single time.
>> And not only that, you are now
guaranteed almost to get the moonfall
back or commit another hidden blade.
>> Diamond had I think must have just been
like gambling on yet I I've got one
moonfall out of the way and I didn't see
another one earlier, so maybe maybe
that's enough. But the hidden blade
causing the draw into the moonfall was
enough for Diwali to say, "Yeah, I'm
actually able to turn this game around."
>> And I still wouldn't qualify that as a
misplay cuz you do have to act on the
information you have. Not not saying
that you did, but you you have only a
few openings on playing into Diana. So
when you think you smell weakness, you
have to pounce. I respect the fact that
he's keen to undertake action, but it
comes back to bite him.
>> It does and now that's three units
played. We know that Diamond had is
going to have to to kind of play this
out slower on this turn, no real way
without anything that can take care of
the Vexina. Falling star is likely just
going to hit the Ravenbloom
and the tide turner. Now that's a
dangerous proposition because if Diwali
cast more than one
one spell here, casts his own tide
turner, bounces it back, that'll put the
Raven bloom. It didn't even need more
than one because the abandoned hole is
going to take it up above the threshold.
Gives it the plus two. And D'awali, that
is so punishing to Diamond Hat.
>> The abandoned hole coming through clutch
once more. And every single move that
Diamond Hat makes puts him deeper into a
hole that he might not be able to dig
himself out of. What options are even
left to him as he's fighting for his
tournament life?
>> There really isn't too much to do. No
quick units will be able to get out.
D'awali will hold up to six, retake the
control of the moonfall, which basically
says I'm going to punish you the moment
you have units. And that means you have
to feel like D'awali is moving closer to
a semi-finals
for himself here in Utrecht.
>> Diamond Hat has gotten so far. The
baited hook finally comes out, but there
is no bait to put upon this hook.
Nothing to chum the waters.
And as D'awali is moving up to six
point, no units in view still. Vex on
the battlefield ever long.
>> Uh, I got this back.
>> The curtain slowly falling.
>> Does indeed get the moonfall back.
Goes up to five. Needs to find a way to
get up to six and really put the
pressure on. There's a ride the wind in
hand. It's all coming to fruition for
D'awali. Didn't even need the Quays that
were mulliganed at the beginning. Tight
turn uh,
another option. We saw it gusted back.
So that will pull the Raven bloom
student to the base.
>> Just getting to the six point. And all
of the pressure is on Diamond Hat, not
on D'awali.
>> And regardless of what Diamond Hat does
from here, you have to prevent the ride
the wind in the opponent's turn as well
to move to a separate battlefield and
hold. D'awali has all of the cards, all
of the options in hand. You have to feel
like Diamondheart only three
in hand left.
>> All the bases to be covered off by
Diamondheart. A man can only do so much.
What is your breaking point?
Diamondheart will awaken,
ready the runes for turn, take one last
look at options, but I've already seen
the shake of the head as DeWali passed
priority, passed the turn over at six
points. It's a double hold or it's a
ride the wind hold
or anything else that DeWali wants
to close this game out. Diamondheart
does not have many options left.
>> So many roads lead to victory for DeWali
and all of them seem to be paved. This
is comfortable, smooth sailing, no bumps
whatsoever, no ditches, and he can
practically smell his semi-final seat.
>> top of that, I think DeWali has answers
in hand to most spells, too.
Diamondheart is thinking about it.
The cards are set to drop, and at that
moment DeWali will know that the RQ
Houston winner will be advancing.
Diamondheart thinking through every
single last option, but it's not there.
Our RQ Houston winner is a semi-finalist
at RQ Utrecht.
>> DeWali keeping his second regional
qualifier trophy dreams alive as he
moves on to the semi-finals.
>> And that
was a good example of knowing what the
core parts of your strategy are in a
matchup and saying, "Actually, you know,
maybe if we're blind in game one, it's
fine, but in in an in a deck list that I
I know what you're playing, actually, I
don't need some of these options. I need
different parts of my deck in order to
play through the early game." And that's
exactly what happened to DeWali. Great,
great win.
>> And for the deck from Diamond Hat that
was supposed to put his opponent under
pressure early on, never got in the
groove. The Wali didn't let him. And
then suddenly a small margin
is all that it takes for the Wali to
snatch that second win as well. Move on
to semi-finals where he well there might
be another uh
funky deck waiting for him.
>> Well, as said earlier, we have eight
unique legends that have made their way
to our top eight. So, that means we have
four in the top four. It's
lovely how that works. Uh we will get an
update on exactly what our semi-finals
pairings are, of course, cuz two other
matches have happened off stream, but
they I believe uh should have finished
by now. So, that is uh an exciting
prospect to look at. We have Squirtle
advancing uh beating
>> Lonely Squirtle.
>> Grizzly Man.
Uh going potentially at the end of the
bracket up against the Wali. They would
have to make their way through their
semi-finals, but we did look at two
separate sides. Now, let's look a little
bit more into the Wali's win with an
interview with Barrett.
>> And here I am once again this weekend
joined with you, the Wali, after a very
powerful match against a deck that I
don't think any of us saw coming. Darius
represented by one of the Mycelian
players.
What do you think about that?
>> Uh so I you know, there's a guy I coach
and he has Tommy, this guy that he's
friends with from also from Spain,
right? Uh he's like this guy that I I
you know, I play with that I know um
from Spain is the best Darius player in
the world. That's what he said, you
know. He's like he's like he's the he's
you know, he's probably the best Darius
player in the world. And I'm like,
"Okay, cool." He tells me 7-1 after day
one. I'm like, "Okay, that's cool, you
know, he probably got the best of." Now,
I'm playing him in top eight. That's
crazy, right? Like first top eight for
Darius. That's insane. And their team is
crazy, too.
>> Yeah, because in that same team they
have who I would say is the best Rex Sai
player in the world right now because
there's also a Rex Sai in our top eight.
>> Yep, he's in there.
>> And then of course, we got to talk about
him. Squirrel
>> Squirrel, yeah.
>> on the opposite side of the bracket
having taken down Alanzq during Swiss.
>> Yes.
>> An update for you.
He also just defeated Prismatcisim while
you were playing. Yeah. So he has now
beat two regional qualifier champions
and Alan might count as two.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, he does.
>> There is an opportunity
>> Uh-huh.
>> where you can meet him in the finals and
we can have a very similar situation to
what we just saw a couple weeks ago.
That could be you against him and I
think that's a crazy story line to
We're going to really find out some
goats of this game real fast.
>> Yeah. Like no matter how it goes, it's
crazy. Cuz like if he beats me, then
he's beat three on his way Also, he'd
have two undefeated runs. Full
undefeated. Back to back. Like just
crazy. Absolutely crazy. He He's
I was talking to his teammate.
Cuz like I don't think Azir is like the
best deck. It's solid, but like he's
just like Squirrel's just crazy. He's
cracked. You know what I mean? And it's
He's proving it. So.
>> Really showing why Azir is a force to be
reckoned with and there are obviously
other people respecting that including
people like Alan and Prismat and
yourself.
>> Yeah.
>> But even still, setting yourself up for
your next match, I don't know who you're
against, but you are on the same side of
the bracket as the other Mycelian team
member, the third one, that Rex Sai deck
and it took down people like
Billionaire on the Volibear to get here.
>> Yeah.
>> You might have to find yourself beating
their entire team to get a win to
>> That would be wild. Holy.
>> to what you were saying earlier this
weekend that the level of play in this
in this region of the world in your
>> Unreal.
>> is so stacked.
>> Unreal. Unreal. Cuz like you have all
the good players coming from uh like
let's say the uh the west side, right?
And then you have the Europeans who I I
think they don't really come to the
North American events as much and so
like you know Squirrel for example his
last RQ was Lil. Yes. Right? He's only
played Bologna and Lil. And he's he's
insane. He I think he got top 20 or
something like that in in in Bologna.
But regardless
yeah yeah so he's he's just like nutted.
Like it's actually crazy. Um and that's
what I'm saying like the the level of
every round is tough. Like you don't get
free rounds especially on day two. And
the fact that their team put three in
top eight and I may have to go all
through all three of them. Rex has also
a deck I don't know how to play against
that well so we'll figure that out.
>> But it's just it's unreal honestly
kudos to their team. Like they are a
group of like insane players in my
opinion.
>> But just as unreal as yourself Towelie.
Still representing Diana and still
solidifying yourself a titan of this
game moving to top eight. You've got to
feel great. Congratulations but you've
got some more games to prep for and so
we are going to send it back.
>> I always love hearing from Towelie. I so
much charisma and Redly is like yeah
okay I can run through that whole team.
That's fine. I can go through that. But
to be honest I don't really know the Rex
guy so well.
>> Yeah well I've never played against him
so I guess I'll just win.
>> Yeah yeah exactly. That's the level of
confidence that you need to be a
two-time champion.
>> But I love those stories though of like
hey I was speaking to one guy in one
round in the Swiss and then he told me
about his friend's really good and then
it turns out his friend's top eight at
the
>> It honestly
it sounds like the start of a a role
playing campaign. You'll hear in the
tavern rumors of a seven one Darius. I'm
like interesting.
>> Rumors of a a Spanish team that are
building their way I mean the success
that my team and I have had even taking
a snapshot right here and now looking at
that top eight list of players has been
incredible and considering
that we're on their home turf for the
next RQ for Barcelona is nuts isn't
>> Okay I'll have to intervene. I will not
say that the Netherlands is home turf
for a Spanish team. That goes a step too
far.
>> RQ for For next doc queue. We We're not
done with this doc queue. We're done
with round of eight. But, what we can do
is take a look at our semi-finals in a
few minutes when we come back.
>> A key component of playing League of
Legends is gathering XP and leveling up.
Now, you can do that in Ruined King II
with the newest additions in Unleashed.
Every XP you get will add to your level
as a player and will benefit you in
different forms. So far, three legends
have been released that directly benefit
from XP gain. Kha'Zix's Void Reaver,
Poppy, Keeper of the Hammer, and Master
Yi, Wuju Master. Notice that all of
these have the Body domain in common.
Master Yi uses XP passively. With higher
level, he finds stronger passive
effects. At level six, your units are
permanently boosted and at level 11,
your units always enter ready. Of
course, in the main deck, most Master
Yis will rely on the champion unit,
Master Yi Unstoppable, as a win
condition. This one gets cheaper the
more XP you have and at level 16, it
even becomes untargetable. Combined with
Master Yi, Wuju Master's ability to
enter ready, he can really swing games.
Kha'Zix and Poppy have the unique
ability to gain XP through their own
legend abilities and otherwise use it
like a resource. While Poppy generates
card advantage by spending XP, Kha'Zix
gains utility by the buffing his units
or moving exhausted units away from the
battlefield back to base. Since all of
these three legends have the Body domain
in common, there's a huge variety of
Body cards that can get you the XP you
need through the Hunt keyword, for
example. Hunt cards grant you an XP
whenever you conquer or hold. So,
winning combats for those decks is of
utmost importance. Cards like Gem-Knight
Hunter, Voracious Grump, and Master Yi,
Tempered can be found in all three
decks. But, XP can also be splashed into
other decks.
Grim Resolve, for example, is a strong
combat trick that gives the unit free
might on action speed. If the unit wins
the combat, it grants you two XP.
This card might find its way into other
decks as well. Europe players have
already played around with the
Shepherd's heirloom, which works like a
Doran's Blade, but does not equip for
power cost, but for XP. There are plenty
of ways to integrate some XP gain into
your deck, so get those level in and
scale into the late game, Rift Bounders.
>> All right, then from over 1,800
players battled it through all the way
through Swiss, only four remain. And I'm
Shae Burton, joined by Leon, and we will
be your tour guides through this top
four round here at the Utrecht Regional
Championships. Leon, talk to me. Top
four, what's going through your mind?
>> We have so many different decks in top
eight already.
Four
have not been eliminated eliminated
quite yet. We're still waiting for one
result from the top eight, but we have
already found one side of the bracket.
So, our next match is going to be Collin
versus Squirrely. We're going to see
that match very, very soon.
Squirrely has had a phenomenal
performance, being completely
undefeated. Again, I don't know if he
won his last round in Swiss as well.
But that is already legendary, right? We
have been talking so much about Alanzq
maybe being the goat of this game.
>> Yeah.
>> What about Squirrely? Come on.
>> Yeah, well, he's going to be Well, he
has a chance, and he's doing a fantastic
job of doing so so far. I've been in
Well, two regional qualifiers. And when
we've seen it on stream, it always just
seems so I don't want to use the word
effortless, but it just seems like it's
always at his own pace.
>> Yeah.
>> He never really seems stressed out. Like
in that last one there against
Pragmatism Pragmatism, it was all just
like it looked like in that game two,
things shouldn't have been going his
way, but you know, he just little Sun
Soldier here, little trick there, and
And of a sudden he's in top four.
>> I mean, the Azir deck won with a sided
in Salvage versus Annie. That is so
amazing. Most people wouldn't even think
of using Salvage against Annie, but
knowing that the longswords are such an
integral part of the strategy of Annie,
identifying that is huge.
>> Yeah, and you just saw the way he just
popped that Salvage down like, "Think
that's my ticket there to top four."
But, let's talk a little bit about his
opponent with that Set deck. You know, a
deck that's very strong on paper, but
traditionally I think it's safe to say
hasn't been making too much noise at the
competitive level. How do you think you
see this one panning out?
>> Pretty strong on paper is uh
a statement for sure, because I think
nobody really saw this coming. I mean,
we all knew that Collin was amazing with
the Set deck, but nobody really saw him
doing a deep run. It's of course he's
going to get all of these best ofs,
very, very cool, best Set player ever.
But, now sitting in top four of the
Utrecht Regional Qualifier, biggest
tournament so far. Maybe the most Set
tournament so far. Some people have been
already saying that the competition here
was absolutely fierce.
So, we can go into discussion why this
deck is so strong in the meta. And I
think a big part of that is Fiora
Victorious.
>> Mhm.
>> Fiora Victorious is of course a unit
that doesn't cost you power. Can
consistency be played can consistency be
played long day on turn two
>> Yeah.
>> of your deck. And this card, when you
buff it up, is insanely overstated. Not
only does it get plus one from shield,
it gets deflect, so it's really hard to
remove. And then
top of the crop, it also gets ganking.
And that is very, very important against
those aggroish decks, because sometimes
when they can't overpower your Fiora in
that one battlefield or don't want to
throw too many units into it, because if
it dies, you're just going to recall it
with your Set ability. They try to sit
down in the other battlefield, wait out
until you maybe leave your battlefield,
and then score one point. And then what
does Fiora do? She just gangs over
because of her third keyword that she's
getting. I think
many aggro decks are performing
incredibly in this tournament. Look at
this. There's Rek'Sai, there's Darius,
there is a Victor that can also be
considered aggro. Master Yi is playing
more aggressively than ever. And Annie
the Darkchild also can be considered an
aggro-ish deck. So so many of these
decks I think they get punished by Fiora
victorious quite a bit.
>> Yeah, that Fiora, quite honestly, when
it gets rolling, it just steamrolls
through the board. And the scary thing
is, you know, if you are going to try to
say, "Well, I'm just going to let Fiora
be Fiora. I'm going to sit over here on
the other battlefield." As you say,
eventually, if you do commit the
resources to actually, you know, kill
it, and you just go, "Oh, I'll just do
my legendary ability then and then buff
the buff." And it's just right back
there next turn, buff it again. And
she's right back in the mix. I'm
intrigued to see how this one pans out.
You are quite like as we do look at this
uh bracket breakdown, it seems to be the
battle of the sort of aggro decks and
then the rally there that Diana
trying to hold the flag up there. Which
could be to be to be safe to say, maybe
Diana's not quite aggro deck, but it's a
very tempo deck, right? It tries to push
the pace quite early on.
>> I'm really curious to see how Azir
versus Set is going to play it out. By
the way, I think this is the most amount
of order decks we've ever had in a top
eight. Five order decks all of a sudden
when everyone has been saying that the
chaos domain is by far the best from
Origins into Spirit Forge and now in
Unleashed as well. Five order decks is
massive, but back to the match up that
we are about to see. Azir, Emperor of
the Sands, versus Set, the boss.
So I think
that when it comes to these combat-heavy
decks,
nothing beats Azir.
Azir can create might out of nowhere.
Azir is flexible by taking unfavorable
trades sometimes, freeing those
equipments. Hello everyone.
Can we get some Can we get some noise
for the EMEA Regional Qualifier?
>> Well, let's make some noise for our top
four right now. Come on, people.
Uh
Here we go. Okay, a little bit there
waving. That's what we like to see.
Shout out to you guys for sticking
around. We are getting late here in the
evening, but we want to see who will be
lifting that trophy right there.
>> And it's this guy in the front.
I think he might be uh getting it. No,
in all seriousness, I think the Azir
deck is so so incredibly strong in those
heavy combat might heavy trading decks.
You can create might out of nowhere. You
can play around with the different gear
equipment gear. And then you are just
pushing it around as well, distributing
brutalizers left and right.
It's
incredibly hard to imagine that other
decks really outplay it when you're
getting into hand-to-hand combat like
you really literally do with that.
Showstopper also a rhyme
>> Mhm.
>> defy target.
>> See, it's interesting. So, I was
thinking, you know, when I was watching
Squirl in the top eight, it's like
because you don't run any units in your
deck, you can run so many tips and
tricks that it just means, you know, you
have so many options as the games do
plan out. You know, we saw the hidden
blade with the salvage. You got all the
equipment, of course, discipline, defy,
all of which can just be summoned when
you've got your multitude of sand
soldiers. And I still think we haven't
seen the sort of, you know, the generic
bread and butter turn of the massive
Azir plus Azir sovereign combination to
close games out. That's the sort of
major strength of the deck. We haven't
even seen that yet. And Squirl was still
absolutely tearing it through on stream.
But we have seen Collin on stream as
well really putting on a show. But yeah,
here's the Azir deck. Look at that, you
know, death grip, Azir arise. We saw the
back off in top eight as well. But I do
like that sneaky vibe destructive that
can cause problems.
>> Yeah.
>> Might is incredibly on the offense.
It's one of the cards that can also
cause some trouble for set the boss
decks, even though set is also running
that VIP skeeper. So,
definitely a threat to look out for.
I thought there was no single repulse
target in the Azir deck, but then I
forgot about the back off. You said it I
think
people usually should think also hidden
blade, of course.
It There's a hidden blade hidden. Or
gods, perhaps. One of the two is going
to be hidden there, and you have seen
this with prismaticism.
Says, "Okay, you're I either going to
bring out your gods, and then I'm going
to kill the sand soldier from that, or
I'm going to kill your Azir, or you're
going to give me two draws with hidden
blade on my Kaiser."
And when this was back off,
he was flabbergasted that Kaiser just
died. This back off for one power traded
off one for one
with the Kaiser, exactly. And that was
already the point where I think everyone
watching this knew, "Oh, that is
Annie generates a lot of tempo, but you
can't really come back from that."
>> I mean, we were watching it backstage.
We were like, "Oh, yeah, back off. We
completely forgot about that one." But
there's Collin's deck here, built around
that set legend. All about buffing, and
you can spend a buff to keep your unit
in play. I want to draw some attention
to that set kingpin card, though. That
might can get out of hand, getting one
extra might for each buff
buff any friendly unit at the
battlefield it's at.
>> Ooh, it's going to be so interesting to
see. Is Is it going to be Fiora
victorious dominating those
battlefields, not creating an opening
for Squirtle to get in those
battlefields, and then keeping on
ganking?
>> Mhm.
>> Or are we going to see a whole different
game playing out? I think it's also
going to heavily depend on who
wins the dice roll, who is going to go
first. Can you establish those threats
in this match-up
first?
>> Okay, so our opening hands are being
consulted. we are in our mulligan phase
here.
Looking at the battlefields there, Leo.
Hall of Legends and the Monastery of
Hirana, which we saw get used a lot in
another feature match from Colin.
>> I'll keep.
>> Old school.
>> to uh keep. That's not fun for me.
I dare you. He gave me some hope.
>> It is amazing that we have our players'
voices here that we will be consulting
throughout this round. So, if you hear
us, be quiet. All of a sudden, it's
going to be trying to hear what our
players will be saying.
>> Squirtle keeping that hand. It looks
like a very, very well-balanced hand
where you also have, of course, a
one-drop in this Soulblade. However,
Soulsword, there is no other gear in
that hand to follow it up. So, if you do
not find one within your next two draws,
you're going to miss that second turn
play unless you want to develop your
Azir sovereign, which is, I think,
a fast strategy.
>> Going to be the four-two mulligan there
for Colin.
All right, and it looks like we're going
to get our top four feature match here.
The Uget Regional Qualifier started.
Squirtle kicking us off. I've Herald
Sand Soldier being created and the path.
>> Now, that looks like a
>> Oh, no.
>> tough hand for Colin.
Maybe Squirtle just has too much aura
so that his opponent can't even begin to
play. This is the Hall of Legends game.
This is
probably the best battlefield for Azir.
It feels like it's absolutely tailored
for it. You can't just conquer in there
and you make another Sand Soldier out of
nowhere for just one
simple energy. You create units out of
nowhere.
>> Reserving that equipment there, moving
it back.
Okay, it's over to Colin, surely. We
know there's a Fiora in hand, right? So
we can at least play that.
What we got there? Rengar Sabotage.
>> Call to glory. There's a card that you
can use for free if you were willing to
spend some buffs or one buff rather and
get plus three might on reaction speed.
Double punch first.
It looks like this Fiora is going to for
the moment stick around at least.
But how much impact is she going to have
also? Colin deciding to develop a Fiora
instead of leaving enough runes open for
a Rengar Trophy Hunter that could be
used defensively.
Even though the play of a surprise
defender Yi
a Rengar is much more
powerful Yi.
>> We are going to see a conquer there at
the Monastery of Hiruana.
Put in square along too. We are going to
see the Sun Soldier backing him up there
with another recruit and we are going to
see two coming back there as well back
to base.
I think your equipment looking slightly
anemic. Only two in play right now.
>> Worst comes to worst, you can develop
Azir.
>> No. Oh. Okay. Speaking of equipment,
we're going to summon the big, the bad,
the scary BF sword
with a Sun Soldier coming down as well.
>> But we don't have enough energy to just
ready our Azir again and make another
token.
It's also why
>> Okay, Colin. Now it's time for you to
get on the board now.
>> He doesn't look
>> I don't know. Looking at that body
language there, doesn't look terribly
impressed. I think it's safe to say.
>> He also doesn't look terribly happy.
Looks into the hand now with the
sabotage. Knows there is one rune open.
Now are we going to see a possible defy?
I think sabotage would be funnily enough
a prime defy target. You don't have that
many in this match up and defy conceals
your hand.
>> Wow. Okay. Hand knowledge kept private
there from Colin.
Forcing resources out the hand again.
What else has Colin got? If you are
going to go up there.
>> That just goes to show again how
important hand knowledge is in this
game, especially when you have such a
formidable opponent because you did
basically decided to not spend a power
>> to
>> to conceal your hand.
>> Big Rengar coming down Trifarian Glory
off both those battlefields.
No buffs in play yet though. Won't be
able to use our legend ability to
preserve any of these if they do go
down.
>> B.F. Sword.
>> Here we go.
>> Squirtle does what he does best. Playing
out some gear.
Trying to get back into the Hall of
Legends. Wants to get more Sand Soldier
tokens, but Colin responds with a punch
first.
>> Bonus damage plus five to the Sand
Soldier in the back.
>> Oh, and I think that Fiora is going to
get outed.
Death grip
on that unit with the B.F. Sword.
Pushing plus five might. That is an easy
equip of the B.F. Sword there.
That is so incredibly punishing. Colin
playing to his win conditions, playing
with the cards that he has.
But the answer is just right there.
>> This is going to be a stacked Sand
Soldier right now.
B.F. Sword still left to equip.
Still got a recruit there to play with
as well. I imagine this is going to be
the B.F. Sword getting equipped. It is.
That is a plus nine Sand Soldier then.
>> We already have the 10 to 9 Hall of
Legends here. The Sand Soldier isn't
even in the Hall of Legends, but in
theory you can just push it in there.
Completely
tapped out. All runes exhausted and
there is no buff in play. So, not only
can Set not be used,
Call to Glory is also not of relevance
in this moment.
>> Okay, here we go. Sand Soldier going in.
>> For turn. And Guard.
>> And the And Guard as well. That's going
to be the mighty Sand Soldier that could
>> My lucky
>> With no buff, he won't be able to
preserve that flora.
And if you're And if you're Squirtle,
you must be feeling on top of the world
right now. Currently four points up.
Colin only has a Rengar, very anemic on
runes as well. Worth noting they are all
order runes.
We'll have to consult the hand where
that's going to be an issue. Potentially
could be.
>> I mean, this is already looking a little
bit like a potential. I mean, you have
no time issue here in untimed topdeck.
So, a scoop angle is not really what
you're looking for, but it is looking
dire for Colin. It looks like Seth
Kingpin to base. Push back the Rengar
and pass. Prepare for a bigger offensive
turn in the next round.
>> Squirtle is going to hold to five. Still
has a multitude, an absolute commando
unit of Sand Soldiers ready to go.
And I think if you're Squirtle, this is
what you want to see in a top four game
one match here. Firmly in the driver's
seat. Up to six on that conquer.
>> Up to six.
>> He's just running away with this. Colin
also missing the early game drop.
Squirtle with a brutalizer is going to
be able to make two more Sand Soldier
tokens every turn that Colin does not
throw threats at him. He's just going to
go wider and wider in base with more
soldiers.
>> He's probably not even got any buffs in
play for Colin. Yeah, the deck is built
around buffs.
What else do we have? Four. That's going
to be the Azir sovereign champion
entering the battlefield. We all know
what that Azir can do, maneuvering sand
soldiers when it moves.
Leo, look at that base.
>> We are presenting game. We're finding
two body runes, which means punch first
is live
again. So, there is maybe
a chance to get
at least into these battlefields. Hall
of Legends is wide open.
But, the deck of Colin is not so crazy
flexible that you can just easily
go into one battlefield and then
threaten the other in the next turn,
unless you find your show stoppers.
Then, you could go into the Monastery of
Hirana,
deny a hold, and then in the next turn
push everything back, go into the Hall
of Legends.
>> Definitely trying to work out what to do
here.
Your eyes will be threatening game next
turn.
He does have two decently sized units to
play with here, but
when you're looking at that board state
over from Squirl equipment still left to
attach as well,
that brutalizer is giving you extra on
the turn it is attached.
Four cards, five cards in hand. You
know, one of them is a punch first.
>> Semi-finals
of the Riftbound Regional Qualifier in
Utrecht
is Colin's deck letting him down.
Finds a show stopper.
>> Okay.
>> That is looking like a rather offensive
push. Show stopper could buff a unit to
have some fallback action.
Push it into one of the battlefields.
>> We finally get a buff on on board as
well. I mean, you can use that legendary
ability
if
something with a buff is that the guards
>> Oh, we're going to see a hidden guards.
>> But the master will get brutalized.
>> Guards is going to be so strong with the
brutalizer as well.
>> And the brutalizer might force out the
punch first immediately or at least a
call to glory.
If you don't want to throw away all of
your runes yet, in fact, it is going to
be called to glory. Let's check out the
might. I think you can just spend your
buff to play for free, but that isn't
even necessary. If you conquer here, you
can draw a card
with the monastery.
>> Okay.
>> Question is, do you want to use that
effect or do you want to say, "Hey,
I really need every single point of
might right now,
and I'm so low on open runes that I
cannot
I cannot really utilize the cards that
I'm drawing."
>> I think you have to keep every morsel of
might right now
if I was calling.
So, it looks like it is the Rengar's.
>> Also, if he keeps the might, if he keeps
the buff or goes into one battlefield
after the showstopper is
used.
Let's see what is Squirtle deciding to
do. He can just conquer the Hall of
Legends with one sand soldier and then
go for a big big push with the Azir
sovereign.
>> I think that could be what we're eyeing
up here.
>> Yes, so many
>> a world in which you could Is a Risen
and that would make that even more
terrifying.
Ooh.
That is Azir sovereign push maneuvering
sand soldiers whenever it moves around.
>> One of the eight
>> big advantages of these decks. Oh, punch
first.
>> Okay.
A big five might swing there.
And Collin able to repel that sand
soldier offensive.
>> But now even more than before Collin
does not pack the punch in the next
turn. He's down to three single runes.
He's going to get to five in the next
turn.
Is there potential win condition for
Skrittle here to still
keep on attacking or do we build up a
massive defense in the Hall of Legends?
>> That is literally what I was just about
to say. He just said, "Well, I'm just
going to load up over here then." I
don't think your deck had a ton of
movement. Can you try and push me off?
Here comes the guards.
So, that means you're going to get a
ready sand soldier.
If you're paying the one as well.
>> I mean, we have
already built up so much, but we still
have the Azir sovereign. That is a lot
of tokens that Azir sovereign could pull
into the monastery of Ionia if we
wanted.
Keep in mind that set is buffed so much.
Azir is going in there.
>> And he can move over all the sand
soldiers, Leo. Look at this offensive
from the sand army.
I'm going to have to wait for the
graphic to tell me how much might that
is. 21 versus 18.
>> 23 with these two more recruit tokens.
>> AND THAT IS THE BIG SAND SOLDIER
offensive who still squirtle game one in
a record amount of time there. That game
was over. Blink and you'll miss it.
Squirtle one game away from advancing to
the finals here. Colin is left reeling.
We're going into our side deck phase,
Leo. What stood out to you about that
match?
>> Honestly, he might be in the finals just
before we have our second top four match
ready.
That is absolutely insane. Also, shout
out to the people behind the desks here
because they knew how much might there
was on this battlefield before the
players knew.
>> They said
I was in the weeds with that one,
production crew. Thank you very much for
getting that graphic up there nice and
fast.
But, yeah. And that's the thing about
the sovereign. It can just maneuver your
units around. And when you have so many
tokens all with, you know, brutalizers,
Eye of the Herald, BF swords, all those
equipment, the might just adds up so
fast.
>> He went up to 23.
And that wasn't even all that deck does,
right? That was without a rise. Keep
that in mind. He never used a rise in
that game. Again,
and he didn't even have to just wait in
that one battlefield. That was also
super impressive. He could have just
gone up to seven, put 23 might into the
Hall of Legends, and then defend there.
But, that is not his style. He knew,
"Hey, there can only be one call to
glory. Otherwise, you are completely
exhausted on runes. You have 18 might
there. I can do 23. No need to wait for
one more turn. I can push, push, push
with my sand soldiers."
>> It's exactly what he did. I really
appreciate I said that offensive play. I
think had that been me, I would have
just sat Hall of Legends and said, "I
don't I don't think you can come over
here, so let's go on to game two."
Squirtle said, "You know what? I don't
think you can stop me right now." And
that is Azir, sovereign champion. And
the synergy between that and the mass
amount of sand soldier tokens you can
make is honestly
beautiful to see. So,
if you're Colin now, I think it's safe
to say they get out of the gates kind of
quickly. How would you Do you think he
has to approach this game too
differently?
>> Well, he better find a two-drop.
That is That is the way he should
approach that game. Better find
something to play early game. It is
going to be incredibly hard to first of
all play versus Squirtle, second of all
to combat the sheer strength of Azir.
Azir, the deck with the best early drops
in the game. Three might unit for just
two energy is absolutely strong.
Disgusting how consistently the decks
puts out these powerhouses. So, that is
already for your body order deck really
hard to combat. You don't have some sort
of mass removal.
>> Yeah.
>> You just You want to fight, but I feel
like Azir just wants to fight a lot
more.
>> Yeah, two different very different
styles of fighting. Well, you got the
set that's going to present bigger
threats, mighty threats, scary threats,
normally buffed threats. But, Azir, as
you say, it's just sand soldier here, BF
sword there, brutalizer. And it the
maths gets so out of hand so quickly,
especially with Irelia and Harald
getting in the recruits as well.
>> I mean,
honestly, he breaks so hard that game.
>> Yeah, he did.
>> Question is how good can the side deck
be? He had a sabotage that one got
defied. Sabotage, of course, always a
good way to get rid of arises before
they even happen.
But, also another card that we have seen
multiple times in body decks, mainly
also to counter Aurora,
is Akshan mischievous. And that one
doesn't have quite the same effect as
versus an Aurora deck. But,
if you steal a BF sword, that is first
of all one less sand soldier from a
arise.
>> Yeah.
>> Second of all, your Akshan all of a
sudden is a seven might unit, which you
better protect because otherwise the BF
sword goes back to your opponent.
Those are all some nifty little plays,
but looking at that side deck,
that isn't the craziest thing I've ever
seen, right? There's the Azir has very,
very little blowout cards. Even in the
last game, we have seen
that Prismaticism in the top eight match
found the Thermobeam relatively early in
the game.
Did that help him at all? No, he didn't
even get to the point where he could
press the Thermobeam button. That is
because you need so much tempo already
to use this card. You have to be at
least on par with your opponent in terms
of might and units, so you are allowed
to
play this five energy card that costs
two power.
Yes, then you're going to deny bigger
rises, but whenever are you going to do
that versus an Azir that at least has
decent draws? So, that is also something
to watch out for. The deck has very,
very little consistent and powerful
counterplay. No silver bullets versus
Azir.
>> Yeah, and even if you was to try and
lean on that action, one thing I want to
draw attention to is that would cost two
two power. And we saw in that game the
power just slid away. He was left with
all the runes right towards the end of
the game. So, that answer would be very
costly. And if Squirtle can just stay in
the game and maneuver around there,
I feel as if Colin's answers are so
expensive, the more hoops Squirtle can
jump through, the slower and slower
Colin gets.
>> But,
then again,
if he gets to play Fiora on curve going
first, yeah, gets to buffer up,
>> True, true.
>> he could potentially run away with the
game. There is a world in which
Squirtle does not find all of those
combat tricks and
can't really get over that Fiora, has to
invest multiple resources, and when he
finally gets to kill Fiora, she just
gets recalled.
And that is also, I think, a way how
this could go. Colin starting, going to
choose Grove of the God-Willow.
He's shaking his head. He's not passing,
is he? He's not passing, is he?
>> It was a pass. No. No, Colin. Not like
this, my son. No. Not in top four.
But we are just going to see the pass.
Squall again off to the races, the
brutalizer plus Sun Soldier combination.
>> Going to have a four drop. This Is this
I feel like this is very similar to game
uh game one, right? Four coming down
again. Squirtle.
>> Fiora is looking good there, but again,
there's no real good way to buff it
right now.
>> there.
>> He has Showstopper, so that works, but
using a Showstopper when your unit is
going to be ready anyways just to buff
it for one energy and one power seems a
little bit like a waste.
>> So, it's a Squall's turn now. Does have
another equipment, expensive one, good
one.
A BF sword plus V.
Currently a five might Sun Soldier right
there.
>> I love
in Riftbound that the aggressive decks
like Azir
>> I think you can call it an aggro to
mid-range deck.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> is not scoring every time
it can.
And he just says, "Hey, I'm going to
lose units
and I need to score multiple points
basically over a few turns in the mid
game. The first point that I can score
does not really matter."
>> It's over to Colin now.
Does have the
Cloudfilled unit there in hand up as
help.
>> Fiora needs to play another unit before
it gets buffed. It doesn't buff any
other units in any way.
>> Sabotage is in hand for Colin though.
Could potentially use that.
Don't know how impactful it could be
this moment in time.
>> Okay, if you if you really want to play
a lot here
>> Yeah.
>> there is a
puny little line that could actually do
something.
Always start with a Cithria
and a set Kingpin. Cithria gets buffed.
Let's see
how we continue here.
>> Okay. So it is over to Squirtle now.
>> Going here.
>> Looks like we are going to
we are going to showdown into Grove of
the God Willow and into Seat of Power,
both of which are going to be
successful, of course, cuz Colin is
tapped out.
>> I love the patience on the first turn or
on the second turn rather and not
getting a conquer, but now saying
I can get a draw of Seat of Power.
>> Yep.
>> Hell yeah. I'll take that. Everything in
gets two points at once, of course, also
being on the even points really
incentivizes you to go for that play.
The big question is now how much can you
capitalize off of that? Can you build up
more of these sense soldiers because we
are not in the Hall of Legends, we are
in Seat of Power, Grove of the God
Willow. Therefore, you cannot really
play one equipment to make two sense
soldier tokens.
Which is still so broken.
>> Really is.
So we are consulting. Is that they
cannot take their time to work out here?
Just debating on what to do. Remember,
these are untimed matches here in our
top cuts of players. They can just take
their time to think.
>> I don't think he has an equipment.
>> I don't think so. We are seeing a lot of
high cost in their hands.
>> That's just an Azir pass.
>> Champion is here pass.
It might be.
On guard to draw one.
>> Yeah.
Sure.
>> No, it doesn't draw one, but you push
the
set Kingpin in and then just kill it
with your seven might sense soldier.
>> So of course it doesn't draw one but
that charm coming in.
>> Now you thought we were still in the
dreaming tree my friend. That is That is
not how this works anymore.
Good times.
>> Yeah, so Squirl will present an
offensive threats here. Colin
does get a buff.
Not on the one you want though.
>> What is happening with runes this
weekend by the way? Only having one
order rune as well on the side of Colin.
>> Looks like that sabotage is going to go
through though. So we are going to get
that hand knowledge. There is an arise
in that hand. There is a death grip.
Is that another discipline yet? And then
on guard.
>> I was going to say perhaps you take out
the discipline to deny card draw because
arises frankly not doing that much right
now. However,
death grip also draws you a card.
So you're not really going to deny card
I think in the end.
It's most likely going to be that
discipline. Uh sorry, arise.
Death grip also
really really threatening though.
>> Yeah, all of those uh potential yeah
targets and all good targets and have
their use case.
Sometimes you prefer your option just to
be a nice easy one but
every single one of them
a potential sabotage target.
>> So if you take out arise actually takes
out the discipline. Let's the arise
stay in Squirl sand.
So now we just need to when we're going
into combat because he needs to catch
back up on points rather soon sooner
rather than later.
How do you play this? You know there is
a death grip. So if you are pushing into
for example the seat of power with
Fiora,
death grip could be used.
And if you are then not buffed on the
Fiora, you're going to lose it.
>> Ooh.
>> That
is huge though.
>> There we go, as what you mentioned in
the in between games one and two that
Akshan sneakily
going to steal that BF sword. One thing
I do want to keep in mind though is you
did mention that Akshan Colin needs to
keep that one alive cuz if it does die,
that BF sword will float back over.
>> So, a potential line here. Oh,
Showstopper of course we want to have
this buff on Akshan and we know that now
that the BF sword is gone, Deathgrip is
not too threatening.
Push it over here.
You could end up
going to seven with both. No, you're at
eight now. So, Deathgrip actually
doesn't tip it over.
I think Squirtle is going to try and
boost the power seated.
>> He wants to play the Showstopper.
>> Sure. I will try to
destroy this Soul Soldier above this.
>> I just want
>> Okay.
>> Draw card.
>> Priest
>> open
the top sand soldier giving up Grove of
the God Willow.
But, this is what Colin's deck is built
to do.
Oh, another sabotage. We know there's a
defense for that.
That Look at the runes though for Colin.
This is quite an all-in play here, but
this is very different. The board
definitely favors Colin.
>> But, he is playing. He is in this game
right now. Squirtle is not running away
on points and very important to mention
something I didn't even consider. Oh,
another Unguard use takes out Wonder
Rise, but there's a second. But,
>> Fair enough.
>> This Akshan,
if it would die, you can spend the buff
to recall it and I don't think that your
opponent's going to get the BF sword
back then. So, I think that Akshan in
set is way more broken than in any other
deck.
>> That's such a good interesting
interaction. I never would consider but
yeah, you're right.
>> Yeah, this is a very different game here
for Colin. This is what his deck is
built to do. Be, you know, be for these
chunky four or five cost units and just
have them import their will over the
game.
>> He even took the BF sword away. Arise
does nothing here. He basically needs a
cheap
equipment here.
Has he found it?
>> We have the brutalizer, no? Would the
device not count for that one?
>> We have one brutalizer, but that gets
you one sand soldier from Arise.
>> Okay, we have another brutalizer,
though.
>> Wow.
>> It's not the most What's the word I'm
looking for here?
Heroic Arise, but we are going to play
it out for the first time here in our
top four feature match.
Two sand soldiers, both of which will
come in play ready.
>> But I think
Colin might get to hold here.
>> I think he will.
I think he will.
>> Because if you throw Oh, he's actually
going to go
>> But now you can just expend the buff
there from your legend ability. So, the
action essentially just gets put back to
base.
>> Yeah, but that's still not too bad.
First, Squirtle retreats the other sand
soldier. Because he has just expended
one
power to stop that draw from the Grove
of the God Willow.
And honestly, if you're looking at
Colin, he's at one rune.
That's not too bad. You can you you are
fine with spending one power.
Thing is, Colin is now so I want to say
statted. He has so much might already,
such powerful units.
It is going to be
I think he's going to be very fine with
minimal plays in the next turns.
>> I think you're right. When you've got
the sort of might advantage and chunky
cards, as it were,
you have a lot more
So, liberty
over the game. You don't have to do so
many things. So, it's just going to pass
over from Squirtle now over to Colin.
Didn't get the whole point.
Well, I say board state definitely
favors Colin.
Let's see what we can do.
>> Do you remember the interview that
Barrett had with Colin where Barrett
said, "Hey, it's so impressive how you
are playing constantly with very little
runes to your side?"
And that is again what he is doing. He's
playing on three runes in turn
I don't know, 10?
>> Yeah.
>> And he doesn't seem bothered about it at
all. Pushes the auction into the Grove
of the Willow. And if he has arena ball,
it's also going to be able to protect it
afterwards.
Seat of power draw.
>> There it is.
So, we can protect that auction again
from up with our legend ability.
>> I guess.
>> Here we go. This is a very different
game for Colin.
Starting to impose his will in this top
four. Remember, he does need to win this
game.
>> I didn't. Yeah, if you want to
Interesting.
I mean, otherwise it just gets Well, he
didn't even He didn't mulligan anything,
so it would just be a shuffle. So.
>> Some sportsmanship there from our
players. We love to hear that. It's over
to Squirtle now, though.
I know a few runes there. That was a
high cost. Could that have been a void,
perhaps?
The Azir with a accelerator as well, of
course.
>> Yeah, that works. A void developed in
base.
Could see that possibly.
But also a BF sword plus
one energy for Azir.
Many cards that can cost five energy at
once.
Not necessarily at once with the BF
sword.
>> Wow, and this right here. What a
different game to game one where game
one Squirtle was off to the races. This
is much more of a two and fro affair.
Colin now developed that arena bar will
be able to get buffs in play so so much
easier. That Fiona hasn't even been a
threat yet. You imagine next turn if
they can catch a buff
that will start slamming
into those sand soldiers. And Squirtle
knows it's a different game. Look at his
body language.
Really has to think about every single
play.
>> Auction is really carrying this game on
his back for Colin taking away that beer
of salt.
>> I we know two bottom cards I think.
The sabotage
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Good call.
>> The auction
hasn't only removed the constant plus
three might that Squirtle would get from
that beer of salt that he paid so much
energy for
but it has also taken away a sand
soldier that would have been ready from
the arise. I think we're very good to
that we're ready.
But still.
>> And it's just an eight
>> more units slamming around as well.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean but if nothing else it's almost
indestructible as long as it keeps that
buff up as well.
>> And since you have the arena bar
>> Yeah.
>> very likely that it's going to keep that
buff.
Seat of power so three of cloud field
dies.
Gives another point
to Squirtle but now as of the next turn
Colin with the arena bar is going to be
able to set up that Victoria Fiora
victorious
with another small boost.
>> Another sabotage in a hand by the way.
When you want solo ruins you might be
able to weave that in yet.
Want to keep those in for that punch
first as well perhaps. Left grip.
>> to the sand soldier in the back.
>> You really only drop bangers, huh?
>> Yeah.
>> Did you say you only drop bangers?
Love to hear that.
>> Uh, so then
Bop it.
>> Squirtle, perhaps playing around Call to
Glory.
>> Oh, you can
use Squirtle.
>> Only one Sand Soldier in play though,
Lier.
>> Uh
Floated one.
Check.
>> Yeah.
>> Going.
>> Already at plus 10 might. Adds a
Brutalizer to it so he can't get jump
scared by Call to Glory.
But there's that legend ability though.
>> Charm the action here.
Yeah. Sorry.
>> Has the charm, pulls the action in and
gets the BF sword back. Squirtle is back
in this game. Floated one energy before
so he can't develop the Azir. All of a
sudden, the entire board is flipped and
Colin can't believe this. How did I get
back into this unfavorable position? BF
sword put on that Sand Soldier in the
Grove of the God Willow. SQUIRTLE IS
BACK IN THIS GAME.
>> He's apologizing to you and draws in top
four.
>> Yeah. Sorry.
>> Absolutely unbelievable.
>> That's a win.
>> We were just saying about how strong
that action was. Squirtle basically
killed it twice in the same turn.
Now it's sent to the trash. Five points
for Squirtle.
The Azir has ended the field as well.
>> But this ain't over yet.
This Sand Soldier token is at four at
seven might. There is a punch first in
hand for Colin. He has at four runes.
Therefore, he has the option to just go
punch first, make this Fiora mighty,
push it into the battlefield, kill the
Sand Soldier, then first mate gank over
to the seat of power,
draw one more card because you play the
first mate possibly into the Grove of
the God Willow. That is entirely
optional, by the way.
And then
>> You have enough runes for that as well?
>> Yeah, punch first floats one energy.
>> Yeah, okay. Yeah, you are correct.
Wow, I think I think you're right. This
is what we're seeing.
So, punch first.
Sand Soldier sent to the trash.
That is now a mighty Fiora.
Oh, we can buff it as well. Might as
well.
>> And that is
I think really, really important. The
big question that Colin might be asking
himself right now is First Mate into the
Grove of the God Willow or First Mate
into base. What are we going to do?
Because Fiora
is protected from the set brawler
ability. Right now, you can get an extra
draw. But you're so low on runes.
>> Possibly win this game.
Good question.
Maybe it's going to be the hippity
hoppity Fiora.
I mean, I like that.
I do like that.
>> Being a ganking gangster
in those battlefields.
>> Ganking gangster, that is exactly what
his Fiora would be. Has got ganking now.
He's debating.
It's all to play for here.
Looks like I think that is the First
Mate being eyed up.
>> Ah, is it going to be the draw or is it
going to be First Mate into base? Three
might that would be traded away freely
in the next turn. Big downside of that.
At this point, you are so low on runes.
Is it wise to go for extra draws or do
you want to keep those units even if
they are not that strong saved in your
base? Colin decides on base and retreats
the Fiora. Wants to keep the buff.
Doesn't want to deramp any further and
says, "I don't need the fifth point."
Would be uneven anyways. No Seat of
Power for me. No, sir.
>> Here comes the Scuttle Crab.
Good action for your card, Colin. play
you draw one.
>> Does he find another equipment? Another
equipment would be huge. IT'S GOLDEN
SHIELD. Another token.
Does not equip the BF sword.
So, I can imagine because he took the
Doran's shield. He's putting the BF
sword on the Azir. Are we pushing?
>> Here you go.
We're going for double.
No, he's going to be a charge into the
go of the quad hollow and the pass
over to Colin now. Punch first bind of
the top.
>> But he only is at one body wound. We are
so dangerous to close to losing this
game. Would basically have to trade both
of these units into this
Azir sovereign.
But that would work.
We have eight might in total.
And we could even
retreat the Fiora, recall it with the
Azir
with the set brawler ability.
>> Oh, no.
>> Yes.
>> But now we're into the seat of power
instead.
>> Oh, and develops another Fiora.
>> Ooh, double buff Fiora.
>> Wait a second.
>> This Leo is very interesting.
>> That is great, actually.
That is a whole different angle. You are
making this feel a defensive power.
>> calls for yourself. It's going to be
super tough for Squirtle unless he rips
something crazy off the top to get into
that seat of power. You're going to go
to six and then on the next turn
>> Draw cards.
>> You can gang
>> Gang come both over.
>> 10.
>> Wow,
Colin finding an alternate win
conditions here as it were.
Changing strategies.
When you have so many keywords, the
Fiora can to those ganking gangsters as
we said.
>> Squirtle has six runes, so if he top
decks a rise, that could potentially
happen.
>> We've seen two so far, right? One got
sabotage, I think. Did it actually?
Can't remember. We've definitely seen at
least one.
>> Now, Squirtle's in somewhat of a
comfortable spot because Colin
honestly is just at five points. So,
even if he gives the holding point over,
even if he says, "Hey, you can gang into
the Grove of the God Willow, you're
going to just go to seven, and I can go
wide and base Squirtle."
Just like ever so often, he might be the
one
who's actually readying the token.
But, if you push into that battlefield
now, you have to make sure
that you're going to get something out
of it because if you're just trading
away one Fiora, that it one is not even
going to die.
>> No, we have to try and as you say, be
more efficient now with our combat.
But, looking at this board state now,
I'm not really sure if we can challenge
both of those Fiora. They would have
shield as well right now.
>> Squirtle one point away
from entering the finals once again.
Another
undefeated run possibly
for Squirtle. That would go down in the
ever so young Rift Bound history.
Squirtle
>> Now, this is interesting. We can send in
the Scuttle Crab as a sacrificial lamb
just to get that hand knowledge, of
course.
>> Doesn't even have to be sacrificial. You
can put a Brutalizer on it, and then it
could trade away the First Mate
if you would want that.
Pushes it into the Seat of Power, and
now the Scuttle Crab would trade with a
First Mate. Yeah, takes it out.
Brutalizer
used well.
>> There's that Scuttle Crab giving that
hand knowledge there, the sabotage and
the
punch first.
>> You did the math right? You're good.
>> Not really. Like
uh that's
eight. Should I talk?
Yeah, sure.
Sure.
>> I cannot believe this. He is powering
through this. He has so many runes left
open. There is a six might Fiora
victorious. So many gear, so many
equipment on that sand soldier. And
Squirtle does it again. BACK-TO-BACK
FINALS HERE IN EUROPE with so much
might, so many sand soldiers. No matter
how sticky the situation or how sticky
the unit, Squirtle finds a way through
this.
>> Squirtle marching back to a finals. Will
he become a two-time RQ champion? He's
doing a fantastic job of doing so right
now. Always calm, always collected.
Squirtle wins our top four match here.
>> Who is this guy, honestly? Just never
losing games of Rift Bound?
>> Even when it looks so dire, Leo.
He just pulls the wins out of his back
pocket. That second game, Leo. That
looks terrifying for him to play
against. And he just finds the answers
every single time.
>> I mean, you're right. When Colin had a
first sabotage, Squirtle won a rise,
then gave him another draw with a death
death grip.
He found another a rise to block the
second sabotage. Then he ripped up a
death grip from the top, found for the
next a rise the brutalizer from the top.
Squirtle finding the perfect sequencing
of cards off the top in this grind game.
Colin really had the biggest uphill
battle
that was impossible. I think at this
point it was fate.
>> Even with that action machine kills.
>> Yeah, the the double charm one, not the
double charm, but the double kill on the
action and just to get that BF sword
back. What a heads up play.
And then again, we with that double
Fiora set up was able to just slowly but
surely get point after points after
points and those sand soldiers again
that this was the set up here I thought
I'm not sure how you come out of this
was just able to battle through with
that absolute cornucopia
of equipment and Squirtle wins the top
four match advancing to the final.
>> Once again Squirtle in the finals
definitely one of the best players in
the world right now but enough of us we
have him in the interview area with
Barrett once again let's give it over to
Barrett.
>> I'm joined once again I don't know how
many times I'm going to be able to sit
next to you here but Squirtle once again
you have made and solidified yourself in
the finals of a second regional
qualifier back to back as you have gone
to them.
>> Yes.
>> No one not a lot of people can say that
or let alone say they've been to a
finals twice now there's literally a
handful and you are now in that same
conversation.
What do you think that you could be the
second two-time regional qualifier
champion right after Alan just did it?
>> I hope I am I wish to be the solid I
couldn't attend the other regional
because Alan I've got it first.
>> But it it actually almost to me speaks
even higher volumes the fact that you
have gone to less of them include we can
even talk about Bologna where you still
performed incredibly well and by the way
on Ezreal which was again the same
legend that Alan was playing and won
with but now here you are a specialist a
representative of the Azir deck and you
play so well
Squirtle I've seen you lose one game.
>> I have lost more.
>> I understand I understand that that's
I'm thank you for saying that too but
there is a world I just want you to
think a little bit forward. The other
semi-finals match is being played. And
you might
have a situation where you have to play
against Dewali,
another regional qualifier champion.
If you beat him,
you would have had to beat Allan,
Prismatism,
and Dewali in the same tournament. This
Do you think
Do you think that would solidify you
almost more
of a caliber player than some of these
other champions?
>> I don't know. That's that's the
question, right? I need to be humble.
>> No, I I That's And I'm glad you are. You
are one of the chillest people I've sat
next to here, and you play the game so
well and collected and full of
confidence, but you're always smiling,
too. You must be having a blast.
>> Yes, I I'm having fun. Yeah.
Uh
The The I love the game, so that's
that's nice.
Uh and all my opponents are being nice.
Like I'm also getting a bit lucky, as we
saw.
But that's good.
I I think that helps to play well,
right? If you are enjoying it, you are
doing it okay. If not, it's like what I
don't want to play. I want to eat well.
>> And the last time we talked, it was
about if you made misplays and you know,
being the biggest critic about yourself.
But now seeing, you know, on the other
side of not just you having success, but
enjoying the game, loving the game,
and being really good at it. Squirtle,
congratulations. You have made it to the
finals here in Utrecht, and that will be
coming, but we must get back to the
action. We have another semi-finalist to
meet, so let's get to it.
>> Oh, thank you so much for that, Barrett.
Yes, we still have one more finalist. We
need to work out who Squirtle will be
trying to arise against in the final. So
So haven't got long, so we can hop
straight into that top four match and
I'm excited to see how this one's going
to pan out, Leo.
>> 100% and that looks like he's going to
face Victor. So Diana versus Victor,
who's going to have the
bigger mind, better minds, smarter
minds?
>> More calm minds.
Anything along those lines?
>> Also not bad.
>> So yes, this is everyone's big bad scary
deck of the format, Diana. One of the
most played decks in our format. We see
many top names piloting it and the
Violet, of course, is one of them.
You know, that chaos calm combination
so strong, that Huawei riding around the
battlefield, causing carnage and the
whole host of other offensive options
and defensive options, of course, like
flash, smoke screen, Ren Bu student,
gust, wide the wind.
Quite honestly, it's a scary deck to
play against.
>> Dwali really deserved best of Diana. One
of the most fought for legends. The
first one was Nice Boy in Sydney. The
second one was Alanzq in Vancouver
taking down the entire tournament. And
now Dwali, that are Those are some
names. Then of course, we have Victor
Origins Legend the last tournament in
Europe where you can get those best of
Origins
legends.
Now
look at this deck. Chakram Dancer is a
new inclusion to the deck.
Ambush units I think Ambush units that
have
decent might in relation to their energy
cost
are already really strong.
>> Yes.
>> Ambush is just so incredible and the
fact that Chakram Dancer gets your other
units shield
doesn't doesn't suck, no.
>> No, you're right. You almost getting
that Ambush tag for free at that point
when it's a free cost of free might. And
when you are a token based deck like
Victor, being able to give those shields
can just out of nowhere as it were as it
were can really just affect the maths.
So, it's kind of similar to the last
round, actually, where Squirls that was
all about the sand soldiers. Victor deck
loves a good token and or charm and not
charm a sprite as well.
>> Quite curious to see who gets to go
first.
Rarely any
deck ever is so punishing when you're
going first against it and you miss your
two drop. Like Victor, because Victor is
going to throw down a dredger and a
recruit token and then double conquer
immediately with little to no downside
for them. So, you got to make sure if
you want to go first versus that deck
that you have
something to play.
>> That's the big you can't really miss
your one drop there as Victor, can you?
With that legend ability you can always
at least get that recruit down.
>> One.
>> Mhm.
>> All right, next to mulliganing that main
deck salvage.
>> All right, it looks like the value will
be kicking us off here kicking us off
here in our top four feature match.
Uh-oh, just going to be the pass back
over though. What's going on in our top
four matches, Leo?
>> So many people are breaking Look at this
immediately two units. That is
threatening a double conquer on the
second turn. And carrion dredger is even
one of those cards if it gets removed in
combat afterwards.
What does it matter?
>> You get the bird back.
>> Exactly, you're getting a bird back.
Question is is Dwali now playing out a
Diana or are we developing a vex in base
for maximum
energy efficiency because I'm spotting a
gust in the hand as well. So, you could
potentially remove that carrion dredger
with the Diana ability as well for free.
>> The carrion dredger that would not pop
for the bird if it is gusted back to
hand, of course. Are we going to see
that gust?
It is potential potentially live.
Of course, we're getting it for free
thanks to our Diana ability, of course.
So, back to hand. No point there, but
this recruit now has free reign.
>> But, at the very least, this feels like
a plus one for Rednexel, even though he
really wants those double pointers.
>> Yeah, you're at one.
>> Goes into the forbidden waste, and
that's a really, really nice one,
because
your recruit tokens, they are very
unlikely to stick.
Oh, that is an eclipse. That telegraphs
>> Keep it.
>> potentially a bellows breath from hand
into the base.
>> Oh, wow, it does. That Diana's going to
be sent to the trash, Leo.
So, Dvalin's going to start his turn
three with no units again, and another
recruit's going to come down, Leo.
>> That might have not happened if you
developed a vaccine base on that turn,
because then that would have cost so
much power. Now, we're going to see Vex
plus Titan. Only one point for Rednexel,
I think. Dvalin's in a decent spot when
you're just looking at the board.
However, the value engine of that Diana
deck, if you do not have a Quay
developed, is heavily dependent on this
Diana Lunari.
>> We're going to see the recruit come back
to base.
It's going. Going to see three there.
Gold token coming in.
That card sharp.
>> Rednexel staring over to Dvalin.
He's considering to take a gold token.
>> I suppose.
>> I think that's what we just That's what
we decided.
>> Okay.
>> So, only one gold token for Rednexel.
>> Finds honest broker.
>> Pass to you.
>> Yeah.
>> And he passes, so no Diana ability will
be used. Otherwise, that could have been
if the recruit token pushed into the
abandoned hall, a very, very cool
situation for a acceptable losses to
kill a gold token.
>> It is back over to Dvalin now. They're
taking breath.
Body language knows he's on slightly on
the back foot here, but only two points
down, not, you know, completely
unsurmountable, of course.
>> Could have been worse.
>> Could have been very worse. Vex Abyssal
will hit that battlefield there.
Obviously stunning any unit that comes
into play. Not that's going to be too
impactful, I feel, in this match up, but
it is just going to be the past all
those runes that open, Leo.
>> There's not a lot of might on the board
for Red Nexus. Already needs to get rid
of this Vex, and getting rid of Vex is
very, very costly. Especially in this
match up, because you kind of have to
target it with something, unless you
want to go for an Imperial Decree push,
and then throw some tokens in there.
But, if you Imperial Decree,
there's really a decent chance that
you're just going to get flash or
especially
>> answered. All right, doing it while
those runes are open. I don't I don't
think you're going to be able to charge
into that Vex and have that go your way.
>> Arcane Victor leader, gorgeous card.
Being developed there with the Gold Gear
token used immediately.
In case of doubt, make token.
It's always a good old Victor
philosophy.
>> Yeah, that's the Victor 101 right there.
He's going to go into where the Honest
Broker is.
Sureing up that side a little bit.
>> Playing around his own battlefield.
If I'm being waste,
is
an old play by himself.
>> And the car chop going up there as well.
Okay.
Devoli has a lot of runes to play with
now. I imagine this will be a turn where
he's going to try and clear away some of
these recruits.
Oh. Maybe.
Mhm.
>> A potential Moonfall push
would play into a lot of things,
actually. If you push the Titan onto
that battlefield, and you say, "Okay,
Moonfall.
>> Yeah.
>> Push in one more recruit perhaps to get
some more value out of it. First of all,
in the next turn your tightener is just
going to die because it's at zero might.
But also, using a Moonfall to then
possibly be Wages of Pain or Bellow's
Breath or whatnot.
That would actually hurt quite a bit.
>> Let's have a look. Looks like a Ride the
Wind has been eyed up here then.
>> Uh 1 second.
I'm going to choose target. Sorry, this
and this.
>> Now I'm kind of convinced that we're
going to see Moonfall.
>> Yeah.
Oh, we're going to see some kind of
reaction.
Oh, that Chakram Dancer that gives all
the units shield.
>> And wait a second. Maybe he's under the
impression that the Chakram Dancer then
is not being stunned.
>> So, it's stunned.
>> Okay, yeah, it is stunned because it
gets in there onto that battlefield. But
Vex was previously already at a
battlefield.
But all of your units have shield now.
Let's see how important that is. But now
Dwali sees that his opponent is
completely exhausted on runes and that
is the space where you want to be in as
Diana.
>> And that means you have free reign.
>> My friend is here with a drink for me.
Oh, [__] Okay, my bad. Thanks.
>> Yeah, some hydration. Very important.
>> Yeah, got to stay hydrated after three
long days of Rift Bound, especially if
you're one match away from the final, of
course.
>> That looked like two runes and the
Diana. Moonfall.
Can we even push in the Victor leader?
>> I was I was just trying to work out
>> Sounds good, sir.
>> Uh That's got How much might does that
Victor leader have?
>> I think that would be a little bit too
much because all of the other units
currently that are currently on the
battlefield have shield. So, it's two
might
from
the
three drop, one might from the Honest
Broker, and then there would be two more
might from the victor leader.
>> What I want to do with the victor?
>> The card shop.
So, you are already
in a bit of a pickle because
>> So,
with this
>> you cannot clear everything.
>> Yeah.
I'll priority. Put that minus.
>> Meaningful.
I think with the chakram dancer
there is in total four might in that
battlefield.
>> I'll hold priority.
And so, I'm going to target this
battlefield, target your victor.
>> Okay.
>> Hold priority.
>> Yep.
>> Uh
>> Smoke screen.
>> And smoke screen your victor.
>> Okay.
So, he's a minus four.
Yeah, he's minus three and then he'll
become minus four from here. So, he's
going to be
>> He's going to be minus four after this.
Cuz this this put it this puts it to a
minimum of one.
>> Yeah, so another two he's going to be
minus five. I guess, yeah.
And then if he dies at the same time as
all the stuff you don't get recruits.
>> Yeah, I don't know.
>> Okay, okay.
>> So, that's all of these are minus one
and this is minus two, but we don't have
enough dice.
>> Yeah.
>> Ah, there's more there.
>> Okay.
>> So, we're rearranging the might that
we're having on the battlefield right
now. I can imagine that we are right now
at
four might in total.
>> Well, this one is was at two and now
it's at
uh
>> They all have a shield?
>> Yeah.
>> So,
>> at two and now it's at zero for the
this.
>> Yeah, it's minus one from
uh
one target is a minus two.
>> basic uh
>> It's plus one, minus two.
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's minus one from the might.
>> Oh, you're saying minus one from the
base. Okay, sure, sure, sure.
So, this is this is
>> zero.
>> Zero. This is
>> two.
>> Two. Yeah, yeah.
>> One, one, zero.
>> But, even if there are units with zero
might on that battlefield and you are
basically tying with four might in
total,
you cannot kill everything.
>> This is done. Correct.
>> So, you have to apply at least one
damage.
>> Cuz then you only have two and one,
right? Okay, so my four damage I will
split so that
I deal
um
one one one one I think kills all of
those and leaves the the card sharp
alone.
>> Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, leaves the card sharp alone.
>> So, my Vex just moves back.
>> Yes. Vex is going to recall.
It's a pretty good trade off you'll take
that all things considered.
>> This is your alone now?
>> Yes.
>> Nice.
>> So, now the tide turner can just go in
there and clean that one up.
So, I'm fantastic swing.
>> That should be the third one.
>> Yeah.
Three.
>> So, it's three to three right now?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
You have three cards?
>> Yes.
>> They got so many ruins open, Leo.
But he doesn't have that many cards. The
value engine has been shut off the Diana
killed early
from Red Nexul. So, he has the at least
has that going for him.
>> We stopped it at there. It's ready.
>> And since the Vex was ready when it
battled and the forbidding waste,
it couldn't kill everything and recalled
ready.
You could have moved it.
>> Sure, I'll just pass.
>> I think.
>> Let's hope so.
Is over to Red Nexul now, though.
All ready to go to Lee set coming in.
Lee set I should say coming in ready.
>> Yeah, that's fine.
That's four.
>> Mhm.
Recruit going to charge in there on that
tide turner.
That's going to charge in there as well
at the top.
>> Three to five.
>> Yeah, three to five.
What else do we have to play?
All of a sudden the momentum is back on
Red Nexul's side. Has
decent amount of cards in hand and I
reckon these do a little bit more than
the cards that D'wal had because he has
double honest broker and acceptable
losses, if I remember correctly. And
honest broker, if you
or hard bargain,
if you are way behind on runes, really
doesn't do that much.
>> Yeah.
I'm going to hide a card as well.
That's the thing about that Victor that
you spend so much just to get rid of
those tokens, and it just explodes and
goes straight back.
>> If that's a hidden blade, you don't even
get to have a really, really nice trade
into that forbidding race.
>> the hand.
Can't develop any units with that, Leo.
>> Would agree. You can push into the
abandoned hall and then try to just use
acceptable losses
to get one might from the abandoned
hall, but that really plays into
>> Um
>> some other cards.
>> I know face breaker.
>> I mean, if you have the hidden blade,
you kill your own recruit token. You're
going to still get abandoned hall boost
onto Vaxen Sao.
>> There's that hard bargain.
>> Sure. I'll pay.
>> He's going to pay the extra, though.
>> And then
>> Hard bargain again.
>> I can't play both of that. Good.
So, it does not resolve.
>> Mhm.
>> This one does not resolve, but that is
abandoned hall times two for D'wal.
>> There's that face breaker, though.
So, both units are stunned.
>> us
>> And he's passing double hold going to
seven
is massive, especially in the Victor
deck. You can now either, because there
is only this Vaxen on the battlefield,
potentially try to double hold.
Think you might want to retreat at least
Vaxen Sao
just to threaten it with those one my
tokens.
All puts everything in there. Wants to
put up at least a little bit of might to
threaten that Vex.
>> Another recruit over here.
>> Yeah, you want card locks?
>> Has another card in hand to Wally also
very low on cards.
>> Okay, here we go.
Wally would need to break both of these
holds.
Only a Vex against the world.
>> What he really needs is a right to win
the plus something.
>> And that is just going to be the
concession there from Devoli Red Naxel
will take game one with that. Victor
Deck only one game away from getting
himself a slot in the final. Devoli
needs to issue a response and he needs
to issue it now.
>> And he needs to not draw all the
acceptable losses in the world. This is
unacceptable behavior from his own Deck
Red Naxel with his fans sitting there
from Greece supporting their favorite
player and he's crushing it. Victor Deck
almost
in the finals of the regional qualifier
in Utrecht.
>> I think the keyword there was almost
though. Still has to win one game
against Devoli, one of the best players
in the world,
but has won one already. Only one game
away. I think it is safe to say that
Devoli, as you said, opening hand really
wasn't the greatest. Had no units to
play with and sure you had the champion
did get dealt with by Red Naxel. Sure,
Vex eventually did get dealt with as
with that tie turner. So, it wasn't
just, you know, Red Naxel just run away
with it and um Devoli wasn't doing
anything.
But, it's safe to say had Devoli been
able to develop a few more units, a way
comes down by the windows you do say,
could have been a bit different.
>> Devoli saw his opening hand and decided
to after whiffing the first turn play,
which is also very, very tough
especially versus Victor,
decided to develop the Diana trying to
dig through more cards in the deck
and not develop the Vex.
And that Vex would have helped quite a
bit with Deflect
to not get immediately stomped
by that Eclipse
Bellows Breath combination that hit
really hard because he ran out of cards
so darn quick
after Diana got removed. If you do not
have Diana, you need way.
If you don't have way, you need the
draws from Diana. If you don't get
those, you're not going to find if
especially if you don't have Ravenbloom
Conservatory. You are not going to find
those stupifies from the top. You're not
going to find those stack decks.
The Diana deck, the value engine is a
machine that creates a snowball that
gets you more and more cards and the
deck is incredibly powerful with
multiple cards. And then if you are at
eight to 10 runes, you have units
developed like a way. You have endless
possibilities of your actions. But if
you do not get to draw those cards and
draw cards off of those cards, you just
do not get to win those games. You will
get out valued rather quickly because
the legend ability of Diana, it doesn't
give you value. It supports you a little
bit with tempo. If you don't have the
tempo,
it's just way worse than creating a
recruit token every single turn. And
this is how Victor runs away with those
games against decks like Diana.
Perfectly
identified from Rednaxel that he just
knows, "Hey,
if he has a way, okay. Perhaps I will
get a Cult the Week turn or something
like that. I have removal for that if he
is
risky with it, but I need to get rid of
this Diana first. Then I need to start
conquering."
>> You're so right, you know, cuz when um
Devalee did have the resources in hand,
you can see he was able to issue
responses and sort of stay in the game
as it were. But as you say, without the
Hurl Age draws, without the Diana draws,
once those options in their hand started
to shrink, all of a sudden, turns got
slower or shorter, I should say. And
then Rednaxel was able to just start
running away with it. What do you think
is going through I say Devalee? What do
you you could be getting sideboarded in
there to sort of help?
>> It Victor is such a roguish deck that it
is really really hard to sideboard
against it, right? You have a lot of
gear hate for most decks.
Singularity that we have seen in the
side deck of Diana is also not really
the best against it because you are
hitting tokens, but then what are you
going to do with those?
Starcross costs It just costs too much
to remove tokens and wartime line
something that people play versus a Lux
infinite dupe. You don't trust me. You
don't want to spend power Victor four
cards in hand. And something like a Vex
cheerless is also really strong against
those other spell-slinging combat heavy
decks like Aurelia, like the Diana
mirror match, like all of these calm
decks basically.
So, you are standing with your back
against the wall with basically no side
deck and
I'm pretty sure that a Victor deck has
something in its side deck for Diana
specifically.
>> Yeah, I mean, it's interesting. It's
sort of like the Azir match we just saw,
right? Where you don't want to have to
invest so much resources
into killing tokens.
Singularity, you don't want to be
targeting tokens with that. Definitely
not. So, it just seems like a very good
meta call right now are these token
decks.
>> I mean, you need to get out the
acceptable losses. So, you have to have
side something and then there are some
applications in which Singularity is not
the worst. I'm having my head in my
hands when I say this. Sometimes you
take out a Xin Zhao or a
Riptide Rex if your opponent plays that.
I've seen a plenty of those on the top
tables during the days.
Sometimes they save the inspector and
sometimes it's just two tokens that you
need to remove in an end game in a
stalemate in which Victor
not only thrives, which Victor tries to
achieve. It wants to
completely kill the game state
basically. Yeah. Victor is best when it
either wins fast or when it completely
drains you off of resources and then
those tokens they keep coming. This is
no ordinary card game. In this card
game, every unit, doesn't matter if it
has one might or 20 might, can get you
the same amount of points when it
conquers. So, these recruit tokens, they
win games, especially
when you take out all of the resources
your opponent has. Doesn't matter how
many cards you have to throw in. If you
have recruit tokens on your side, your
opponent has nothing else, you have
nothing else, you win the game.
>> Yeah, so you can force out all these
options, singularities, or star, you
know, four link star, any of those
businesses there. And you're the Victor
player saying, "Well, I'll just
move my legend over, I'll get one more,
do it again. If you don't, I get a
point. If you do, next turn, turn my
legend, do it again."
It just shows you the infinite tokens,
as you say, can just win this war of
attrition.
>> Shame, the more we talk about it, the
more I think siding in singularity
versus Victor is the correct choice.
>> It does seem to be.
And we are talking ourselves into it,
right?
>> It can buy you some time. Yeah. It can
be a quick way to discard that draws you
another card. Sometimes you don't want
to discard the other utility cards, but
it does seem more and more like a tough
match-up.
>> Victor, Herald of the Arcane.
Released in Origins.
Hasn't had the big breakthrough
performance there. I think the highest
one was a top four in Bologna from Ghost
a Driver.
Then in Spirit Forge, the deck
ducked, basically. It didn't really do
too much. I mean, wait, in Origins,
there wasn't Bologna. It wasn't in
Spirit Forge. Sorry about that.
Then
bunch of nothing from Victor.
And now we are back at it again in
Unleashed. Some pretty good performances
already, but this is a deep run. And now
we have Targon's Peak, which is so
incredibly beneficial for the Diana. The
win rate of this deck is incredibly
high. It is mad versus Rockfall Path,
which basically just shuts off a Kha'Zix
in this match-up. And to your own Chakra
dancer.
>> This is true.
But it could also stop the way I've
trying to load it up a battlefield
though. Load it up with mites.
But here we go. It's our mulligan phase
here. Rednaxela, if he wins this game,
he will find himself in the final here
the U check regional qualifier Devoli.
This is a win or go home situation. Make
no mistake about it. But we are getting
started in game
>> No.
>> game two. I don't see it.
>> Stack deck?
>> This can't be happening all the time.
>> These are three two drops. Look.
>> IS THAT THREE TWO DROPS ARE THE NEXT
THREE CARDS EVERYBODY?
What's going on in the top four?
>> Duaeli is so flabbergasted that for one
moment he forgets the stake that the
stakes that we're having here and he
shows his opponent all the cards
revealed from Stacked Deck saying Look
look at this.
It's three two drops.
>> Leo
that's happened every top four match for
one player. They've missed their drops.
>> Yep.
>> Honest broker coming down under a grace.
It's what I said Victor's not fine. This
is the war of attrition. You miss, I
win. You miss, I win. That's how the
Victor deck plays.
>> Now we're going to see perhaps an almost
repeat of the last game. But this hand
has a lot more card draw, a lot more
utility. Duaeli just developing the
Ravenbloom student. Not saying hey, I'm
going to lose my Diana again here versus
you. No, no, no, we're not going to do
that.
But
>> Aura of the week?
That's going to be an interesting one.
Keep an eye on that Aura of the week
everybody.
>> I'll bring this guy over here. Plus
>> So
Recruit token is going to conquer the
Targon's peak. Are we going to get to
see a gust on that Honest Broker or are
we perhaps keeping the gust for once for
our own Diana if our opponent is so
hungry to remove it again?
>> It's okay. You can just untap it later.
I don't care.
>> So I was asking about the sequence now
on the Targons Peak.
>> Dwali saying it's okay, you can just
untap whenever. I don't care.
At this point, players giving each other
the benefit of the doubt.
Saying, "Hey, this is all fair play
here."
Not trying to
call you out on something that I know
you're going to be fine
>> Yeah.
>> at.
>> Why is Why isn't that hand there?
Oh, thank you very much, production
staff. Well, thank you.
They're hot on it, aren't they?
Okay.
>> Got chopped into the Targons Peak.
>> No.
>> Uh last game.
>> Okay.
>> Uh Dwali opted not to. That's what was
going to be the case again, but there is
another
recruit as well.
And it is going to be the pass over, so
Targons Peak activation
is over to Dwali. I do say, "Ooh,
careful, careful." There we go.
Ooh, Moonfall off the top.
>> A Moonfall in a situation where one
battlefield is completely stacked
already.
That seems
like a draw from heaven. Is that Wait,
you could take away almost all of the
resources that Rednexel has built up so
carefully
when it comes to cards on board.
Ravenbloom student Diana is going to
immediately tell it, Ooh, we're going to
>> Ooh.
>> up here.
>> Okay, going to return that honest broker
to hand or current dredge, I should say,
sorry.
>> Gust.
>> Stupid play.
>> We're just not going to Moonfall here.
We're just going to overpower this
battlefield.
>> Hold that Hold that Moonfall for a later
turn.
>> Wait a second. If this gets answered by
a Wages of Pain, there is a huge
Moonfall. If you put this Ravenbloom
student to
three damage, so it has one
life
>> Yeah.
>> left. If you Moonfall in a recruit
token, Rednexel loses every card, and
the Ravenbloom student survives.
Hovering over those Oh, it's Hidden
Blade. It's Hidden Blade instead.
And to Wally
he's nodding in acknowledgement.
>> I don't think
Can he play the hard bargain?
>> Yes.
>> He has to, surely.
You can't let this go further, surely
not.
>> If your opponent really throws a Hidden
Blade at your two drop,
think it's a signal that you should hard
bargain this.
>> Okay, so hard bargain will come through.
The volley weathers the storm.
Rednaxel
on the recipient of a board wipe there,
apart from that lonely little recruit in
base.
>> Has three runes up still. How careful do
you want to play with your Diana? Do you
want to be Is there a moment where
you're too careful with this card? You
can ready two runes at the end of turn
again with the Targon's Peak.
>> I'm being careful if it's me.
I guess I do get the two back off
Targon's Peak. There you are correct.
>> What is the punish for playing Diana
here?
Like if
it's the same thing that happened in
last game where a Bellows Breath plus
Eclipse happens, that leaves Rednaxel at
two runes.
He's going to leave the Ravenbloom
student alone even
and he's just going to make one more
token.
>> Is there a world in which you can try
and charge into the Ravenbloom student
and call the week the Diana?
If I have my cards enough for
>> Yeah, but you need something to charge
with.
>> But the recruit there, aren't you?
>> That one has very few might so far.
>> This is true.
>> Very little might I should say.
Now to Wally is thinking about
developing this Fizz, wants to keep
Diana around, perhaps waiting out a
little bit more removal, place it even
into the battlefield
of the Raven Bloom student.
>> Sorry, he cast a Stark deck.
>> Okay.
Just to get through the deck.
You know, not the most efficient way to
use your fids just to view first deck
deck, but if needs must
>> He found two more two drops.
>> Just needed to shuffle that deck a
little bit nicer.
>> Just the bottom arms and the
>> They all going to go to the bottom now.
>> Top two arms in past.
>> So, it is going to be the pass over now.
Red Naxel
what can he do?
>> And all of a sudden in this game two
people are very very aware of how
important tempo is.
>> Double Call the Week.
>> Ah, that does look like a play
especially since you have a gold token.
You want to use that Conquer the
Rockfall Path Double Call the Week would
be very very efficient here when it
comes to the downside of Call the Week
which is
>> silent.
My notifications have just kind of gone
crazy.
>> He's asking if he can put his phone on
silent there. The notifications are
going wild.
It's everyone saying, "Good luck, Valli.
Good luck."
>> It's probably the boys in the group chat
discussing
roasting
>> of the match up here.
Okay.
I settle back in then.
Red Naxel
>> What's in hand?
>> Four.
>> Bring this guy over. Pass.
>> Oh.
>> Three.
>> With a Oh, no, wait. No, that was pass
of the priority, surely, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, okay. I forgot to pass the turn
for a sec.
>> Red Naxel has been eyeing this Double
Call the Week for quite a while now.
>> So have I.
>> Good show.
Okay, here we go. For one a gold.
>> That is Victor Leader.
>> Oh, that wouldn't be any
>> Nope.
>> Yeah.
I'd say that that wouldn't be a double
call of the week.
>> Things you can do
one call the week.
>> It has to be double or nothing surely.
>> I'll do this here.
>> Oh, wages of pain. Okay.
Going to wages fizz.
>> Yes.
>> I think if you get a wages of pain off
for a full value onto a fizz, it should
be worth it to do it. But the gust has
been kept in hand the entire time.
Gets this fizz back to him. That's a
tremendous amount of value.
>> Actually, considering how good fizz is
in this match up when you take a gust
from the trash, you can just basically
send away a recruit in situations where
your opponent doesn't have a lot built
up in base. That can save you from game
at some point.
>> So, free ruins open and the golds.
>> I'll do three to a unit of the
battlefield.
And then play a gold gear tug and
exhausted.
>> You got to get the gold still.
>> Did I
The golds from card sharp I think.
>> Yeah, he he still needs to get the
golds. Yeah.
Yeah, he didn't get one from wages.
>> Okay, thank you. Sorry. I got distracted
by the guy.
>> Oh, you're you're fine. You're fine.
Yeah, I didn't think it that either.
>> So, do you get that gold there from the
wages of pain?
Every decision matters. This looks like
call the week. Taking care of that
raging student.
>> I'll do and your recruits passing.
>> Sure. Very efficient with the energy
getting that recruit open in.
So, it looks like we are going back over
to Devali now. Oh, looks like a
singularity has been sided into.
Is currently in the hand.
One for a stat deck.
No units in play. Does find another fizz
flash.
And then can't quite make out that other
one.
Oh, is that a
Vex?
A flash Oh, is it Huwei? Sorry, it's a
Huwei.
We haven't really seen Huwei be a factor
so far in this top four.
>> Yeah, and especially now when you have
seen one called week and maybe this was
so well played by Red Nexus saying,
"Hey,
you know what?
I'll play just one called a week, clear
the entire board, and maybe my opponent
is going to develop the Huwei
uncarefully thinking that I might be
another stack deck for the Fizz, by the
way.
That is That is another value engine
that the deck has.
>> Star-crossed car sex.
>> Honestly
>> Traveling merchant.
>> Star-crossed Fizz when your opponent
doesn't really have anything developed.
>> Yeah.
>> Kind of nasty.
>> It is. Just basically saying, "If you're
going to play one unit a turn, I'm going
to remove one unit a turn."
Tough decision being made here, though.
Singularity is currently in hand as
well. Not going to use it this turn, of
course, but keep an eye on that one.
But that six-damage to two-unit nuke
some point in the game.
>> Hitting those recruit tokens left and
right.
>> You'd hope it hit a little bit more if
you're doing Singularity. That sounds a
little bit more destructive than two
recruit tokens, but it is going to be
our champion unit coming down, and it is
the pass over
>> I like that we're developing the Diana
in base. However, this is
one of the good old combos of Victor,
usually.
That would be Watcher Bellows.
Oh, Diana is being targeted with a
superfire.
Perhaps
are we going to see a repeated
>> Look at the beautiful options in that
hand, Leo.
>> Oh, that smells like a repeated Bellows
Breath.
>> It's a ridiculous amount of removal in
our hand.
>> Honestly, with all this gold that was
generated so far, you are at such a
healthy amount of runes.
Can play Bellows Breath and then you
still have enough for Victor Leader plus
a token.
Wow.
>> Efficiency.
>> Yeah.
Stupefy.
>> Did get played.
Debating on what to do next. Bellows
Breath repeated seems like a
>> I'll bring this guy over here.
>> Okay.
>> Yep.
>> Oh.
I'm just thinking.
>> Oh, that deck there off the diner.
That's taste better. A lot of stack
decks, isn't he?
>> That is true. That deck should be well
the stacked at this point.
Now, while the rune management is right
now or the rune economy rather on the
side of Red Nexel.
>> That should be four for me.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> And the points are going to speak at the
end.
>> Sure.
>> I don't think that he has
enough points at the moment.
>> We're going to hidden blade. Oh, we're
going to do a hidden blade cold cold a
week combination. Still got Bellows
Breath as well, by the way.
Oh, hidden blade is owned. You clue.
Okay.
>> Did you use a gold for that?
>> Uh yeah.
>> Oh, bro. Sure. Sure.
>> Hidden blade only hits you in at the
battlefield.
>> Oh, so it does. You are correct. Thank
you for that one, Leo. Okay. Still have
the Bellows.
>> Repeated Bellows.
>> There we go.
>> Yeah.
>> The Stupefy still shrunk the Diana. We
did not put a dice on it. There's the
Bellows.
>> cold of week.
>> Oh, you had it. Okay.
>> Stupefy out for the second Stupefy. And
there we go. The board wipe there from
Red Nexel back over to Devolve.
>> But that was such a huge investment. Are
we possibly going to see a who way being
developed? You know there is a Vex and
Traveling Merchant. Perhaps the who way
that we saw earlier was sniffed
up from the stack deck.
>> I think so.
>> under the deck. Think you can just
develop two units here. Sounds rather
nice.
>> What a battle of the board state this
has been. Both players jostling.
Both players finding their answers.
>> But Devoli has more cards in hand. He
does have after this turn, I would
presume
>> The removal again.
>> More might on the board.
>> he handle the try?
>> That's the try.
>> Oh, I was going to say. I was like, that
hand looks very similar to the last
turn. Okay, so we're going to see a Vex
upper deck come down and the traveling
merchants for Devoli back over to
Rednaxel.
>> Sometimes you're very happy with Victor
that you are removing like one unit.
>> Yep.
>> You put away three runes last turn?
>> Uh sorry, what?
>> Uh yeah, last turn was uh two for
bellows, one for Kalista.
>> Okay, sure.
>> The blade was on the on the gold.
>> So, you had you had 10 10 runes last
turn?
Or no, no, sorry, sorry. I'm tripping.
You're good. Uh you had eight last turn.
Yeah.
>> Every rune matters.
Now, the question is, you know you're
seeing that Vex in base, and it's so
threatening to half of the cards
Rednaxel has in hand. He has Vi
Peacekeeper.
And he has the Xin Zhao.
All of those could do some work. All of
those won't do any work anymore as soon
as Vex
hits the field, but we are already at
four points.
>> This could be five.
>> So, we take the risk, and the recruit is
also going to go into the Targon's peak
very, very likely if it doesn't get
gusted. Diana is still open. So, Star
Cross is also an option on that last
ready unit that Rednaxel has.
>> This is true.
>> Star Cross not necessarily what you want
to use on a token, but if you are
denying the sixth point, that could be
quite valuable, actually.
>> Let's try anyway.
Here we go. This is the turn. Are we
going to see it?
>> He's just getting it.
>> No. Okay, up to six.
Threatening lethal. I mean, all is on
that one recruit surviving this turn
rather low, but it will require some
investment. Singularity.
>> Singularity looks a little bit more
juicy than it did before.
>> I mean, that would clear off both of
those.
>> Yeah.
>> And then you can slam your Vex up there
as well, make life hard.
>> You can kill the Xin Zhao, you can kill
the Honest Broker.
>> Yeah.
>> Then there's only one recruit left in
base with your developed Vex.
Does not sound too bad. However, there's
also Moonfall. So, you could push the
Vex into the Xin Zhao battlefield.
Moonfall in the Honest Broker, and then
you're not, quote unquote, ruining your
rune economy.
>> This is currently a trade, right? Four
on four.
>> Yeah, but then
>> We're going to see a Moonfall, I would
imagine.
>> Yeah.
We also have another one at hand. If
anything happens, you can just play
another one. Trade immediately happens.
Vex reigns supreme, takes out two units.
Gold gear token.
Still being played because of the Honest
Broker. And now I think, I mean, the
Traveling Merchant is still waiting. I
think we might see a little conquer
there.
>> I would imagine so.
Still has quite a lot of good stuff in
that hand. Star Cross, Moonfall, Fizz.
>> I'm saying
with Vex developed
it is not completely crazy
to push into Targon's Peak and then Star
Cross that token. I'm saying it's not
completely out of line.
>> I think I can agree.
>> Discards the Moonfall.
>> And
>> Ashe bro.
>> Yeah.
>> Traveling Merchant getting it done
there.
Drawing to a way?
>> Oh, yeah. And that is a point where you
can
just freely develop it.
>> What is it? You do need a turn to
develop the way, it looks like this will
be a rather safe one to do it.
>> No way.
You still have three runes open after
this. And you can potentially play this
Dark Cross on the traveling merchant. Of
course, this is a potential game shot
for Red Naxel. Does he have a
combination of removals to take out Vex,
to take out the merchant, and to then
utilize the recruit and maybe another
card? I think this is asking for a
little too much. Oh, double Sprite
fountain.
>> Okay.
>> I was going to ask a question. Like,
let's say this is out of battlefield and
I gust you in response. Do you still
draw the two cards?
>> Yeah, yeah. You still draw it. It's
independent.
>> Sure, sure. Makes sense.
>> But we do have the Vex, though. We've
got to deal with that first.
>> Can we, though?
>> Can we? That is the question.
>> That looks like Victor Leader, and that
is going to pass the turn with another
recruit token developed. Nothing to be
gained here.
Just good for Red Naxel that he is so
far ahead in points that he can just
afford to wait a little bit.
>> Okay.
But now, a way has been a non-factor
in this top four.
Has been developed now. A multitude of
runes for Devalee.
Could this be a singularity turn?
>> Possibly.
Would not hate that.
>> I've been eyeing it up for a while, but
it would get rid of the the Victor
Leader now.
>> But that's only a four-might unit.
Doesn't really do too much.
>> You could also play another Vex into a
battlefield, but what's also possible is
that you're just trying to see what
you're drawing with the way. Maybe get
rid of one of those spells. Maybe even
ditch the singularity at this point,
honestly.
Because it is a little clunky, but we're
discarding the stupefy, keeping this
option open. If you singularity there,
you take the token, you take the Victor
Leader temporary, is going to do the
rest for you. You're going to completely
take everything away. And that is
usually You're so right, Shay. That show
called that you need to win games as
Diana with Vex in the battlefield. Yeah.
>> That would turn off all those bright
fountains and all that business. I quite
like hard on to singularity though.
That's like my emergency button. If
something goes wrong, I can just think
think two sixes.
Well, we are going to see the whole way
we're going to see the traveling
merchant get pushed back super far.
Looks like being eyed up here.
At least get to draw one. Can't imagine.
I guess he's got moon fire in hand
actually. So, we can start
>> Have we
>> Do you have a stuff in the way?
>> If we picked up very sick
>> is the singularity.
>> Yeah, those two.
>> As you rightly said, it's going to be
the recruit and the leader. The recruit
that hasn't got temporary of course cuz
that will be getting sent to the trash.
>> us
>> At the end of the turn There he goes.
>> Not even the trash. This token is
vanishing of course.
>> from existence.
Ooh, Imperial Decree.
>> If we still had that Battle's Breath
that would have been crazy.
>> Ooh, the Ash.
>> Ash focus
>> Okay.
>> Ash focus in this scenario is not the
nicest. That's basically just a look
into the hand.
>> Hey, you never know. Might catch
something good.
Oh, got to get to the going to hold it
so what you're saying. Yeah, he's going
to get it straight back.
We do get perfect hand knowledge though.
That is something you don't always get
in Rift Bounds.
Vex, hard bargain, Fizz, Star Crossed.
Oh, you sit There's There's too many
good cards there, isn't there?
>> See, I knew I was going to instantly get
one back so I didn't anyway.
>> Yeah, yeah, makes sense. Sure.
Just going to put this under Ash for
now.
Play this.
>> Develops a vine base.
>> That.
>> There goes Star Crossed.
>> It's back.
>> That is looking like one big push, but
that's Star Crossed.
It's already so threatening.
>> Okay, so now we're starting to see a bit
of a transition in play style here from
Red Naxela. We're no longer relying on
those recruits.
>> I think what you can easily do here that
the easiest line that I'm finding here
>> Yeah, he's talking.
>> is Star Crossed the Vai
and then you play the Fizz and Star
Crossed the Ash as well.
So, you get rid of both of those units
again, you're already at seven. Your
opponent has to double conquer. You play
something into the battlefields. You
push the Traveling Merchant up. You can
put two units into those battlefields
and bounce the two of Radnaxel and none
of these units are going to do anything.
Star Crossed plus Fizz as annoying as
you could imagine.
>> Yeah, that would be backbreaking, I
think.
Is that what we're going to see?
>> Go Fizz.
>> Here goes the Fizz.
>> Oh, boom fall.
>> That also works.
>> Yeah, even better.
>> Ash sent straight to the trash.
And he's aiming again to remove those
threats. Star Crossed currently in hand
as well, don't forget.
>> I mean, at this point
for the Wally, it's
really hard to lose.
>> Yeah, look at the points caught up in
those points. Currently seven.
We'll just need to hold.
>> Trigger.
>> Yeah.
Even retreats the way.
>> Yeah, but why the window something?
Doesn't look like it.
>> I don't think he cares at this point.
You can even with the Titan. I push up
the Traveling Merchant into Targon's
Peak and then play the Titan into
Targon's Peak at the way back in there.
Now we have right the wind.
>> There you go.
>> Star Crossed.
>> There's the Star Crossed just going to
remove all options for Radnaxel.
>> Yeah, Radnaxel is suffering from this
Vex stopping him completely from running
into those battlefields. He is stunned
as a player for multiple turns now. He's
now going to get the last draw.
>> draw
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> I don't even know which card could
Rednaxel get back into this game. And a
hidden card just for good measure.
>> third
>> Rednaxel needs to push off both of these
holds
to win. That would win him the game as
well.
Can we see it? I don't think we are.
It's going to be going on to a game
three here, folks, in our top four
feature match, Devoli versus Rednaxel.
Devoli putting on the masterclass. We
are now going to an essential best of
one to see who will be joining Squirtle
in our U Trek Regional Qualifier final.
>> Insane performance from those players
over
last couple of tournaments. It is
incredible to see the consistency of
some of these Rift Brawlers. Hello to
the crowd.
Hope you're enjoying this show as much
as we do. Devoli already a champion.
Squirtle already a champion. Rednaxel
perhaps a first-time champion
if he can win this game three. Finally
going to be on the play.
Finally going to start off a game.
But honestly,
instead of starting off a game, I would
rather go second with a Victor when my
opponent misses the first drop on
consistently.
>> Yeah. Well, that's that's going to be
the tie or tape here for game three if
Devoli would even get a two drop down.
Didn't need it in that game.
>> Yeah, I mean, when you're going second,
you can always develop Diana.
>> Yeah.
>> But in this matchup, we have seen how
important the Diana can be. So, that
might be more of a fallback plan.
I'm saying if Devoli finds a two drop,
he's not going to develop Diana on
curve.
>> I just game three. This
This is
so close. Essentially a best of one for
a chance to be there in the final.
Woo.
Do you think Do you think side deck What
do you think of getting side deck here,
Leo?
>> I think
Dwali might
stick to the same cards, honestly. He
just needs to get the unacceptable
losses out. Those cards really don't do
anything for him.
And
Rednexel is so quick with it.
Don't think he has changed much, either.
Might have brought in a safety
inspector.
Card that can't be hard bargained, but
still gets rid of a way if you want to.
Another big question.
We haven't seen one of those in Watcher
in his deck list so far.
Watcher plus Battle's Breath. Phenomenal
combo, especially against those
three might units or four might units.
But, what is going to be really
important
is the fact that we're playing in the
Arena's Greatest in that last match-up,
and that makes it faster. That's exactly
what Victor likes. But, Diana,
if she's forced to play aggressively,
she can.
>> Can also do so, but I think I'd give an
in an Arena's Greatest game, cuz
you know, Rednexel was off to the races
that game. Did go on the board early.
So, if you have one more point one more
less point to play to,
this is Honestly, folks,
this is going to be a really good one. I
can't work out how it's going to be. I'm
glad that I've got Leo here, and we're
going to be your tour guide here as we
see who's going to be joining Squall in
the final here. Our Utrecht Regional
Qualifier.
Diana versus Victor.
>> Dwali versus Rednexel.
Who's it going to be?
On the play for Victor,
one of the most aggressive decks
from Spirit Forged
is
slightly less aggressive perhaps
in unleashed but more dominant. Going to
see we haven't really seen any Sprite
fountains used yet because they were
only drawn when we were in a Vex game.
So finding those Sprite fountains could
be crucial especially in Arena's
Greatest. That is one of the strongest
starts in the game. Let's see if Red
Nexo decides to play
with a Sprite or wants to develop a
token or a carrion dragger. This is the
first turn only two runes and you have
three different choices. This is the
complexity that we love in Riftbound.
>> In an Arena's Greatest game as well.
>> You don't have to worry about a two drop
now.
>> True.
>> Okay.
Dwallie laughing away the pain.
>> I'm just going to keep.
>> You're going to keep.
Okay, here we go. Game three in our top
four feature match here at the U chat
regional qualifier. Carrion dragger
coming down for Red Nexo.
>> Did catch the Arena's Greatest there. Is
over to Dwallie now.
>> I like it that he is not immediately
de-ramping and now Dwallie is thinking
what am I going to do? Develop a Raven
bloom student. Doesn't play out the
Diana immediately because he's afraid of
that color week or other shenanigans
that Red Nexo has as we know. Are we
going to see a double hunger into color
week now?
>> There's a lot of background noise.
>> Yes, it's getting really loud.
Sorry.
>> That is us. We apologize.
>> Same.
>> It probably doesn't help that we're
quiet now if they're trying to test
that.
>> I mean the thing is we have a little bit
of delay on this because we want to show
you all of those games. So I think by
this point when they said that the audio
will have been fixed already or really
quickly.
So, I think we can just keep talking.
>> I did forget about that. Thank you so
much for that, Leo. Okay.
>> Not sure why it just randomly increased.
>> Oh, that was Yeah, okay. I I remember
exactly when this was. Yes, yes, yes,
yes.
>> Yeah, yeah, there was a short moment
where we were really, really loud and
that is going to be fixed just ASAP.
Don't worry about that.
But it's very funny that we are seeing
this like 10 minutes ago.
Even we were startled a little bit.
>> We We were startled. I'm used to being
loud, but I understand. But honestly, I
was super loud here in the venue.
But let's have a little think here then.
So, we've got the Carrion Dredger.
Four runes to play for Red Nexus.
>> So, I think the next play is going to be
perhaps
I mean, you want to take away the Diana
with Calla the Weak, but what you want
even more is to have this tempo. So,
Calla the Weak
onto a Ravenbloom Student in your first
turn feels very much fine, especially
when you have the Sprite Fountain. And
then you can just sack off your Sprite
that conquered in the arena's greatest.
Unless the Wally has an answer for that.
Maybe he has a Gus Sprite Fountain. That
is the most aggressive start that you
can have in game of Hearthstone.
Immediately puts it down on the arena's
greatest.
And now
Wally actually just makes a token.
Does he or does he not? Yes.
And passes. So, he does not even use the
Calla the Weak. Perhaps wants to force
the Wally to trade in with the
Ravenbloom Student. Get that one out of
the way and then tackle whatever comes
next. Maybe he wants to keep this Calla
the Weak first of all concealed and
second of all as an answer to a Vex
Huwei or Diana.
>> I think you're right. Could use Calla
the Weak here, but much rather be
up-trading into something with a bit
more value, like one of those Vex, for
example, or the Diana Champion unit as
well.
Not No stat deck there though. No way to
get through the deck.
>> Ravenbloom student trading into the
Carian Dredger and
>> Yeah, there was a stupefy in hand. This
is why we don't play Call the Week cuz
you know you can get around this
Ravenbloom student in other ways.
>> And DeWolfe he needs to have an answer
for this or else the Ravenbloom student
would be dead.
>> There was a hard bargain in the hand,
but
>> Do you want a hard
>> hard bargain a stupefy?
>> That is very much unideal. We are in a
showdown, so the Diana can exhaust
itself to get one more energy, so you
would still technically be able to drop
a Vex afterwards, but that is also
something you don't necessarily want to
do.
Unless No, wait, that's in Rockfall
Path.
That is so big, so you can't even play
the Vex into the Rockfall Path.
Vex is not going to stop
>> It's the hard bargain now.
>> the next sprite. That is so important.
>> We'll get the bird token now though.
>> Yeah, go to uh
>> It's good for you.
>> Yeah.
>> Is DeWolfe perhaps losing a lot of tempo
to his own battlefield?
There is also a chance that he just says
pass here because he wants to keep
>> There's not a lot else in that hand. I
mean, you could put Champion unit down.
>> Yeah.
He has a smoke screen in hand and that
couldn't be played if he played Diana or
Vex.
>> True.
>> If he doesn't act now though, Red Nexus
might be running away with those sprites
forcing out more interactions.
>> So interesting. As you say that
DeWolfe's own Rockfall Path
making life so much harder. Haven't seen
the sprites be a factor here in this
round, but
here they are. Going to have another
one.
When this one goes away,
sprite phantom will produce another. Vex
so good at dealing with them.
Not when you're in a Rockfall Path.
This is going to come down the
old-fashioned way back to base.
>> And I believe that Red Nexel is loving
this situation. If Sprite doesn't go
back to base, it dies to temporary, and
then the Sprite Fountain dies to
temporary, and then the Deathknell gets
you another Sprite. That is such a
loaded hand.
>> My goodness, the Zing Zao.
>> Completely exhausted Dwali Sprite can't
just run into that Rockfall Path, and
then later on
>> Still have the Call the Weak as well,
right?
So, we can Oh, no. Oh, no. Dwali's
tapped out as well, even with the Diana
legend as well. So, we can easily do a
board wipe and get a double conquer here
very easily.
>> That looks like the perfect setup for an
early blowout with an aggro deck. This
is the unstoppable force that Victor
wants to be in Unleashed. This is
everything that aggro players ever
wanted. Sprite Fountain giving you so
much might, so much speed, so many
points in no time. Now, Red Nexel, of
course, this is Untimed Top Cut, the
semi-finals of the regional qualifier in
Utrecht. There's no need to rush things
at all.
>> Take a deep breath in.
Really think about it. That play does
seem rather strong to me.
>> But you always have to factor in all of
the options. We know that the Diana is
exhausted, all of the runes are
exhausted.
>> Yeah.
>> There can't be anything, but
I mean, if you've ever played versus
Set'arr and other order deck with Call
to Glory
sometimes something happens. Now, goes
to conquer in the Rockfall Path, takes
out the Ravenbloom student Dwali, does
not even act like he's thinking about
something.
>> We're going to see the conquer first.
Yeah. And now it's going to go through.
Are we going to see that Call of Weak
now?
Surely.
>> There's no way this does not happen,
especially because it lines up so well
with the honest broker.
Does it not happen?
>> Brutes.
There there it is. Call of the week. Vex
Epiphany is sent to the trash.
>> Uh yeah.
>> Next turn. Okay, we have a Fizz. We have
another Vex Epiphany, but slowly but
surely Victor is running away. We are at
seven rules, so that could be a Diana
Vex development turn, but you would have
to accept that your opponent is going up
up to seven points in the next turn. The
question is, how well can you stop him
from doing that? You have to ride the
wind. You could potentially
play Vex ride the wind into the Arena's
Greatest to take out the recruit.
>> Yeah.
>> Then hope that your opponent is not
accelerating anything next turn cuz then
Jao's multiple copies of those are
waiting in hand, so it would be a
formidable play. However, Red Nexus has
so much
>> time in this game. You can see him
smiling looking at his friends.
>> Even if the Vex finds a way into the
battlefield, Wally is at two points, at
three if he accelerates it into the
Arena's Greatest. So, you can just
play him sideways.
>> Yeah.
>> And just say, "Here we go."
>> Yeah, you just wait a turn.
>> And that's the thing about Vex. It needs
to be when either you're ahead or at
least even. If your opponent is ahead,
you can say, "Okay, I can't accelerate.
That's fine now, but I'll just wait a
turn them."
>> Yeah.
>> That works well the well.
>> It's a tough spot to be in.
>> He's so happy, and I can't blame him.
>> Can't blame him. He's in a good spot
here. However, you can't really relax
too much
against previous regional qualifier
champions, of course. Vex Epiphany is
going to hit the base.
He did say ride the wind is in hand, so
he can start to get, you know,
can start to maneuver around these
battlefields.
I am a champion.
>> Oh, it looks like he is going to try and
build up everything he can. Playing this
Diana would mean that you're giving up
two more points against Rednexel who's
already at five. That would put him to
game point. Any sort of backrow removal,
any sort of singularity S cards would
blow you out of this match completely.
Do Wally. Last grasp is Diana Lunari and
Vex Appethetic. Six points for Rednexel.
Another conquer coming soon with the
Honest Broker. What is following this
up?
>> Any form of backrow removal here would
be terrifying.
Do we have it? I think it was a hidden
play but I think he can't use that when
he works about fields of course.
Come on. What's in the hands?
>> I think double Xinzhao
would not be unreasonable.
>> I think that's very strong.
>> One Xinzhao and a recruit token.
Maybe also a Victor Leader and a recruit
token so you crash the Victor Leader
into the Vex next turn.
>> That's four recycle ones on that leader.
That's leader.
>> And you make a token Victor Leader and
you hope that you can crash the Victor
Leader into the Vex of your opponent
next turn so you can play those Xinzhaos
ready. Do Wally, take a deep breath.
This is
the last chance. This turn has to be
perfect. He has very few cards in hand
but picked up a stack like this. Card
can help you. Also, you have a lot of
runes. Almost double as many runes as
Rednexel has so
if you conquer that Rockfall Path with
the Diana
you might be able to afford
using your Diana Labartla
Lunari ability.
Goodness me.
>> Yep, looks like that is going to go
through.
>> Just need to find something. Looks at
the top card of the deck. Thinks about
it if he wants to keep it on top.
That would be
a signal that it is actually a spell
because I think in this scenario
if you are putting this
on top of the deck and this is a unit
it would be wild. It's a star crossed
put to hand. That Okay. That's help you.
Especially
with the Fizz in hand. The Wally is not
going down without a fight. Conquer's up
to three. If Vex pushes towards the
arena's greatest
that is going to be four and all of a
sudden
with Jin's favorite number
if you're double holding you're
threatening lethal.
Soon.
Not too soon, but
we're getting there slowly but surely.
>> Star crossed that was a fantastic pick
up. Going to be star deck now as well.
Going to try and maneuver through that
deck.
Something you love to see
when you're on the back foot trying to
find those answers. Oh, double Zing
Zhao.
Zing Zhao and then a carrion dredger.
>> The Wally found a singularity with this
deck deck. And that is
very very hard decision because if you
are slowly but surely stabilizing and
taking over
the board state
the card is going to help you, but can
you afford to pick it up right now
instead of something that is going to
immediately help you?
>> Vex will hit the arena's greatest.
That ability will be live for what it's
worth.
Ooh, on the pass. Okay.
All those runes open now, Leo.
You know star crossed is in hand.
Okay. Red Naxus.
What can you do? What were you in? What
did you say?
>> A bellows breath picked up from the top.
I don't think that this card
really helps you in this situation.
Because you have no other spell.
>> Okay.
>> Can release stuff here. Can you afford
to push four recruit tokens?
Play battlefield. Now that one is
stunned.
>> Yep, so is that one.
>> That one too. I think we just build up
more. Let your opponent hold to six and
pass.
>> We are waiting. I think we are.
I don't mind this, you know. If all
you're saying all I have to do is just
push you off one battlefield.
Let's just have as much might as
possible.
>> And now see how efficient that was. He
used the time he gained by conquering so
many points
for building up. That was a turn where
the Wally came back with double conquer
and he left eight runes up in a
situation where you with your back
against the wall
using not using eight of your runes,
passing it over and your opponent goes,
"Okay, you know what? I'm not going to
play into your reactive cards in your
hand. I am going to go wide in the base.
Four might, four might, one might set up
for the next turn where it's going to
get important that I am conquering." And
now to Wally.
He is not any further than the last
time. And look at Red NeXuS. He's
smiling.
>> I was about to say look looking in the
crowd. He knows he's definitely in the
driver's seat here.
DeValli staring down. All the runes in
the world are open. But as you say with
those absolute mighty army in the base.
What can he do?
I'm not sure there's much we can do. We
know singularity isn't there.
>> No, I don't think he took it.
>> Oh, he didn't take it. I apologize.
>> I think he took a moonfall instead.
Moonfall of course really strong card.
But it would cost you
three energy
of the 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 that you
have open. So you take away one Xing
Zhao for example or rather a Victor
leader because otherwise
there is going to be another token
spawning.
>> Yeah.
>> You take that one out.
You're at eight runes.
Can possibly play another moon for you
at five runes.
>> I'll just pass again.
>> He's passing. On the pass. Okay.
>> And probably just
>> So, is Red Naxel going to take a turn
off again? Or is it going to be charged?
>> WOW. OH, THE HIDDEN BLADE. THAT IS
MASSIVE. I think that's it, right?
>> Naxel decided.
>> If it goes through
>> I definitely have cards in hand. I have
six cards and 12 mana, but I'll find a
way for this. I'm done. Don't worry.
>> Hidden blade can just maneuver maneuver
a unit off a battlefield. You can charge
in, of course.
>> Okay. Let's see how
>> assuming you have to have the decree or
a watcher. Decree I can be. Watcher
depends.
>> They're discussing the emotions, but Red
Naxel, he wants to think.
>> I don't mind it.
>> Absolutely not. Hidden blade. This is
the turn he has to win it because
otherwise double hold aren't clear those
battlefields he has to fight.
>> Okay. Zing Zhao up the top.
>> We start talking.
>> 4 1 0 3. Try and get those answers out
of DeWaal's hand.
>> Thing is, if DeWaal decides to now just
go for one of his combat tricks, a
hidden blade would be crucial.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
Hidden blade is the X factor here,
right?
If that can resolve
the units the recruits are charging in.
>> Red Naxel does not need to double
conquer. He just needs to be big big big
in one of these battlefields. So, if
DeWaal cannot stop the hidden blade
>> Yes.
>> That is going to be tough. Reveals one
more card. Red Naxel also does not or
gets a gust that doesn't help versus
Zing Zhao unless you can reduce its
might.
>> I pass.
Focus.
>> Surely there's a steep fine in that
hand.
It's like a six seven card hand, all
right? I think there's a smoke screen as
well.
>> I like how Redneksel is just poking
here. Now, let's see. Does the smoke
screen already pull out that hidden
blade?
>> room of one, yeah. Yeah.
>> Is he going to reveal
that card that he just top decked
immediately?
>> Do I care?
>> War question.
>> care.
>> Okay.
>> Get ready.
>> There we go.
>> Next.
>> Combat one down, yeah? Here we go. Just
forcing out those answers one at a time.
Do I care? No. Let's try again.
Could they be the famous words that
secured Redneck? There's a moonfall.
>> Duwali pulling in a recruit, not taking
too many risks.
>> Oh, that's minus two.
Minus two.
>> Now, that would be a favorable trade for
Diana Lunari.
The last straw for Duwali sitting on
this Rockbiter path, ooh, recycling one
rune.
>> Hidden blade is two, right?
>> Yeah, but I think we are Bellows
breathing.
>> Okay.
>> Just to get
>> Two. Twice. Yeah, one twice.
>> Okay, so that means Xing Zhao is
threatening
the kill now on the Diana.
>> Redneksel also understanding that it
doesn't need runes anymore.
>> No.
>> Therefore, playing around a possible
Stupefy.
Dealing two damage with Bellows breath.
>> One twice.
Yeah.
Two little runes under.
>> He is being
very, very patient, presenting the least
threatening cards
to his opponent to bait out more
interaction. He's already gone through
quite some runes. He knows there is a
>> You have two cards left?
>> Star Crossed in hand for the Wally. We
have seen that before, but what do you
want to Star Crossed here? You can't
afford to lose any of those
battlefields.
>> There's so many units. It just It just
need one to charge in.
>> Does the Wally
try to go for a gust play? He still has
the Vex Apathetic that stops you from
just entering ready and rushing into one
of those battlefields. Gust on Tuxen's
owl could help him out quite a lot, but
then what? Are we going to see a hidden
blade after that? And then
are we going to see it onto the Diana or
onto the Vex to then replay this Xin
Zhao?
>> Move four, number two.
>> And I would assume that this one pulls
in Victor Leader.
>> Bring in Victor.
>> Uh so this resolves, yeah?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Bellow's Breath resolves.
>> Are we going to see the hidden blade?
Now this would be the time. The Diana is
at such
a formidable spot.
A gust onto the Victor Leader.
>> Slowly now with the amount of ruins
left, the hidden blade seems terrifying.
>> Big long combat chain.
>> Can I check?
>> Just going to check the trash.
>> The last moments of this second
semi-final at the regional qualifier in
Utrecht.
Wally sitting at two ruins left over
facing Xin Zhao and a recruit.
Does Red Nexo care is the question he's
asking himself again. He has the hidden
blade that he
pulled from the top to Wally with a
phenomenal defensive turn. But, if this
combat concludes and it gets to a
cleanup,
there would be
damage healed from Diana. So, the
Battle's Breath would have basically
been
>> I don't want to mess this up.
Maybe a few seconds.
>> Yeah, all good. All good. Do you have
it?
>> Have what? I don't know.
The question is whether you have it.
>> Okay. Sure.
>> What would he be playing around here?
Hard bargain, perhaps?
>> Hard bargain?
>> Hard bargain.
>> At this point, wouldn't matter anymore.
>> It just depends on what's in your hand.
>> He knows that Star Cross is not an
option anymore. We know that card.
What could he be playing around?
>> There's a hidden blade.
If that goes through, Rednecksel will be
in the final.
>> Wait a second. Wait a second. He will
not get that point. He's going to only
draw a point. He's at seven points. He
hasn't scored in that other battlefield.
There is also a Write the Winds. Wally
could push that Vex in there. Hold your
horses, Shay.
Wally might be in a decent position
here.
>> Of course.
>> Because if you Write the Winds
after this result
into the Rockfall Path
>> It's fine.
>> and you win that combat,
Rednecksel doesn't have
>> Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, sorry,
sorry, sorry, sorry.
Yes.
>> any crazy sorts of interactions anymore.
Vex is just going to reign supreme, hold
to seven, and then the Fizz in hand
could copy the Write the Winds from the
trash, pulling it over immediately to
this
arena's greatest. Did Wally hold off a
defensive Diana masterpiece?
>> Uh, this guy is dying.
Nice score.
>> He even drew two more cards from the
hidden blade.
>> Yeah, he did. Okay, here we go. Titus
seven a piece.
>> Now to Wally, he's completely tapped
out, but Rednexel still has so many more
units he can conquer here
with
the token and then charge all of the
other tokens into the Vex. So, this at
least would trade. He would sit at one
token and then there is the big
question. Can
Wally win from that? He has right the
win IN TRASH.
>> WALLY WINS WITH THE VEX IN THE TRASH AND
REDNEXEL WINS OUR TOP FOUR MATCH and he
finds himself in the final.
>> What an insane rip off the top from this
conquer draw on seven. Sometimes you're
saying, "Hey, it doesn't matter if you
get that seventh point. You have to
conquer both." But, if you get that draw
and it finds you the accelerators, the
ready Sprite, it is going to get you to
the finals of a regional qualifier. This
is just how card games go sometimes.
Wally with an absolute defensive
masterpiece in that last turn setting
him up for success. There would have
been only a recruit token. This would
have been played. Copy right the win.
Push in there. Get the seventh point and
then wait for a potential hold. This was
a great setup for to Wally, but the
Sprite fountain of fortune came along,
got the W.
>> That was absolutely incredible. We were
there watching.
>> You couldn't see us, but we were there
watching like this and this Sprite
fountain comes down at the perfect time.
The second that Vex Apathetic was out of
the battlefield, the Sprite fountain
will come in to close it up for
Rednexel. I think that's enough here for
enough though. It's been It's been us
for a long time now. Let's kick it down
for winners interview with Rednexel.
>> An absolute incredible match. I'm joined
here with RedNaxel, your second locked
in finalist here in Utrecht. RedNaxel, I
just want to build you up a little bit.
We haven't been able to follow your
storyline 100% of the way here, but
this is your first regional qualifier
and you are now in the finals with
Victor.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> How does that feel?
>> Well, I
I didn't come here, you know, to to
reach the finals, but it's a pleasant
surprise and
you know, I I think, you know, I'm I'm
happy even if I lose, but I will try for
the best.
Really happy to be here.
>> Moments from now, you are going to sit
right behind us at this table fighting
for a trophy against Squirtle who is
currently going for his second regional
qualifier win and here you are at your
first one showing up just like he did
having to play over and over again. How
confident are you feeling in that match
up?
>> No,
not at all.
But, you know, I'm going to try my best.
The thing is
I've played a lot of Victor,
but I haven't trained, you know, most of
these guys have their own teams and
they're testing all the match ups, all
the possible combinations. I know Victor
well. I don't know very well anything
else, but, you know,
I still hope.
>> And hope is a dream, a dream to be the
Victor with your fans of course cheering
you on in that finals and I can't wait
to be there. RedNaxel, congratulations
once again. Incredible performance. Are
you taking out one regional qualifier
champion in DeWaal
and another one stands in your way.
Don't go anywhere. We're going to send
it back so we can get ready for the
finals.
>> Thank you, Barrett. Hearing from
RedNaxel there closing in on that finals
final spot.
I mean,
first off to Rednexel, like how how
could you ever predict that you know
what I'm actually just going to be in
the finals?
>> What more needs to be said? Honestly,
when you walk in on your first final,
play with confidence, play to your
strength, and to be rewarded for it.
That is the stuff That is the stuff from
fairy tales.
>> Yeah, rewarded from the top of your deck
with a set of sprites. So, you're like,
"Cool, I've got it. Never didn't have
it. All good." As really, really, you
know, putting Towelie all the way
through that series on the back foot,
and Towelie not able to end up turning
that game around. And what a tense end
to our semi-final.
Rednexel
now finds themselves going up against an
RQ champion. Not only an RQ champion,
the last European RQ champion, which is
insane to think that somebody is, in a
sense, defending their crown in this
bracket. Of course, we've had other RQs
in between, but Squirtle hasn't been at
them.
This is Squirtle was like, "I just play
on European soil at this point." And
comes back in the bracket through the
final, takes out a who's who of North
America
on the way here with Prismacism and
Colin from Challenger TCG falling along
the wayside for Squirtle to make their
way to the final.
>> And facing their biggest obstacle yet,
reigning European champion, captain for
Mechaelion, this I mean, you got to have
to bring your absolute A game. However,
despite the humbleness from Rednexel
himself,
I think there is a real path to victory
here. We'll get into it later, but this
might not be as doomed as he made it
sound a little earlier ago.
>> Yeah, that that's fair. And it's
definitely a match up that that at the
competitive level we we were seeing a
little bit in Spirit Forge, the the
Iselia Victor match up. But I don't
think he's the one anyone would have
predicted would have been this final. We
joked earlier about Order being strong.
Order being the new Chaos, which I guess
is uh
apt going into Vendetta. Um get maybe
get to see some of those color pairings
of Oh, no, what happens when you put
purple and yellow together? No, we can't
do it. Cut it all.
Change the finals. We're not allowed to
have that coming up if if Order's good,
we're not allowed to to start putting
two broken
uh color pairings together. Uh if you
haven't noticed, we we of course in
between rounds uh have to take a moment
or two just to make sure the players are
ready. Uh so, yes, we've looked through
the bracket. Um what has been your
favorite thing so far of the weekend,
Bandit?
>> Honestly, I'm just so glad to see Colin
back uh up in the top mix. It was
devastating to see him him lose in the
run-up, and you immediately start to
imagine the worst-case scenarios. Seeing
him pull through to the end,
it's it's hurts even more to see him
lose in the semifinals, but Squirtle was
such a deserving victor.
>> Yeah, I mean, the
you know, Squirtle just seems to crush
through these brackets. He's been very
impressive crushing past
uh Colin in the way to the finals. We're
ready to get to our finals. Let's have
our players take to the stage.
Defending
his crown, looking for back-to-back
European Regional Qualifier wins, on
Azir RQ League Champion, Squirtle.
And his opponent, looking to catch
lightning in a bottle, cheered on by his
family, it is none other than
Naxil.
So, we're ready or at least moments away
from our finals.
Moments through the motions.
>> Yeah. And now it is time to talk shop,
James. Okay.
>> It's my favorite part of in the being in
the run-up as
we are shortly away from getting these
deck lists to you.
We have to talk because if you look at
any opponent that Squirrel could be
facing in the finals, I'm going to say
that Victor might be one of the tougher
match-ups to be punching through.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz Victor has both answers for single
units that are very, very large,
>> Okay.
>> as well as being able to address
multiple smaller threats at the same
time. Bellows Breath, Thousandtail
Watcher.
>> Uh-huh.
>> But most importantly, they can mount the
pressure early. The way they showed to
the Wally with Caldoweeks, they can
suppress those in power.
>> Well, this is the the game plan from the
Azir's side when we look at Squirtle's
deck where of course we've very familiar
with this. Plays out the equipment,
utilizes the Azir legend ability. For
those of you that have not played
against Azir a lot, it's really
difficult to keep them pinned back on
the amount of units because just the
amount of equipment that they throw
activates that legend ability,
constantly creating the army that is
just a wide board that utilizes
equipment passed from sand soldier to
sand soldier to sand soldier as each of
them fall in their duty of conquering to
a winning point. However, as you said,
the other side of this match-up, the
Victor,
you know, is another token deck in its
own way. Like
the Origins Victor with the recruits
that come through it, you're constantly
spamming out, albeit smaller units, and
albeit with less utility coming from
anything like equipment. This list
actually not looking that direction at
all, but what it does have is a lot of
direct damage spells, a lot of ways to
influence the board.
>> Not only that, but if you go through it,
it is really hard to push this Victor
back on its butt. Because every time a
unit dies and the Victor leader is out,
you're getting it already to recruit
when you get the turn it back. Units
that when they die, they will be
spawning birds that will be ready on
your next turn. It's quite doable to
keep the pressure mounting. The only
thing that can keep them back is when
they run out of cards to play.
>> that is fair. Grouping together, when I
say damage, I'm also looking at like the
kill spells that come through it. And
you you add things like Imperial Decree,
you can really turn the tide of a battle
by you know, trading your small recruits
in to larger units. So, Red Nexul, we
can see the game plan there. You talked
a little bit behind the scenes with me
earlier about the sideboarding plan of
these. We don't have sideboards up here
on screen yet. We'll obviously get to
that later on. But, the players do know
each other's sideboards, so we are free
to talk about it. Tell me, what do you
read about potential ways that a Victor
can play into Azir?
>> So, there is already a Salvage main
deck, which is
>> Okay.
>> very fortunate.
>> Mhm.
>> However, we are we can share with you
that
in the sideboard, there are
there are
Just waiting. Honestly, I'm going to
wait for the players to put up their
headphones.
>> Well,
>> Just in case. Just
>> That is fair. The the deck list we can
see the players do have
on the stage. They are looking at them.
It is apt to say, "Hey, we should
probably wait." And not to talk about
>> When they have full information, there's
nothing at stake. There is the
Pickpocket that is in the sideboard.
Now, we saw this all the way back when
Sigils were
>> Uh-huh.
>> daily topic of conversation.
Pickpockets just get rid of gears with a
maximum cost of one.
>> Yeah.
>> And I if I recall quickly, Azear plays
nine of those.
>> That's fast math if that is exactly how
it is, but we saw it it come up. We were
looking at things like the Eye of the
Herald being a good target for that. You
got the Doren's Shield there, the Soul
Sword, like lots of different you know,
openings that that Azear normally goes
through that you can kind of
scalpel come in and and and really
dissect.
>> And the only thing that were should
worry you a little bit is that you're
playing against the best Azear in the
world. And the stats do not lie.
>> Yeah.
>> Legend Favor being just all across every
game uh by played by anyone win
prediction where the player's pedigree
comes into account.
>> Okay, so let's put this let's put this
in context.
In Squirtle's three uh Q appearances, it
is a combined
two
and four
overall in series wins and is on a
I think it's 28
series like undefeated streak and then
some draws in the middle there. Like no
losses in like about 31
series.
>> That is at an RQ level.
>> That
That is consistency.
>> That is ridiculous. That is
That is insane to to to even kind of
contextualize as a run.
>> legacy to be leaving that behind so
close to joining that also exclusive
list of two-time champions.
>> The list of Alan.
>> The list of Alan truly, but to put that
on the other side
I'm not sure how big the list is of
winning the first R Q you attend. I
guess that's just the Wally.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
by default, right?
That's that's very fair. Which I mean,
now that we have had a few, you're like,
okay, there's I mean, sure, people are
still going to do it, but that, you
know, that that road through of like,
hey, I show up, I rock up, I'm actually
going to do well. I mean, you're
in some regards untested at that point.
It like maybe even if you have a good
competitive scene locally,
but as soon as you jam players in a room
like the caliber we've had here this
weekend,
making top eight is an unbelievable
achievement already, and then to bypass
some of the biggest names in the scene
on your way here is crazy.
>> And then not to even mention you are
facing
like a team captain.
>> Yeah.
>> This this man is is supported and has,
you know, all of the highest echelon
information ready to go.
>> Yes, and I even saw Squirtle and
Mycelion around him just before this
game as they were kind of watching out
the final moments of previous round, and
they they're strategizing, already
talking about the match-up like how does
it go? And that's one of the things that
being on a team does give you a benefit
of, and and this really does kind of
feel like almost a David versus Goliath
moment in in this where Red Naxel, yes,
has family and friends. I was speaking
to Red Naxel's brother George and
talking about how this
trip for a first R Q from Athens, from
Greece,
been playing Victor since Origins. He's
just like, yeah, I actually just I think
it's really good. And then I look over
at Mycelion, and they're like, hardcore
breaking down the match-up. I'm like,
this is the dichotomy of competitive
card games.
>> And to have that
be a factor in the finals, to have that
on the highest stage imaginable in
Europe.
>> But as with all one-v-one competitions,
thank you very much everybody here at IQ
Utrecht. You brought the energy all
weekend long. Let's get in to our final
Squirtle against Red Naxela. And I was
about to say in all one-v-one
games, you can have a team, you can have
the support behind you.
But now it's just down to these two
players to find out the third European
IQ champion.
>> And we are underway.
We have Squirtle going first based off
of his placement in the regular before
top cut.
>> I have some here.
>> every single advantage you can get. The
answer in kind coming through. Bodies on
the board.
>> So, starting Hall of Legends and
Forbidden Wasteland for our
battlefields. And both of these decks
are going to put out units really quick.
They're going to amass wide boards, and
then we're probably going to get to a
point where both players go, "Okay, now
I have to think. Now I have to actually
do a little bit of calculation on on the
way that the combat is going to go."
>> Because I am so fearful because Squirtle
has shown us time and time again, even
when you disrupt that momentum that he
acquires himself, he is so adept at
juggling the resources he does have to
sustain himself, regain his footing, and
come back hitting even harder.
>> I want to pose something to you that is
this for once a battlefield for
Squirtle's choice that doesn't only
benefit himself?
Yeah, because for once if you do lose
control of Hall of the Hall of Legends,
Victor's going to be able to untap and
get two recruits per turn.
>> I think you're you're very you're very
sharp for putting it out. And why you
also have to kind of run it when you
know you're going first. Right? Usually
when you have a die roll, it's not
always very certain.
>> But seeding, as you said, coming into
this. Squirtle knows that they get the
choice in game one.
>> Exactly. You know you can secure
yourself. So, getting it out of the way,
quote unquote, before it can be outside
of your control, that is exactly the
presence of mind you need in the finals.
>> Then forbidding waste giving the minus
two while defending.
And opportunity for Red Naxul to try and
like even up any kind of holes the
difference between the sand soldiers and
the recruits.
>> I hear you.
Um I think it was a throwaway
battlefield in this
>> Fair enough. He just like get that out
of the way.
>> Both of these decks are just so
so adept at overpopulating on the
battlefield.
>> It was bad.
When it happens to you, yeah.
Yeah.
I guess that's it for me. Pass.
>> Even so Squirtle saying, "Yeah, that
feels bad when it happens to you."
Getting the untap.
>> Now, Azir being developed early on in
the game. We saw this happen against
Collin as well.
You need to be pressuring out early.
>> Move here. Move trigger.
Return.
Pass.
>> Yeah, that's going to be a pretty quick
back and forth every time forbidding
waste if it's only the one defender
there. So, we'll just say, "Yeah, not
going to commit anything to that. No
point." It's interesting you mentioned
the Azir as well.
Of course, Azir is going to be able to
move tokens with it when it does go
forward. So,
>> Right to
>> It'll be interesting to see how often
that gets used.
>> How often
Red Naxul will allow it to be used
because we've seen before Victor is
great at striking with surgical
precision taking out the head in command
before committing to any battlefield
themselves. And these bombs need to be
addressed sooner than later or Squirtle
will run with it.
>> The Emperor of the Sands going into
battle himself, equipped with a VF
sword.
>> I'll play Hidden Blade is on the chain.
Defy comes out in response. So, one Defy
gone.
>> to conquer.
>> This guy dies, get the gold.
>> Yes.
>> And with how spell heavy this Victor
deck is, these Defies
>> Great soldier.
You die.
>> are going to be important you would feel
throughout the game.
>> The more you can get out the way the
better. I mean, in this regard, I'm
still going to give it to squirrel in
this weight.
>> Keeping your general safe.
>> Keeping your emperor safe.
Those are really are the price targets
in the deck that is filled with chaff
and throw away units.
>> Meanwhile, taking a look at Red Naxela's
hand, there is some refill when it comes
to the units. There is as in Chiao in
hand, there's a Vi.
>> in hand.
Uh four, I think. Yes, four.
>> At this point, you're going to have to
be really mindful because even though
both of the decks are playing similar
games, the moment similar as in like a
mirror match-up, the moment you give a
minor slip-up, that difference is
compounding.
And you're not really able to pull
yourself back into it.
>> Sure. I'm not going to mess this up
because
it's been a long day.
>> It has been a long day and there's no
way
to prepare for a finals match-up. Let
alone against an IQ champion.
>> Hidden Blade over here.
>> I'll be for context, we're getting close
to 24 hours.
>> Yes.
>> of Riftbound over two days.
>> What's 30 total, yeah? Yes.
>> Bring this over.
>> Yes.
>> Bring this over. Good score.
>> And this is what you need more of,
favorable trades, trying to keep This is
him on the back foot. However,
it does mean
>> a recruit.
>> Cuz we're going blow for blow right now
on this battlefield, wiping each other
up left and right. And the moment you
get units involved that cost power,
that taking cards from your hands,
losing those will be a lot more painful,
especially when they're already alone.
The Forbidden Waste really coming back
to bite if he is not sending any
reinforcements.
>> Red Nexus deep in the tank now, coming
through with deciding the location on
this recruit. We know that Squirtle, for
instance, has an arise in hand, and
that's one of the ways that
when behind and Isia can just spread out
a bunch of units and say, "Hey, actually
I'm still in this game." You have to be
able to deal with all of my weapon
master town soldiers coming at the
battlefield.
>> And earlier we said, "Oh, if it's uh if
it's any less than four, you're not
hitting a good arise." But when you are
coming out the gate swinging like these
players have been, investing a lot of
runes, suddenly two ready bodies can
turn the tide, especially if they will
be taking care of as Xin Zhao. More
resources gobbled up.
>> So,
>> I pass to you.
>> playing to the Forbidden Waste will
deactivate the uh Forbidden Waste
ability for a potential showdown coming
up. That is, of course, if the units
remain as they are.
Never underestimate Squirtle's ability
to manipulate the board in favor and put
himself in the best position. That is
how he has
attained already an RQ trophy, plus put
himself in the finals the very next RQ
he's appeared at. So,
potentially quickly becoming a final
boss of sorts here in Europe.
>> And with a hand so healthy in size, a
rune pool to back it up, Squirtle is not
making empty threats currently.
>> No, he does need to be a little bit more
than he doesn't wait too long cuz
Rednaxel is making full use of his
turns, double scoring time and time
again.
>> Yeah, and the answers are there.
>> That's the danger, right? Because four
seems innocuous, but six is is perilous
to be at against the likes of a Victor.
And we've seen Rednaxel pop out the
sprites and very quickly turn the game
around against the Wally. So, that is
one of the dangers is if you let that
points score creep up
you you get punished so many times.
>> It's where Rednaxel can strike out of
nowhere, catch you by surprise. It's
going to
need a whole lot of prep to be
surprising Squirtle though
who is
launching a counterattack Radisson.
>> And the thing is a rise is basically the
entire turn if it's done for Squirtle.
Like that it is essentially tapping out
say okay I'm doing everything this turn
and then I don't have anything the next
turns. I really hope I really hope
everything that I do sticks.
>> And it's really kind of you have to
ponder because he has so many cheap
>> Yeah, what?
>> gear still in hand
that can be making a difference.
>> thinking for a just a second. I was
about to do a play. I mean it's it's an
important game. My my opponent also took
time and it wasn't a problem.
>> We are in the finals and of course it is
an untimed round as well.
So, uh
Squirtle just thinking through and I
think understandably this is a pivotal
moment in this game as well. I think an
incorrect decision in this moment would
certainly
put Squirtle on the back foot.
>> And you can sense the nervousness from
Squirtle as well. Just because he did it
one time before doesn't make you
suddenly an expert
at things. If I've done something once
>> I I would say Squirtle's an expert at
this.
>> No, but but playing finals, handling
that pressure
You can't train that.
>> That's very true. And Squirtle, you can
see a somewhat uncharacteristic
>> more triggers
>> Yes.
Yeah, conqueror.
Go to three, pay one and top my legend.
I'll play another pay one and another
two create another soldier.
Which will get this one.
And I believe that's turn.
>> Because here's the thing you have to
keep in mind.
>> Calling for five?
>> Yeah.
>> Drop for turn?
>> Yes.
>> Ooh, there is a Sprite Fountain off the
top. Talked about these options to get
out onto battlefields quickly. There's a
Vi in hand as well for potential ambush.
So, this if there's enough
for it, I believe maybe one off to be
doing both in a turn.
No, in fact can do both. I'm mistaken.
>> diving a little deeper into the deck
list of Red Nexus. So,
cards
>> He's Wages of Pain.
>> Uh six.
>> can find such efficiency
on a sand soldier
with an expired brutalizer.
Getting yourself that gold
>> You need that. That's right.
>> Get this guy. You need to show some your
economy some love currently.
>> With so many cards available, you really
have to wonder, do you really want to
defy that? Is that worth holding onto?
Yes is the answer from Squirtle. I'll be
keeping my ground.
Threatening with the Sprite to take over
nonetheless, walking the recruit
afterwards.
Bring this over. Pass.
Hang guard.
>> Yeah.
>> I'll lose Stupefy.
>> Yes.
>> Trade?
>> Yeah.
>> And this is once again a trade where Red
Nexus is coming out on top. They're
trading but the Stupefy replaces itself.
>> Yeah, up to six now as Red Nexus is
>> playing.
>> Essentially putting themselves on game
point for the first
round. I say that because it's
relatively straightforward to score
twice.
>> I didn't No problem.
>> At this point you always have to commit
to a reactive arise to make sure you're
not losing the game.
>> Exactly.
>> Rather to pull it back your way.
>> And then it just comes down to what
answers does Red Nexus have in hand? You
basically have to just say, "Hey, this
is the best shot I can put out there."
You know that the Red Nexus for instance
does have a Vile in hand which would
turn off one big unit.
>> And he will still get uh another Sprite
on his turn.
>> Yeah.
>> The army that Red Nexus is amassing is
looking more lethal by the second.
>> Yeah, Xin Zhao two recruits, the the
Sprite, the Vile in hand plus other
options depending on the draw, means
that even if Squirtle does stack both of
these battlefields, you have to play
around a bunch of different lines here.
You have to also play around the line of
like Imperial Decree coming out. That
would just be a different way of making
it through the battlefields as Squirtle
goes to four points.
>> And that is a nasty position to be in
for Squirtle. You can't be
overpopulating your battlefields cuz
that Imperial Decree is such a major
threat, but only leaving a few units out
there leaves you so vulnerable for
someone that is threatening game one.
>> Exactly. It it it's do or die at this
point in game one for Squirtle.
Red Nexus
has managed to pin back the units from
Squirtle this entire game. It's going to
be an Eye of the Herald.
>> Blood one.
Yeah, well, I recycle the blood one.
of triggers
>> Yeah, yeah.
Stacking on
>> Arise.
>> Yeah. The Forbidden Ways gets the arise
from the floating energy.
And this is
>> Four city states of Gondor.
>> Squirtle. Setting the bar. This is what
you need to reach, Rednaxel. This is all
I have. Do you have what it takes to
take game number one? And now it comes
down to how do you allocate the
soldiers, the equipment, the weapon
masters? Because we know there's a fire
in hand, but four sand soldiers, if this
is all spread out and in a really
separated out pattern, the math then
becomes quite tricky on on how do you
stun? How do you allocate things to each
battlefield? And we'll see what Squirtle
does. Actually, potentially, uh you
know, on
the way that this is lined up
I I'm so so interested to see where
Squirtle goes with this.
>> It's more tricky.
Uh
Like this, okay? Squirtle
with trigger.
Moving here, moving Squirtle. This will
go back. Create a recruit to the base.
This will go
Uh where was that? Did did you played it
here and then move on?
>> Uh I I played the arise, so there were
two tapped units here. One ready unit in
base and one ready unit here.
>> Okay.
>> This one go back. I play a recruiting
base.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> And then I'm thinking about this one.
>> Yeah. Yeah, important to note there's no
restriction on
arise. As long as you control the
battlefield, you can play there and
they're ready, so you can move back to
create
the unit as Squirtle is doing.
And that is it for Squirtle as well. You
You have to survive.
>> Yeah.
>> You have to keep an eye on the future,
as well. So, prioritizing to take two
might out of the equation, to think a
little further ahead, not only about
survival, but about conquest and
domination afterwards, as well. But,
will he get that far?
>> Yeah, these battlefields aren't that
stacked. So, that's the thing is
>> four
and three more, seven.
>> Should we uh
seven, yes.
Seven.
>> Seven's not that big. And only two units
of five makes short work of that.
>> Seven, eight, nine, 10.
>> 10.
>> It is two recruits, Xander, so it's four
units on the one battlefield, four units
on the other one. As uh
the the the way that it's stacked does
uh
adjust things, but yes, it is it is not
as much might as you might hope it would
be if you are in Squirtle's position.
>> Oh my god, this is going to take a
while. Uh then
>> You can't afford any mistakes right now.
A single might can cost you the entirety
of the game. If this assault gets you
nothing, look what you're left with.
>> I must say it, though.
Take your time. You're in finals. Take a
breath. Your opponent's runes are all
exhausted. They're all tapped out.
They're all gone. You know there are no
responses. I believe no hidden cards on
the table, either.
>> But, they're really properly hidden.
>> So, Red Nexus, this is now as a
one-player puzzle
of your first game in a grand finals.
Just get over the top of both of these
battlefields.
>> Don't get too nervous. There's there's
only close to 100 people watching.
Oh, and your family.
>> In the venue. And then all of the all
the people watching at home.
>> Yeah, so and this is where even playing
one finals will pay off so much. The the
the largest step is from zero to one.
Can the first-timer keep control of the
situation, play to his path to victory,
and overcome the puzzle set up by
Squirtle fully entrenched on the
battlefields.
>> Trying to see exactly what was in hand
from Red Naxel. As it goes back down to
the the the table. I believe there's a
salvage there. So that would be getting
another look plus
killing a gear. There is What's that one
in the main deck?
>> I'll trade with this guy. Yes.
I'll bring
everything over.
And I'll play Vi.
>> The Vi coming out.
>> Uh so
>> That's one more than I had.
>> And keep in mind
>> with Jinzo as a tank
>> Jinzo as a tank. Yes.
>> It's tough to trade efficiently.
It feels like Red Naxel
>> And
>> um
>> I will do a crude
>> position I mean says
I can just hold this to when I don't
need to conquer both battlefields.
>> And the kingdom of Squirtle lacks an
emperor to rally the troops around. It's
hard to mobilize an entire army.
>> I hold to six.
>> But remember this deck cascades
equipment incredibly well onto single
units. Is there a line for Squirtle to
break this hold leaving one unit back on
the battlefield? It's all down to what
is in Squirtle's hand. I feel like
that's
>> Okay.
>> such
>> 1800
>> rickety situation.
Two in hand. We know
>> 4 5
>> that one is a salvage.
>> 11
>> Oh, there's a death grip in hand.
>> The death grip
>> And an on guard.
There is a significant amount of might
to be transferred.
>> And importantly enough,
Salvage's action speed. So, cannot play
it in response to that Death Grip.
How respectful will Squirtle be of the
two energy left open?
I think he might have found the the way
out.
I think he
The math on
on this, of course there is of course I
I think it's a BF sword on that Sand
Soldier.
It is going to get
Salvage away, but there's another BF
sword there that can be equipped.
There's a Soul Sword as well, and all
you got to do is get over this one
battlefield
and then conquer.
With the recruit that follows behind it.
>> And
after that, if they can get it to stick,
but Nexul's only outs are like
Thousand-Tailed Watchers.
>> But it's down to Squirtle respecting a
potential Salvage. If if the math is
Salvage, a hidden blade they could be
representing as well. There is a
plethora of options.
Even even an Eclipse we saw flying
around before as well. And here's where
our perfect information on the game with
the hands makes it a very different
puzzle to look at than what Squirtle
has. Squirtle has to consider all of
these lines of which is the most likely,
which is the most
that I have to play around.
And it's impossible to know.
>> Can this be the moment where all the
guidance from his teammates will come to
fruition that can speak to him all the
way from the audience. The first assault
and possibly final has been launched.
>> Uh
my trigger results.
>> Okay, move trigger results are into the
showdown.
Uh, this one
the long sword.
The BF sword just to clarify. The uh,
long sword not
Yes. The the the tiger just a a
clarification on that is
It is two BF. Uh, so this is an eight
nine in total. Let me think for a
second. And unfortunately I look at four
here. Uh, yeah. The move trigger
is going to negate one of the might that
the young guard in hand would have given
to Squirtle because now there's the
other unit. It does mean that you're
trading evenly on that because the
recruit is the other one, but just
important to note it doesn't represent
plus two. And there is not a lot of
wiggle room left. You are committed to
the showdown now and you're missing your
most effective weapon.
But is there a way of kind of cascading
the rest of it onto the recruit in base?
That's the other thing that is as long
as you clear this battlefield out at
some way through this turn.
It's so tricky cuz Sinzau messes with
the math taking a lot of his followers
as protection. There is still five might
remaining. But this would be enough,
right? Is that No, it's an eye of the
herald. It's not a BF sword. I was going
to say the salvage has removed enough of
the power.
And look how Red Knuckles' attitude is
shifting. He is suddenly a lot less
nervous about his position. A shake of
the head from Squirtle. Squirtle doesn't
know whether he's found a way out from
this. Doesn't have the XP either, I
believe.
For the man that rarely loses, he's
close to be reminded of his own
mortality.
Does the math once more just to make
sure Squirtle's going to play two pieces
of equipment, Doran's Shield and
This will go for sure. Soul sword.
equip here.
Put two to two.
Can equip the Harold to potentially get
the plus one from the recruit. Needs at
least five to stay alive. Says float
one.
>> I mean do we go right this important
here?
>> You're right Squirtle. It is important.
I haven't seen Squirtle this tense all
weekend.
He's being pushed to the limit in the
game where he goes first it should favor
him a little bit.
>> Here. It's a three.
>> Up to three.
I have the Harold could make it. Young
God is in hand which would become five
and if you can equip the Harold right
that takes it up to six with the recruit
and the recruit would survive and it
would be enough to get through it
surely.
>> Going here.
>> Yeah.
>> With one floating only now playing
guard.
So this is
five at the moment.
So I will play one float one.
>> Yeah. Equips it goes down to zero runes
decides all in on the economy will go
over the battlefield but Rednaxel has
top decked his way to stay in to a game
before already. It costs Squirtle
everything he has but the ends justify
the means.
Two battlefields have to be cleared out
by Rednaxel.
And Squirtle considering next turn. If
you can retake you need to retake two.
We know what's in hand. Which which
would would win the game if you retake
both Rednaxel would be totally fine with
that. There is no turn after this for
Squirtle. We are down to the final point
between these two players in game one of
our final. Rednaxel will draw one off
THE TOP FIST BUMP AND Squirtle it looked
so dire in this first game.
Push him. Keep pushing him. It just
makes him play better. Push this man to
the limit and he starts to shine. The
reigning European regional champion is
able to shrug off a dire situation in
game one and be able to close out that
game. Not a single rune left to his
name, but an empire below his feet going
into game two. It's only going to get
harder. This sideboard of Retnaxus, I
cannot overstate how important the
pickpockets are. How important the extra
gear interactions will be. And on the
other side for Squirtle, I'm just not
sure if the sideboard changes will have
that much of an impact. So, to look at
the
>> Okay. sideboard from Squirtle again,
players have decklists on stage. You can
see them uh scanning down the list of
everything main board, sideboard. One
thing uh potentially to bring in, it
doesn't always seem like the best of of
of uses to use a charm on a token, but
the fact of the matter is if you can
control the number of units in the enemy
field, then maybe you can actually
maintain your position. And there are
two copies of charm in Squirtle's
sideboard. Would we expect to see them
come in in this match-up?
>> Here's the thing. I think if you can
manage to have them stick on units like
the Victor, like even the Sinzhaos,
making sure that they're not getting any
value out of that tank ability cuz that
really messed with the combat where this
this Victor is getting away with
recruits beyond count when you think oh
I actually had the numbers here.
>> Whereas Squirtle at the same time is
like tank? That's cute. I'll just blow
right past it over the top with all of
the might combined of Shurima.
Wow.
What a
What a what a story already being
written by Squirtle. I mean, we're now
one game away. One game for Squirtle
away
from back-to-back European
titles for
Squirtle. Yes, I will
continue to say we've had other IQs.
Squirtle has not attended them. So, for
him, this is the next appearance after
his win.
>> Honestly, how gracious of him to give
other people a chance as well.
>> By not By not buying a plane ticket?
>> Yeah.
>> Interesting. Yeah, fair. This is the
main board of Squirtle. Anything that
you think we'd be looking at dropping?
>> Yeah, the Vi.
>> Bye-bye.
>> Okay. It's really It's really kind of
tough to get the value out of the Vi,
especially because Victor tends to get
onto the battlefield first regardless.
>> Uh-huh.
>> It is really hard to find a proper
target to be taken out of the fight.
Similar arguments can be made for the
back off.
>> Yeah, that was going to be the next
thing I was going to ask of like, "Hey,
if if the Vi is out for the same reason,
do we look at the back off?" Then, we
talked a little bit about what do you
bring in instead?
Arguments to be made around the Ash,
perhaps, with a question mark, because
of things like Imperial Decree or some
of the spells that you're anticipating
to come in. And there there's a lot of
holding in this series, so I would say.
So, it's it's not a permanent option
like against other decks.
>> It is maybe as like a one-of.
>> Just Sure, yeah.
>> I like it as an option just to get the
information.
>> Okay. And
>> I mean, don't get me started on on on
information, but
it gets more valuable as you get later
into the tournament. When you know your
opponent has tendencies that they tend
to gravitate to,
the more you get that to play with, to
leverage that to your advantage, that is
how you become champion.
>> Meanwhile, for Red Naxel, we talked a
little bit about sideboard already with
the likes of Salvage able to come in and
the Pickpockets. Anything that you're
you're looking at from the the deck list
of Rednaxel to say, maybe we can drop
that out of game two. There are some
some different things in there. Does
Does the Watcher stay in, do you think?
Again, it we're predicting two players
that are in finals, so
>> Here's the thing. I think the Watcher
and Bellows Breath combo, even though we
haven't seen it once,
>> Oh, sure. Actually, that does rack.
>> absolute devastation. And it doesn't
matter how Well, it does matter, but
even taking out three Sand Soldiers
without repeating it is
incredibly painful.
>> Yeah, that's fair. As we are on
Arena's Greatest for Rednaxel and Seat
of Power for our second game. So, Seat
of Power, obviously,
>> It lets you draw when you control both.
>> draw and is basically saying, we're just
going to play with a lot of cards in
this game.
>> I would like to discuss your take on
including Coldlight because for Victor,
>> Yeah.
>> you love playing Coldlight if you can
trade upwards, but there is that that
tipping point where the value you're
getting from
Coldlight out of an Azure is very
diminished. Early game, you're really
happy to see that.
Mid to late game, oh, he's also
sacrificed to recruit. I think there's
an argument to be made. It is too
situational. Most of the game is spent
either mid or late game. I'll take it
out and then I'll kick myself if it's
like my one out.
>> That's fair. It's an interesting one
that we'll talk about. And something
else that's interesting that I want to
bring up, we saw it in the previous
series, there's a one-of Chakram Dancer,
which is not a card that we've seen too
often in the meta. It did actually work
decently well against Thuwali to, you
know, ready up and shore up some of
those battlefields. It's actually also a
bit of an in-joke and a meme
with his brother and their friends with
the Chakram Dancer, so we'll see
how Rednaxel goes.
>> Channel three.
Draw.
>> And here, once again, we have a a
situation where Squirtle is introducing
a battlefield that his opponent is very
happy with to be conquering all the
same. We talked about before Rednaxelol,
the only thing holding him back, drawing
enough cards. Seed of Power enables just
that.
>> It does indeed. And of course, that's
Squirtle being
uh on the the the
I want to say on the draw, but playing
second.
Is the way that that is said.
>> I suffer from the same affliction.
>> Uh does say, yeah, okay, it's my
battlefield, but you're going to get
more of the benefit from it in the early
game, cuz you'll just like spam out
units and get it. But Rednaxelol
um
will take advantage of that. And we
talked a little bit earlier
um a about the the Carrion Dancer.
Sorry, Carrion Dredger, I should say.
And the value that that has in these
decks where you're just able to to trade
it and say, yeah, I'll get the bird
anyway, that's fine.
>> Here Here's the thing. Both of these
decks are so great at carrying momentum,
not letting themselves be slowed down by
losing units.
>> I have a feeling that both Squirtle and
Rednaxelol having such similar play
styles index
>> I'll hide the card.
>> understand where you're like, I really
need to think about where this token
goes. Like you had Rednaxelol go to put
it down at the battlefield and say,
sorry, hang on. With your right Yeah, no
problem. But it literally I think it's
going to happen again and again where
they're like, one second. I need to I I
thought it was here. Maybe it's better
somewhere else.
>> And I'm really enjoying their their
cutthroat play style because they are
not waiting around for too long. I don't
think we we've really seen more than
five or six units at the same time on
the board because they are constantly
being fed to the war machine.
>> And Rednaxelol uh
looking to even this series up. There's
an Arisen Hand, Knight of Harold. Hidden
Blade. There is an axe that has come in
from the side board from Squirtle.
>> I mean, even just to put it down, even
if it's for a single turn, if that's all
you need to make the difference.
>> I do wonder though whether if your
Squirtle, you have to have turned the
corner on the game first and it's kind
of like a win more card of like, "Hey,
now I'm ahead. I know you're not going
to hold. So, now I'll play out the Ash
to take away any chance you have coming
back into the game." Cuz you play it out
now and it's just a body that eventually
gives a card back.
>> I think that's valid criticism.
>> Meanwhile, at
the arena,
we need to defy the eclipse. And once
again, Squirtle's aggressive
protectiveness of the sand soldiers
>> Wages from Hidden.
>> This
Losing out the defy, losing the sand
soldier all the same
and giving some relief to Rat and Axel
who will be claiming another gold
token. This is what it's all about.
Preventing Azir from getting more than
just a handful of permanence onto the
board.
>> Rat and Axel on the other hand, I think
there's a stupify in hand if I saw it
quickly before he placed it down. A
little bit low on the cards.
Will go to his turn, obviously gets one
one more draw.
>> Squirtle or three.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah.
>> And see the powers right for the taking.
>> Yeah, exactly. So, that that is the way
out of that, get the card draw.
>> My turn.
Ooh, the defy has stuck around.
And it makes a lot more sense for Rat
and Axel to keep the defy around as
these gears tend to multiply.
>> We've all done it. We've all done it.
The gold token stays in base, but the
recruit token goes forward. Hey, first
IQ, you're in the grand finals. Who am I
Who's my opponent? Oh, it's the IQ
champion from Leel. Great. And he's
playing tokens, too? Okay, fine. We'll
excuse a few little things. Call the
week
in hand super fast
by
>> And this is the exact moment where Call
the Week is in it at its most powerful.
Where you can keep your opponent down.
Where it doesn't have to cut through
plenty of bodies out there. But when it
can bully around the loners.
>> Yeah, although not
able to play it
at this current point in time. So the
one sensei will make it through.
Has stayed
in the base for this. Squirtle now has
to look to re-control this game as Red
Knuckles starting to take up in the
points.
>> And you really have to start making the
decision out am I going to invest in
more gears out into the board which are
quite limited currently.
>> Uh-huh.
>> It's way too early for an arise even in
the most dire of situations.
So if you want to take back control of
the battlefield, prevent your opponent
from going all the way up to six and
start threatening the game afterwards,
you have to put yourself out in a
vulnerable position.
>> Yeah, and you know that however you post
up on battlefields
this turn, Red Knuckles does have units
already available to get back to both
battlefields.
>> Accelerating Azear out there looking to
draw more with a concrete seat of power.
But that is a costly enterprise to be
in. Holy having to deal with the
Squirtle out there, then a Call the Week
could be disaster. Nothing hidden at
these battlefields. No way out.
>> That's what I was going to say. The the
fact that that draw into go means no
hidden cards available for Squirtle even
to try and feign a backup plan. We're
basically down to a defy or an on guard
with one rune available. Squirtle's not
going to a whole lot of options in this
attack.
>> So regardless, you are looking to at
least take over one battlefield, make
him sacrifice the other, and then the
gates are open. The city ours.
>> Yeah, exactly. The Viy potentially comes
to fruition here with just one unit
moving into that battlefield, and then
you Viy, get the stun. I don't think
that there's anything that the Squirtle
really can present in that situation to
prevent that battlefield from from
getting conquered by Rednaxel.
>> Uh
>> And uh the Pickpocket
>> Bring this guy on.
>> comes out of the sideboard. That's what
we were talking about earlier.
Goes in against the Sand Soldier that is
on Arena's Greatest. Wants to to
make sure to conquer Arena's Greatest
first, get the value out of holding that
battlefield, so that when you do go and
deal with that pesky Azir, you will get
the draw off it as well from the Seat of
Power.
>> Conquer.
>> Not a single resource goes wasted in
Victor's Empire.
>> The bird, followed by Viy, and that
means Squirtle has to find an answer to
Rednaxel's battlefield, and we know that
that arises in hand, but it's going to
be the entire turn. Only one will have a
Brutalizer to it.
>> Brute as well.
>> He is up on the ropes. Ways out seem
limited, but we have said it before.
>> And the Sprite Fountain is in hand as
well. We're closing in on a final game
of the series. Does Squirtle have
anything other than the Arise to do? Is
there another way out of this?
>> He is an escape artist, but surely he is
human, too. Surely Squirtle has its
limits.
>> So, there's the Gods that would
potentially be a ready unit if you can,
you know, pay the recycle for that.
That's going to be the way out. It's not
the Arise at this point in time.
Weaponmaster Brutalizer.
>> Yeah, five.
>> Five, yeah.
>> Uh
>> I've a good four?
>> Good four.
>> Is there another way that's go?
>> Oh, dear lord, the call of week is in
hand. Surely we will equalize the score.
>> Got to be careful for the defy. Got to
be careful if that's what you're banking
on. I mean, it's it's such a small spell
for the amount of runes that are
available for Rednaxel. You've got
options here.
A hidden blade as well would do the job.
>> You don't want to trip up at the finish
line. Not when you're so close.
>> You've got multiple options here that
you can eat at least one defy. Then you
just got to make your opponent have the
second one and you've got turns to play
with. Call of week comes out. Squirtle
pulls back the sand soldier and that
means Rednaxel is going to eight points
and Rednaxel is taking us to a game
three in our Hu Utrecht finals.
>> Game number three in the R Hu Utrecht
finals, a fate that any finals deserves.
This is what a victor can do to the
Azir. Put them under pressure from turn
one and never allow them an inch.
However,
once again Squirtle will be starting
first.
We know what the battlefields will be.
Rock fall path on the side of Victor. It
only closes off any potential hidden
guards. That is about it. Not a lot to
be gained
from there further. Actually, hurting
their own value along with it. So, it
makes sense they held on for this as
long as they could, but now they have to
face the music. Yeah, it also does have
a secondary effect on things like gods.
>> There is a nightmare unfolding for
Squirtle. His last battlefield is
Tri-Farian War Camp.
>> Mhm, yeah.
>> iconic for its uses in Victor Decks.
>> That that's a really really key point
and as you were talking about gods, I
was alluding to Azizi's arise ability.
That's another thing that will get
turned off by the war camp and that's
the other Sorry, not war camp, the
Rockfall Path. You're right, these
battlefields do
somewhat have a favor
towards the victor, but how many times
have we seen Squirtle in a position
where his opponent is favored? Sometimes
Squirtle seems to crash through. Don't
see it all that often.
>> A true Houdini who can get himself out
of many a sticky situation. You don't
become a two-time finalist cuz you're
lucky.
You get it cuz you've earned it.
>> Certainly luck helps on the day.
Certainly it it's good to top deck
sometimes.
I mean there was definitely a fortunate
semi-finals.
But plenty of times it was in fact
Squirtle who made his own luck, who made
his own fortune and it paid off time and
time again.
>> So, it comes to this.
Two whole days of play.
13 rounds of Swiss
plus a top eight cut.
Routes through IQ Champions for both of
these competitors.
A game each
in a token landscape
for both Squirtle and Red Knaxel.
And it's one win away for either of
these players
from putting their names in history.
Either Squirtle is only the second
two-time RQ winner or Red Knaxel running
the gauntlet on the first attempt. And
>> Here's the thing, as we are shaking
hands and getting into game number
three. Do or die, all or nothing. A
rookie making a grand appearance or
champions reigning ever strong.
>> Let's take a look at opening hands,
opening mulligans. Squirtle will send
one back. Red Knaxel will now
make a similar decision.
>> Ooh, Salvage already in the opening
hand.
>> And the Sprite Fountain that has come
so useful to Red Knaxel through the top
eight route.
Would love to see Squirtle's choices.
You have to feel like there's equipment
in hand from uh that mulligan decision.
>> Funnily enough, even with all the
sideboard Salvages included, still only
gets one Red Knaxel up to two Salvages.
>> Okay.
>> Big Pockets are going to be very
important and you might have to hold on
with the Salvage to answer the BF
Swords.
>> And uh the Chakram Dancer, I believe,
was drawn from Red Knaxel. Now that that
kind of like joke may end up being in
like a competitive deck. Imagine that
way of saying I think it's actually a
useful card potentially in this match
up. So, the opening turns are Squirtle
plays the Sword into the Sand Soldier.
The other side of the table, it's quite
a quick Honest Broker and Recruit follow
up say go back to our reigning RQ
European Champion.
>> Eye of the Herald looking to make full
use of that Triferian war camp, start
reinforcing, start entrenching, do not
give an inch.
Will of course
be neutral for the if the units are
neutral that battlefield will be
Not benefiting either of them, but now
with the sand soldier entering the fray
into the base, you get the weapon master
trigger. Squirtle's going to think about
it.
And you're really already at a
crossroads
as Red Nexus.
Cuz you're going to have to start to
ponder do I counter pressure, do I try
and race, or do I try to establish my
board a little more and look for a more
opportune moment was giving more
breathing room towards the RQ champion.
Believe there was a a hidden blade
drawn from Red Nexus.
Looked like it for a split second.
A hidden card.
Yes, as uh don't always get the best of
looks, but now we get a good old good
old look at the hand from Red Nexus as
we said salvage in there fountain
or the sprites of Chakram Dancer.
And then a stupify at the back. So
some tools to work with, but when you're
having to kind of play out the recruits
and then you have to re you know
establish some sense of control it's a
bit slow. And here's the thing you're
still going to face up into two energy
on the side from Azir. There are plenty
of
tools available here you a discipline
that can bail out if need be.
You just saw Squirtle take a puzzle look
for a moment on what Red Nexus was
getting up to and then realizes you want
my recruit off this. That's an intention
to tell you there's a call the week
around the corner potentially in mind
when you're looking at something, but we
know that it's not there. Also Sprite
fountain we will go up to four be able
to trade, and then it is Ret and Axel's
turn to get himself established, but it
will be a costly investment.
>> But that's the the the multiple lines
you have to take into account is which
of the two is it? Now you see the Sprite
fountain. Now it comes out.
>> And when the resources are scarce and
growing scarcer still, every commitment
of power is
is a bloodletting, honestly.
>> Now, Squirtle does have a discipline
in hand, will use it, taps out in order
to play that.
Now it's down to
multiple choices with uh
>> And it's
>> Ooh, Ambush Chakram Dancer. Now won't
get the benefit from the shield.
>> Yeah, have a look at that, Squirtle.
Squirtle's like, "Wait a second, what is
that card?"
Chakram Dancer Ambush is in, turns the
tide. That wasn't the line that you were
reading. We were talking about Call the
Week. We were talking uh about a Sprite
fountain. No, Chakram Dancer comes out,
takes out the Sand Soldier, and leaves
the Sprite behind.
However, Ret and Axel, that is not a
stronghold. He is limping just that
little bit, and now it's up to Squirtle.
How much do I want to invest because can
I weather another
Sprite that is ready and gunning?
>> Of course, that Sprite that is there
will not score on
the Trafarian war camp. It is in the
beginning phase. It will uh
disappear before scoring. So, Squirtle
knows that for now it would be holding
to three.
>> That hurts.
>> Oh, you're just in the grand finals.
>> highlighting uh
>> rubbing it in a teeny bit. I know that
feeling, but yeah, that that hurts,
doesn't it?
>> I mean, it's mirrored on the other side.
Does it look familiar?
>> Right next to
>> one of these?
>> happy because he he only needs order
runes at this point. Everything is just
dandy for that.
>> Uh, that's a dunk. No.
No, if it does not arrive can't play.
>> Okay.
I mean,
yeah. It's fine.
>> And here you have the selection of
battlefields. That is really important.
>> Because it's
>> only a limited amount of bodies
available. Two Squirtle. He's using the
safety of the rockfall path that cannot
be ambushed.
>> And importantly though, the rockfall is
turning off the eye of the herald
because eye of the herald says here and
units cannot be played here on rockfall
path.
Weapon master comes through, brings back
the eye. Want to get that off that
battlefield. Now a hidden card.
>> On the rockfall path.
>> Which means it's
>> Is it a hidden blade? Pretty much, yeah.
>> It's it's
you know that at that point. It's hidden
blade.
>> But but but might as well place face it
up, buddy.
>> As Lothar and I said, the not so hidden
blade.
All the way through Squirtle's win.
>> that one the deadliest or
>> Uh, it's pretty deadly. When you know
it's coming, it's still quite deadly.
>> Try Farian war camp looking oh so
inviting.
Can you truly already commit to start to
contest the rockfall path?
Seems dire but
because you are giving a moment's rest
to the Azir, the gears start to
reappear. Pickpockets not have made an
appearance just yet.
And developing the Victor onto the
battlefield would be
putting your general in jeopardy.
>> Is is that just a body at this point? It
Right next to thinking about it still,
hasn't moved on.
>> X
It is so
vulnerable.
A single brutalizer could get the job
done on sand soldier.
I mean, there's a lot you
if the charms got sidewooded in
If the charms got sidewooded in then
Squirtle can pick apart battlefield
quite easily as well.
>> There's there's
Can you really play around the charm
even?
>> Uh my my point is just that, you know,
in post sideboard there are different
options that you have to consider
through here. So, stacking one
battlefield isn't maybe as uh
>> And you you just can hear an actual pray
that he he had he had a Xinzhao by his
side, a bodyguard. We will hide a card
for some extra protection, but this
might be the most pivotal play in the
entire RQ weekend.
>> Rednaxel stacks up the battlefield,
stacks up the war camp. A Squirtle
awakens, ready's for the turn.
Has three
pieces of equipment available should an
arise be
in hand, although it doesn't have the
runes for it. So, it'll be a following
turn
for an arise. So, do you develop more
equipment here? Do you get more sand
soldiers? I caught the
the flash of a discipline there, so that
would as well help
pump up and over, but this is already
quite a big battlefield. Remember,
Teferian war camp giving plus one to all
of Rednaxel's units.
>> Yeah, threatening five. If you equip the
Doran's Shield, you will go up to six,
give yourself tank.
That will be quite pivotal to keep your
recruits safe.
But you have to be mindful. We know Hit
and Blade are out there.
>> Uh-huh.
>> And with how nervous Squirtle looks,
you're going to have to keep in mind
what kind of information conveys that,
cuz that doesn't scream I have to fight
to me.
>> No, but and that battlefield currently
is 12. Victor with war camp, Sprite with
the war camp, recruit with the war camp.
But that's a surprisingly hard to break
battlefield.
>> And most importantly of all, why is
Squirtle sweating this? Because he is
losing the hold race currently. He has
to act cuz if he lets this get out of
hand,
it's too far gone.
>> I said 12, it's 11, I believe. But well,
let Squirtle do the math when it is time
to go in. It may not very well be this
turn, but we have seen Squirtle use the
death grip to
incredible
incredible strength throughout his
multiple now IQ runs.
Potentially setting up.
It's a bit of a bomb.
>> Going in. What trigger?
>> On every side, it's such a vulnerable
play.
>> Trying to use hidden blade on you.
YEAH.
OH.
>> OH, NO. OH, IT JUST goes through and
Rednaxel is going to [__] the attack
>> They're from Squirtle.
>> There will be a sanctuary coming out for
next turn, but now there is a serious
gap that you can exploit out of. Now you
are even more vulnerable to a potential
call the week.
>> And now it does somewhat flip the tempo
of this game as Rednaxel is going to
hold to four.
>> Right dies.
>> And say, "Okay, if we're one for one,
the way that this ticks, I should be
able to take this."
>> Yeah, it pushes Squirtle from bad to
worse, because that play gave him gave
him two cards, but he's really tight on
resources. Yeah. So,
leveraging that into the game-winning
play is going to be really hard,
especially when Victor is entrenching
himself, building a fortress on the
Treferian war camp.
>> There's a murmur in the venue here in
the viewing area. You can hear people
start to speak
and build up
towards a final moment in this match up.
Is a player that first RQ an unknown at
the RQ about to take down the RQ Leal
champion who is undefeated,
undefeated
>> 30 games
>> in two RQs so far.
Salvage on the eye removing the
additional unit production from
Squirtle.
>> And that is that value we were talking
about with the pickpockets coming
through. You're picking apart
a champion leaving him with the slim
pickings as
even an Arise is not a guaranteed
bailout anymore.
>> And even though
there's confidence on the side of
Rednexel
there's a
quick in the step.
Do not count Squirtle out. We have done
that before and it cost us dearly.
>> All to floor.
>> Yes.
>> And these are the
pivotal potential last turns.
So Squirtle needs to find an answer
here.
Finds a Squirtle
>> Squirtle crab
>> Squirtle crab and that is not
particularly an answer here. It's a one
of in the main board. It will draw
another card though. So
>> And it gets you another dig.
>> Finally that the fight that he could
have used oh so well a
mere turn a go.
Laughing at him in his hand.
Going over the lines one more time.
It is really what can we pick apart what
is left on the Trevenant world cup? Even
picking apart a single body from there
will mean
more and more openings to exploit.
On the clap back from Rat Naxel, you
have to keep in mind
two bodies ready to start running from
the base and because of the gold tokens
that he has been nourishing
throughout, he will be moving up all the
way to A. That is the point where you
can start threaten thousand tail
watchers again. Options in favor of Rat
Naxel, but it's a treacherous path that
he is on.
You When do we see Squirtle this pressed
for options? When in this run have we
seen him this deep in thought? Even in
Leal.
I It didn't feel like they pushed him to
his absolute limit in the way that the
first timer is currently doing.
Whereas Rat Naxel's cool, calm, and
collected.
For for a player that
again, first IQ appearance.
Has Squirtle potentially on the ropes.
This is the the demeanor of a of a
player that knows when they're down,
knows when they're almost out, and knows
their deck hasn't given them the answer
that they need in this match up. It's BF
sword
into legend ability.
And that just sets up for next turn and
you know that Rat Naxel here is going to
hold up to five and where do we go from
there? And because you are spending a
turn developing, getting the BF sword
out, you are opening the door.
Opening the door for Rat Naxel to start
pressuring that other battlefield even
though he's not required to just yet.
You're going to have to fight a battle
on two fronts.
>> Oh, a Bellow's Breath.
Oh, that is not what Squirtle would be
happy to see. Bellow's Breath has been
so good and and that's two, right?
That's one already in hand. This could
be a blowout moment with a Stupefy in
hand as well. Red may just say I don't
need economy. He lost to it in the first
game where Squirtle said, "To hell with
my runes, I'm moving on." This might be
Red Naxel saying, "I'm going to just
wipe all of your units out and conquer
to put myself in a winning position.
>> Light the forges, strike the iron while
it is hot and currently Rat Naxel seems
to be on fire inching forward to
immortality.
Can he get the impossible done?
Take your time.
>> Got to respect the one up from Squirtle.
>> he has to Defy in hand.
>> And it has to be respected. So,
how much he spend on this?
The repeat is expensive and if that gets
defied, is that
the tipping point?
>> Can we
have a distraction set up? Can we bait
anything out from Squirtle? Force him to
do the most important risk assessment
challenge he has done yet.
>> This is where you really hope Squirtle
doesn't speak Greek.
Red Naxel seems to be working all the
way through all of the lines here.
Victor forward, pass. The Stupefy in
hand, is this the bait?
>> Okay, she's dead.
>> Victor will be going down, will be
stocking up the hand a little bit more.
>> I think that was Rednaxel trying to bait
out something.
>> Assumed there was a hidden blade there
at one point, but maybe Rush is into it
as the recruit perhaps now.
Digging more and more.
Really feels like we're digging for that
thousand tail watcher, but they're a
little skittish today.
>> Got a hidden blade though. You don't
necessarily need the watcher if you're
able to just take out all of the units
here. Again, Squirtle needs to refill on
the next turn, so it would have to be
like a rise off the top in order to end
up breaking this if we do see Rednaxel
wipe the board.
>> And why you really want to prioritize
this is something that we haven't talked
about in at least two matches. So, the
importance of six victory points,
everybody's favorite talking point. The
moment you start to be in a position
where you can threaten the game in a
single turn, that has to be respected.
>> Okay, it's actually going to be the
stack on the battlefield for Rednaxel,
not going
for
the board wipe.
Doesn't want to get caught up by that
defy. Doesn't want
to be in a position where you you're
closing in on a win, but actually end up
losing out by playing too brash. This is
Rednaxel saying, I am keeping the pace.
I am setting the pace in this game. I am
ahead on the points.
>> But, we have seen Squirtle break these.
Game one was in oddly familiar position
where Squirtle death gripped in and went
over the top.
>> That is exactly what came to my mind as
well, James. A single hidden blade
>> is
>> stuck away.
Now, it is up to Squirtle to prove that
he is worthy of all the commemoration
that he has been receiving throughout
the weekend.
>> It's gods off the top. That'll give one
extra unit.
>> And now Squirtle's talking through. My
Spanish is not good enough to know
anything other than what accelerate
does. I'm just going to assume he's
talking about the gods coming in ready.
>> I sure hope Rednaxel doesn't speak
English. That would be
>> I hope he understands at that point.
Death grip. Double death grip in hand
with a Defy Discipline. So, you can you
can get that. You can get high enough up
as long as you hold that Defy for the
hidden blade.
>> But, that is a high price to be paying.
If you are even capable of sacrificing
the two bodies,
you're leaving the door open on the
other side of the battlefield. And
currently
in two decks that are so
nonchalant about sacrificing bodies,
they aren't have never been caring more
about their units than they have at this
moment.
>> Teferri and War Camp is doing work for
Rednaxel here, and it Remember, this is
Squirtle's battlefield. Not of choice,
cuz we're at the end of the game.
>> And even if you do manage to take it
out, the fact that Rednaxel will be
untapping with three bodies ready to go
due to the Deathknell effect spawning
the birds, means you are having a
serious threat once again.
>> That's true. Luckily, if you're on team
Mycelian
or were a fan of Squirtle's, it's not
the case that Rednaxel would be able to
win on the next turn with that. Would
hold to six. Score to seven if you're
able to clear out both battlefields, and
then need another turn.
And we can never count Squirtle out.
>> Looking
for a path through treacherous terrain.
>> And important to note in this game, the
Azir from the champion's zone is still
there. So, if Squirtle is able to thread
the needle and find a way back into this
game that Azir could be a killing blow,
but we're a ways away from that. In goes
the big unit
of Squirtle.
>> Um maybe I can react to this.
>> There is a Eye of the Herald trigger on
the chain.
And that is what Rednaxela is deciding
if they want to react to, because of
course otherwise we go to Squirtle's
>> So that's seven.
>> Eight.
>> It will be 10 in total.
>> Uh
you can do the trigger.
No action.
>> No action.
>> Um wow, we're going to trade.
>> 10.
>> I want to 8 10 2.
>> And remember Squirtle's that that
cascade of re-equipping
hurts the economy on the next turn.
Pass, pass.
>> Uh 4 6 8 10.
>> The Tevarin war camp soaked
>> as the dust settles.
>> I was going to say I was going to ask if
sand soldiers bleed, but I guess not. Uh
as the equip comes through on the BF
sword now moves in to look to conquer
finally, but
>> Yes.
>> We know what's coming next.
>> I'll try to do this here.
Just going over the option, but the the
five ready to go.
>> Is this really worth two extra cards? I
doubt it is.
>> Squirtle's giving it serious thought.
>> Play the fight.
>> Mhm.
>> The fight comes through, needs to hold
that unit, needs to take control of the
pace of the game.
>> Yeah.
>> Will get up to six.
So,
do you do you hold up
economy? Do you look to play out?
Is there any reason to play out the Azir
now? Are you just waiting to accelerate
it next turn?
>> Here's the thing. Rat Naxel cannot be
threatening the game when he gets his
upcoming turn.
>> Right.
>> That is the cost of trying to hold on to
that battlefield.
>> Squirtle now it goes back into his
favor, right? Because now the points are
being set at the pace that Squirtle
wants. So, if you can set up to be able
to
force Red Naxel onto both and say,
"Yeah, go to seven points. That's fine.
I need to conquer on my next turn."
>> And even if you do manage to get the
watcher now, because all the bodies are
spread out,
it is hard to find proper value to stick
around.
>> Yeah.
>> And they're buffed up.
>> Watcher defensively is nowhere near as
good as watcher aggressively,
but a Scuttle Crab potentially with a
B.F. Sword
might very well do the job on the next
turn.
>> That would make me fear for my life.
I'll be real.
>> Scary scary thoughts. Sand Soldier
>> Uh which gear did you play this turn?
>> Yeah, I not play a gear.
>> Did you play a gear?
>> I played Eye of the Herald.
>> Yeah?
Yeah, I
I was 100% cuz I used Eye of the Herald
to get the the
>> Okay.
>> Did you find a I guess you could just
roll
check it, just in case.
>> Did I break the other one?
Oh, sorry.
>> Yes, you you broke the other one with a
pocket.
>> I guess. Okay.
>> I just go
>> if you can wait and just double check.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> So, the The laid out in front of you,
you can only activate as there's legend
ability if you have played a gear this
turn and red knuckle cuz these turns are
being mulled over for quite a while, you
kind of lose sense of where the turn
starts and where it's
>> And that's the thing is is keeping up
with what your opponent is doing at that
exact turn as you follow the lines
through is a skill in its own right at
this high level.
>> And you have the resources right now.
You have a judge next to you to just
double check that everything's above
board.
>> we're waiting for confirmation.
Uh if I played a during this turn. I I
think I did but I think it's better if
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Okay. Perfect.
>> Uh so good.
>> Uh no problem. Uh weapon master triggers
uh I will
Uh
get this one I believe.
Yes. That's better.
>> I must admit even uh
at the caster's booth
sometimes keeping track of what was
played on what turn is not as easy as
you might think. And we don't have the
pressure of figuring out how to get
through this turn to win a championship.
>> We also have those judges there.
I'm not going to commit to any
statements before uh before my lawyer
has cleared it.
>> Chat no.
>> Oh yeah. Of course.
>> Um a Squirtle
>> The all-knowing oracle.
>> Squirtle has found a way to put two
units in base. Two units on the
battlefield. Has options.
And all of a sudden
that thousand tail watcher is a looking
a lot more attractive than it has ever
done before. Can we [__] it off of the
top?
The potential last turn a salvage
coming through.
And that single energy on the side of
Squirtle looming like an unclosing
eye staring into your soul ever
threatening that last defy.
Salvage on the BF sword.
We'll try and set up
Something you have to keep in mind for
the long term. Red Knaxle is not playing
to win the game right now. He's playing
to stop Squirtle. And that also includes
if he fully commits to taking Squirtle
off of one battlefield, the door is open
Squirtle to say, "All right, well, I'm
just going to fully reinforce my other
battlefield now. Good luck stopping me."
>> And there are other options. We talked
about the Azir being in the champion
zone as well. You hold up to seven and
then say, "It's party time." With all of
the token units coming over to the other
battlefield. So, there are options for
Squirtle to close it out should the
might all balance out in Squirtle's
favor. And what looked like a really
desperate situation for Squirtle in
another
>> Oh, the last Defy.
It's a gut-wrenching Defy.
>> But, we know the Bellow's Breath
potentially is in hand and the Defy, you
said it, the last Defy. How does this
add up for Red Knaxle? Won't be able to
clear everything for this, but is
is the calculation there?
>> But, it's got to be so incredibly tricky
because the the way the bodies are
spread out, Bellow's Breath can only
target two areas
>> Yeah.
>> at best. There are two Bellow's Breath
in hand.
>> Exactly.
>> But, that is becoming rather rather
costly. You need one more body for the
Azir to really get the job done.
>> But, to sequence it correctly, you can
do that before any showdowns happen. So,
damage will be on units assigned. You
have bodies in base to be able to clear
it out. Is the math there? Is Red
Knaxle's path to staying in this game
blowing out all of the units that
Squirtle has and essentially saying you
have to you have to be able to play
units and and look for a hold on a
following turn.
>> 24 hours of played Rift Bound weighing
on the mind of both of these players.
When the stakes are at its highest, when
options are most critical.
>> HOW HE GIVES UP
REDNAXEL DOESN'T FEEL LIKE HE CAN BREAK
THROUGH.
FROM LILLE TO UTRECHT, no player can
best Squirtle, the two-time REGIONAL
QUALIFIER CHAMPION.
>> And the relief on Squirtle's face, he
fought so hard. The streak is still
alive. He puts his name in the one of
the most exclusive clubs in Rift Bound.
>> On European soil,
Squirtle goes back-to-back with RQ wins.
Squirtle, our champion. Let's give it
over to the main stage.
>> All right then, Squirtle, you want to
join us over here, my friend?
Hello, Squirtle. All right, let's take a
deep breath, my friend. My first
question for you, how are you feeling
right now?
>> Uh the words again.
I can't it like
it was hard to believe winning one time.
Now I'm back again without dropping a
game.
It It feels unreal.
>> Well, that actually rolls me into my
next question actually. So, right now
you currently have the longest
competitive winning streak in Rift Bound
history. My My next question is, do you
ever actually lose games of Rift Bound?
>> I do. I do. In this In this uh
tournament there was a lot of uh
2-1. So, every game was rough. The
finals was super hard. I saw me losing
uh in several times.
But, yes I lose, but
>> So, you lose, but here you are currently
a champion here. My next question to
you, any shout outs? We have plenty of
people here. Anybody want to shout out?
>> Yes, of course. I want to shout out
first to my team.
That we made three people in the top
eight and there they are.
Also,
also I want to
thank you every each Spanish people
here. Even if they are not from the
team, they are cheering for me. It feels
like a big community.
Uh
also to my friends and family looking to
me in home.
Uh and that's it, I think.
>> Sounds good to me. So, Squirtle, the
longest winning streak in competitive
Rift Bound history. Our Spanish Sun
Soldier superstar. Our Spanish Sun
Soldier showstopper. And now our
two-time SUN SOLDIER CHAMPION. EVERYBODY
HERE IN THIS VENUE, PLEASE LET'S MAKE
SOME NOISE. RAISE THE ROOF FOR YOUR
UTRECHT REGIONAL QUALIFIER CHAMPION,
SQUIRTLE!
>> WOW, AFTER A weekend there of
competition, that wraps up our Utrecht
Regional Qualifier coverage. But, Rift
Bound is at home. If you want more Rift
Bound action, you haven't got TO WAIT
LONG. WE HAVE HARD BALL COMING AT you
next week. But for now, here in Utrecht,
that is our show complete. Thank you,
everyone. Thank you, everything
everyone. We'll see you next week.
>> No cutting no slack. Nobody's surviving.
Prepare could be any minute. If we can
do what we do, then we can win it. Or
this is the end like a life sentence.
Move like general, keep it consistent.
Don't let them up till they all finish.
We're going in like we back for
vengeance.
Tension is rising.
Get on your feet. Whatever we do, we
repeat. It's time to take to the
streets.
We won't stop defeat cuz this is the
danger danger danger zone. Danger danger
danger Get on your feet.
Whatever we do, we repeat. It's time to
take to the streets cuz we won't stop
defeat cuz this is